[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right do you think what do you think
should i take a night david you would
like a night on the tree yeah the night
is my favorite time of day it's also one
of my favorite pieces
you guys are like my christmas three
seconds
helping me decorate
and what do you think you guys do do you
think magnus's team have something
sparkling prepared for him today i think
both teams have something sparkling
simon
i reckon yeah i reckon that jane's got
to go for it today no more of this uh
drawing kind of nonsense
yeah so we're going to see but uh yeah
he needs that sparkle we do have the
instagram jelly is also joining us yeah
also joining us today
christmas and the holidays it's getting
close and this could be the very last
day of the world chess championship
match so welcome everyone to just24
global
[Music]
[Music]
it's that magical time of the year and
it also game 11 in dubai if magnus
carlsen wins the game today then it's
gonna be over he will defend his title
and be crowned world champion again and
back in the studio joining us ginger gm
simon williams great to have you back
it's great to be back and um i'm glad
you've prepared the tree for me uh very
nice
lovely christmas spirit going on but it
could it could be the last day
um today so it's gonna be very very
interesting i mean we saw jan
going for sort of a
damaged limitation i'd say in the last
game but he's got the white pieces now
if he doesn't win this game well it's
completely over i mean a lot of people
saying it's over already but he's got to
go for it today there's no no other
option at all and obviously you did see
uh game nine and ten from the comfort of
your sofa in england did we witness a
collapse by anna pomnyacci there
i think so i think uh in in those games
i mean you know especially this blunder
that was the last opportunity i think
for yan to do anything and i can
understand why he took a draw but it
does seem that he's a bit resigned to
his fate and now he's got to go all in
i'm kind of excited about today because
he's a great player he's an amazing
player and he's very good when he
attacks and uh hopefully now he can let
loose he's got really nothing to lose
now we've got nothing to lose you're
very dangerous yeah you said it he has
to now win
three out of the four last games to take
it to tie breaks i mean it seems almost
impossible is it now a little bit also
about saving some honor and going out
with a bang for yana pomnyacci
i i think he's just got to go
totally all in in some respects i mean
to get one win would kind of salvage uh
this world championships even if he goes
on to lose it
and you know it will also be very nice
for all his fans and for all of us
watching as well we get more chess so i
don't know what he's going to play today
it's going to be very interesting to see
his first move um so yeah it's getting
close now yep it is getting close but
first let's uh look back at the two
previous games in game nine magnus
carlson won that after a big blunder by
anna pomnyacci and in game 10 well maybe
the players started showing signs of
being a little bit tired after a very
long match
it is one e4 and
wow
bit of a surprise so jan is sticking to
the most solid move the most most solid
opening move
no sicilian no 1v6 lawrence very
surprised we described it as a must-win
situation and this is the most drawish
opening in chess
this is where black just tries to
hold the balance exchange off some
central pawns
neutralize white it will be symmetrical
it's all out defense now from the
pontiac
there's still no winning chances for
black ever
and he's the one fighting for the
equality
magnus is in a peaceful mood he doesn't
continue the game these rooks are about
to leave the board and draw any second
now magnus given the mad situation were
you surprised to see a petrov
yeah i didn't
didn't particularly think
he would do that but
i guess he was in
damage limitation mode at this point
my name is carlson it's
getting very close for him it is the
first player to reach seven and a half
points that will be the winner of his
match he now has six and a half points
so that means a win for magnus today
will secure the victory in this match
jana pomnyacci is down on three and a
half points he has to win three games to
try the match and take it to thai breaks
it seems
unlikely but to guide us through game 11
as always we have grandmaster david
howell international mattie markowski
and we're also joined by grand master
nils randelli and sweden's highest rated
player in the studio today so nice to
have you here thank you thank you nice
to be here what what do you expect game
11 janupomiyacci basically must win yeah
i think he will really as simon said he
will go all out i mean he will really
try to push very hard for the win there
is no other opportunity basically
how he will do it that's more unclear it
could be almost anything but something
unpredictable and very very risky i
think will happen yeah now obviously you
worked as a second in team magnus for
the 2018 match what is the team carlson
doing now are they done are they
finished are they relaxing now or do you
think they have prepared something fun
for us
they have definitely prepared very very
hard especially on the rest day the team
not magnus himself he has been doing i
mean he has been resting relaxing and so
on but the team has been working very
very hard i think especially considering
the
sort of
lost black game that magnus had in this
in this match it was not that great for
for magnus i think at least it looks
very very risky and they are definitely
going to
either change the line or have checked
it very very carefully so no the team is
definitely not resting all right glad to
hear that and hopefully people out there
in the world not resting as well and i
bet our viewers on social media as well
you're like guys hoping for some
explosion today yeah the whole chess
word is expecting we're hoping for
praying for a comeback from napolita
because you know we all want him to
score at some kind of point but we want
you at home to be very much part of this
experience so we're asking you to tweet
us your move suggestions your thoughts
your questions and also your selfies so
get your cameras out remember to take
your pictures in landscape format and
you can tweet us your selfies by using
the hashtag c24 live and we will feature
them on the show and there is
some sort of uh there is something going
on out uh going on out there right uh
support for diana pognachi the the
russian fans and his fans they really
want him to do well in the last few
games yeah everyone is cheering for
napomniachi and his fans have coined a
hashtag which is nepo gambit and is
actually coined by a
russian ice skater two time world
olympic medalist world champion and she
coined that up and she gave him his
support just to kind of help him steer
these difficult waters yeah the nepo
gambit you guys well maybe uh that will
help biannual pognyaccia maybe also a
rest day is exactly what needed what was
needed for him and our team on ground
they checked out dubai yesterday take a
look
behind me that is the burj khalifa that
is
828 meters tall so who said you can't
get high in dubai huh this place is just
bananas
the scale of this place has broken my
idea of what scale is this is dubai
scale they have band masters they have
super grand masters they have big and
then they have dubai big it's brand new
everything is brand new even that guy
completely new guy so i don't know
really what i'm getting everything is
super super international here i don't
really know how much is authentic arab
emirates stuff and how much is just
there just trying to please
tourists really
you know what i mean
[Music]
gotta keep on moving no matter how hard
your dogs i heard you like testing
[Music]
it's a little bit sad and we have of
course to get the big picture of this uh
crazy city and of course they have
the biggest ferris wheel in the world
that's just that's just a given right
that's just a given
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's really nice to just have a moment
of like isolated quiet almost
tranquility
to just take a step back and try to
appreciate the fact that i'm actually
here at this world chess championship i
really hope that john will give it his
all i mean i can understand if you don't
but i really hope he will give him all
here to give us some exciting chess
in this just absolutely magnificent
[Music]
all right look at that
that looks like fun they're enjoying
dubai it could be one of the last few
days and uh yeah david what do you think
the players did on the rest day do we
know anything um knowing magnus there
was a bit of sport involved i'm not sure
what else um probably actually though a
big mystery either way i think he's
trying to do something different trying
to change up the routine the last rest
day when he came back of course he'd cut
off the man bun so
um i think he's just gonna be trying to
switch off his uh switch up his routine
now the prediction challenge you guys
it's getting close to the side the
winner overall in the world in the
magnus nepo prediction challenge but
also in our internal studio battle so
you guys well this is uh standings after
game 10 david
third place noel come on third place
still very nice ivanka 41st kai 138 and
then ginger gm we actually don't know
where simon is in the world but the big
question is of course what have you
predicted for game 11 uh yeah this is
the big one i have gone for a decisive
result i just have a feeling that maybe
napoleon she's going to push extremely
hard either it's going to work very well
or it might backfire so i've gone for a
magnus win and i'm assuming that nepo
might play the same opening that we saw
a couple of days ago in the english
opening okay ivanka
yeah i kind of actually came to the same
conclusion as david i was also inspired
by the fact that in order to just go up
the rankings i need to take risks so
i've also gone for magnus winning and
it's going to be a repeat of what we saw
before all right and nels i know you're
not playing the prediction challenge but
what would you predict for today's game
uh i would probably predict the draw
actually i mean i understand that nepo
really will fight uh i mean will go all
out but in chess sometimes it doesn't
really matter like magnus is so solid
that
like uh
i think anyway despite nepal's best
efforts we will we'll probably see a
draw all right and that's good news
because that means we will get at least
one more game but let's see what it's
going to end up with game 11. it starts
in 18 minutes we're gonna have a quick
commercial break we'll be back in a
couple minutes
[Applause]
today more than ever when the world
comes together to create a better
tomorrow
it's going to be
larger
[Music]
magic
magic with music with architecture with
colors magic with celebration with your
safety
from here there and everywhere for six
whole months day and night join the
making of a new world starting october
1st
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the new chess 24 playing
experience play in light mode or dark
mode choose from a range of time
controls or create a custom game
and get paired with players from around
the world fast
enjoy a polished playing experience
while making moves on a fresh responsive
board to claim your victories train and
improve with over 80 000 puzzles and
that's not all
download now and discover what more you
can enjoy in our brand new app
now anyone can learn and improve their
chess skills with the world champion
magnus carlson
[Music]
the magnus trainer app is packed with
fun mini games in interactive training
content playable anytime anywhere get
the magnus trainer available in the app
store and google play
[Applause]
ariana pomnyacci is ready for game 11 in
dubai this could be the last time he
enters the venue in dubai the big
question is of course what will he
and his team have prepared for game 11
with the white pieces everyone expecting
jan to
go all in for a win today and uh
seconds his team of course it's a vital
part of these world championship matches
we keep talking about them all the time
so now david and oscar has attempted to
show us how it actually works what do
the seconds do and how do they help
so we're here in sunny stavanger for the
norway chess tournament actually today
magnus carlson will play his challenger
jan pontiacci in a huge battle the whole
chess world is going to be watching it's
a big day
but david there's actually another
tournament going on in stavanger these
days i'll be playing in the norwich's
open tournament and for the first time
in my whole chess career i have a second
that's me right and you're the lucky guy
i've got an important job i'm going to
be preparing you helping you get ready
for the games and what do you think of
your chances in the tournament with you
on my team i'm confident i'll uh finish
uh at the top of the table okay let's
win it all right david let's have a look
okay what about this one
okay reti great player great man
also a decent opening but i'm not sure
it suits your style that skill i think
you need something a bit more aggressive
i actually have a couple of ideas maybe
we can check them out on the computer
first perfect let's do that
i noticed that your opponent today
doesn't like to be attacked early in the
opening so you want to check out the
idea that i've got yeah let's do it
i'm ready so okay we start with our
kingspawn
and i notice your opponent always plays
the sicilian defense yeah 100 of the
time so this is predictable
and now
i think the grand prix attack is suited
to you that means bringing the knight
out
and once your opponent plays copycat
usually i play maybe bishop
b5
in this position yeah that's a decent
move as well but i think your opponent
will expect it
let's see um so one move that your
opponent definitely won't expect it's
just an innocent looking pawn move and
it's actually an idea of a friend of
ours odin and it's been played by magnus
blitz games bullet games wow just to
push a pawn forward and i think this
will really surprise and confuse your
opponent today the other
second idea is that no matter what your
opponent does you also have the option
of bringing your bishop out and on the
last move with this pawn push you've
actually created somewhere for the
bishop to hide
all right so let's see if i can
remember some of the moves so we'll
start with e4 i'm expecting your
opponent has a few moves here but i'm
expecting them to push this point yeah
unlike f3 it's always solid okay good
okay so now is the big
big moment so usually i go bishop b5
but
let's play a3 yeah and uh from my
experience when i've been playing this
testing this online most of the time
your opponent will actually push at this
point just getting ready to bring that
knight out maybe getting ready to push
in the center
and now the plan is to play b4 right
yeah just hit them where it hurts
and i don't think your opponent will
expect this to be honest and
i guess you can just recapture yeah and
if they get greedy if they try and snap
off this pawn then already they're
losing
really yeah white
has a winning position already it looks
really innocent but now you gain so much
time with your pieces you bring the
bishop out hit the knight this looks
strong
black can't even play a5 right because
of the pin
with the rooks exactly they can't even
defend their knight so they have to
retreat and
yeah this looks so strong though the
real bishop stop them from castling yeah
but there's a winning move here can you
find it asking
[Music]
this looks quite strong yeah it's a
killer you're basically jumping in well
giving a deadly check and black's king
is already defenseless now we can pick
up the queen yeah
and check hitting the queen as well it's
game over yeah and then even take back
probably on a1 yeah if you get this in
your game today i will love it
that would be perfect
we've played it out on the board we've
gone through it on a computer now it's
time to test whether it's in your memory
let's play a game in our minds knight d6
jack
king f8
knight takes p7 check and you're winning
you know all of my heart already perfect
good luck
thank you
so the moment has arrived asko how are
you feeling a bit nervous but i'm
usually nervous before the first game of
a tournament but
our preparation really helped me to to
get in the zone and hopefully
it becomes valuable in the opening for
sure some nerves are good but yeah
remember it's all about confidence
keeping yourself keep being aggressive
you got this
[Music]
oh there's too much
work look at that david as a second
giving out some deep dark secrets there
yeah i was just saying to you guys uh
i've won countless games with this exact
opening online and uh yeah i've just
given it all away for free now yeah so
now everyone just go back look over and
then you have a perfect opening for all
your games and well nails is this
what it looks like when you work
especially maybe for a world
championship match
slightly different yeah it's slightly
different i would have i would say but i
mean there are some parts of it that
actually are
very close to reality like like what
not like trying to figure out what uh
the opponent's weaknesses are with the
help of of your team and try to figure
out which openings to play that suits
against this style and then we are not
talking about only making like the best
moves or the best uh openings but we are
talking about
uh making moves that are the most
unpleasant for the opponent so it's
actually a very different thing and for
this it's it's very useful to have this
whole team that can really go much
deeper than you would be able to do in
let's say a normal tournament when you
have to play a new opponent every day
well with the help from david how did it
actually go for oscar let's uh go down
to dubai uh we see magnus arriving the
venue he's going to have the black
pieces on the black suit today magnus
carlsen he can end the match today with
a win and uh tanya is standing where the
players will be fighting it out today
hey everyone we are inside the
auditorium the playing hall this is
where the spectators will be and right
up front we can see the glass box where
just in a few moments the players will
walk in for game 11 currently there's
maurice ashley inside just doing last
minute checks making sure that
everything is fine a big day for the
chess world coming up yanna pannashi the
pressure is on he starts with white he
needs to win this game which means he
needs to take big risk and big risk well
that means magnus carlsen might get his
shot to win and if he does that's world
championship over magnus carlsen could
potentially win his fifth world
championship title today
pressure is on what we are in for is a
wild game what will yan's team have up
there see what have they prepared for
this very critical game we're going to
find out the importance of coaches the
importance of seconds is so crucial and
we also have with us asking to talk more
about that ask it what was it like in
stavanger
it was great i mean i had a lovely time
working on chess with david
unfortunately some of his preparations
didn't help me
in the games i played but later on in
the tournament i actually
had a game with the opening we prepared
and i think for players at my level it's
not about necessarily learning all the
different openings but maybe get some
new ideas on how to
understand different positions and
expand on your understanding of the game
it's definitely a lot different because
when you're working with the computer
then you only know what to move but why
is that move made is when you need a
coach to understand that exactly and i
have a grandmother that's 90 and she can
also use stock fish you know and see
white is plus one but you have a very
good point it's all about understanding
why and that's uh that's where a coach
can be helpful uh to to broaden your
understanding of certain positions and
the game in in general absolutely asking
we've got a very critical game 11 coming
up what can we expect from team napolita
i discussed this with you and judith
polgar at breakfast today and and we
kind of agreed that
nepali actually got a good opening in
his last white game with the the move c4
and i think he and his team are
confident that that opening can be
played again today and push for the win
after the opening
he's got to do what he's got to do that
is his only chance to create chances
with the white pieces 1c4 is what many
of us expect because as askil pointed
out that's why he got his best position
we'll see what happens back to you guys
in the studio
oh it's getting exciting yeah thank you
so much tanya and oscar the game starts
in about five minutes and we hear oscar
talking about using a second during his
uh obviously lower level tournament
great help for him uh he talks about the
style thing has that been an issue for
for john in this world championship
match that his seconds they haven't
really given him openings that fit his
style yep exactly it's not even about
magnus's style because magnus is hard to
pin down so it's uh it's been more about
himself uh for yan and he definitely
feels like he's gone against his natural
instincts in with many of his opening
choices for example nibbling away in the
royal opens with white i mean it works
he's still a strong player he can handle
it but against magnus he's not going to
make any headway and petra off with
black very solid very passive it feels
like he's trying to become someone else
and
he didn't get here by doing that
he got to the kind of pinnacle of world
chess just by embracing himself and
being dynamic and yeah he's maybe failed
to capitalize and fail to use his own uh
his own strengths and you noticed you
told me after we saw the rival footage
of janna pognachi that for the first
time he did not arrive with his
main second vladimir putkin yeah and
sergey karikan wasn't there who
previously came with him a couple of
days ago um jan just turning up with his
girlfriend maybe he doesn't want the
pressure of any other chess players
yeah it's just him now is it a sign also
though that he's going to play his style
his opening just his own work today i
hope so yeah nils you think that's true
it's very hard to save the case any
correlation but
yeah i mean by this point
it does make sense for him to go back to
his sort of uh truer self definitely
because i mean he has been trying this
other style it has not really worked out
and uh well
i mean especially considering the moment
in the match like if he's not going to
try like his own stuff now then when he
will he ever do it yeah so
yeah it's an interesting thought yeah
and then we did see in the video with
david and oscar
how they actually prepared oscar to play
these openings that david had found for
him and i'm really curious about that
because one thing is of course finding
these openings and preparing them for
the two players in the match but how do
they actually remember all that stuff
yeah this actually is also to a large
degree uh dependent on the second it's
actually one of our like very important
a very important part of our job because
we have so much information like it's
four or five people with super engines
we are checking for like 24 hours there
is no way that magnus will be able to
absorb all this knowledge that literally
no chance at all but what we have to do
is highlight like the most important
points like what are the key points what
does he really need to remember and this
choice we have to make and then we have
to present it to him wow and that's uh
that's a very very important
part of being of the job of being a
second which is i think very hard for
non-seconds to grasp how important it is
but it's a very relevant question and
also i would like to add that it's
especially for magnus because magnus
style is a little bit
less dependent on concrete long lines in
general which means that he prefers to
spend
even less time like rehearsing these
sort of positions or these sort of long
lines he wants to get out he wants to
get out as quickly as possible and then
also we have to
present it even more clear with even
less detail but even more sort of you
know strict yeah what he needs to know
so it's a very
interesting task yeah because we really
get down to like
the basic point of what the position is
about because the rest he will simply
not remember yeah
it's a very useful for yourself as well
obviously it's a very strong chess
player to spend
i don't know like six months i don't
know how long you spent before the match
in 2018 working with magnus to actually
use that those openings and the
preparations yourself yeah definitely
definitely i mean just to see see magnus
work is of course like greatly
beneficial for your own chess it's just
i mean even uh
sort of you absorb it without even
understanding it yourself immediately
yeah you just sort of pick up stuff
along the way all the time every day wow
very nice all right well game 11 it's
getting close let's see if the players
arrive
very shortly magnus with a win with the
black pieces today will decide the match
he's going to defend his title and
receive the crown
as a winner of this world championship
match and you might if that happens if
this match is over after 11 games
would that be a shock for you if we have
told you that before the match started
it's going to take 11 games yeah
absolutely if you'd said 11 games and
then there would be three losses
by napoleon i would have been totally
shocked because i kind of expected it
would be pretty close but i did say on
record that i did think the magnus
carlsen would win the classical portion
yep so um
remember as well five draws at the
beginning of the match it was tied it
was really close napoli actually had
lots of chances himself and uh for it to
go downhill so quickly i think that is
the biggest surprise yeah the margins
have been small after jana pogba lost
game
six in the match magnus after that
winning two more games we are waiting
for them to arrive jana pogniacci with
the white pieces and you guys have told
me you are expecting
something fun from him today maybe the
british again the english english sorry
english english british yeah yeah
messing that up and i also see on
twitter that uh people are also thinking
that maybe napoli actually will just
throw caution to the win and start off
with a small little move one b3 a cowboy
opening
i'm pretty sure it's just adeban
yeah if it was magnus with the white
pieces maybe a slight chance yeah um
anything's possible definitely and the
problem she needs to surprise magnus in
some way or other whether that's on move
one whether that's on move 10 somewhere
down
down the more main line who knows but
i know simon's expecting and hoping for
some gambits maybe i saw simon put the
grub opening up on the board over there
which is one g4 which would never ever
happen but it's the type of thing that
napoleon she might consider just to
shock his opponent yeah his style here
yeah now
uh in the 2018 match nelson did did the
team feel that you were most successful
with the white or black pieces for
magnus
uh definitely with black that's uh
what's so uh
i mean uh
strange or sim because actually i was a
second also for a 2016 match and that
one match was much more similar to this
one yeah whereas in 2018 it was sort of
opposite that it was a bigger advantage
okay now they have started what are we
seeing on the board okay it's one e4 no
english opening that was just a one-off
and i also mentioned to ivanka just
before the game started if not an
english opening i thought maybe the
italian but uh i voted for english in
the prediction challenge so
those points have disappeared
well technically it was others it was
others yeah
and right now you will see magnus copy
and uh repeat what he's done so far seen
this before we've seen this before pawn
to e5 white knight coming out hitting
the black pawn in the center and black
defense will we see another royal
personals what do you think i think is
the italian
okay interesting very interesting wow so
this has become super trendy over the
last few years magnus has played it with
both colours it's been one of his movies
any times in multiple to jump is just or
now will the knight come out to the g5
square okay so no white doesn't go on
the attack with his knight which is a
very popular move at all levels
at lower level lots of games are won in
that fashion but no just normal
development
and uh this position fond memories for
you on this uh in this opening nils
the italian game how so i don't know
i i have played this position yeah many
times with with both colors and it was
also an opening that in the 2016 match
between magnus and kayaking it was
featured in many many of magnus's whites
games ah so was it in the the berlin
mostly came in sergey's white games it
was
they played a couple of berlins first
with magnus white and then he switched
to italian and then he played italian in
a few games and also in the tie break i
see so they had a lot of games in
italian but then in all those games
uh magnus was white so
well okay so we obviously know sergey
karjakin is in yan's team is that
something that he maybe then to help
prepare possibly but also it is we have
to understand this was five years ago it
was by modern standards a different age
yeah so i don't think that uh it has
that much uh relevance for this match
yeah okay
what do you think of the game in this
opening what can we expect we can expect
a lot of pieces to stay on the board for
a long time i think that's the ponies
strategy he just wants to keep maximum
tension there will be some maneuvering
at some point um as nils mentioned the
theory in this opening is evolving all
the time there are small nuances it's
all about different move orders so for
example white might have three or four
different useful moves but you can play
it in any different order and that will
completely change um the nature of the
position often so
um yeah i've got traumatic memories and
in this opening from recent history i
lost on the black side to alareza
farouza in the ground swiss
and uh it was actually in this exact
position so
we'll see whether that uh this game
continues down that path okay but uh
either way this is very topical this is
well known both sides will have analyzed
this very deeply
and uh white is the first to castle
black delaying that decision for a while
there's no rush okay so we'll have to
see then how long this game follows your
game against feruzia
that's right yeah and uh as i mentioned
that game didn't end well for me from
the black side but from the opening it
was relatively balanced
and okay jan just moves this rook across
there a very natural move
and what do you think we'll see magnus
do castle the king
push the black each pawn one square
forward i think most probably he will
castle uh castle the king now but
again it's as as you mentioned then this
is an important point here you have so
many moves that you can play in so many
move orders yeah for instance now he
drops back the bishop this is very rare
to do in this specific moment okay
it's extremely rare but it's very uh
common that you do it one or two moves
later
and uh it's also a very common thing
that then after the let's say he castles
on the next move they will have gotten
the same position by different move
orders so this is a slight surprise
but
it's it's quite likely that
nepal will now think for 10 minutes what
are the differences
then he will make a move magnus will
castle and then nepo will start to play
fast again okay because he will be back
in exactly but it's a typical small uh
move of the tree that is quite uh is
that a good idea to to put them in
sometimes in the opening where there's
no danger to mixing up the move order a
little bit definitely do you have the
open and spend some time but now we see
that nepa this is now
approaching very interesting uh
from a theoretical sense because
uh
this move with the knight on the rim
it's very specifically directed against
magnus's last move like he's trying to
go with the knight forward
to to the b5 square and then he will hit
the bishop on a7 and this is a move that
would make absolutely no sense had
magnus not dropped the bishop back okay
why is that because then knight would
not attack the bishop
like when when the knight comes uh comes
forward exactly yeah so it's a direct
reaction against magnus's last move and
now we are on completely
i say independent territory now we will
actually be opening exactly oh wow i
mean we have seen this position a few
times in practice but
my guess is
if i would have to guess maybe 10 games
instead of
2000 with short castle so it's uh it's
very very rare
but it's definitely uh it seems like
nepo is is prepared for it
and uh
it's interesting to see how how well
magnus is prepared or if this bishop a7
was intended as as a big surprise
yeah exactly exactly and
yeah this is almost uh guaranteed to be
white sex move if he gets time but if we
just call the bluff and do castle as
black um trying to transpose back into
main lines you think the knight will
come forward attacking the bishop and if
the bishop moves again yeah the bishop
will move again but i guess magnus could
argue that this knight later will be
misplaced for example if black gets time
if white is just a bit slow here then
black can maybe move the knight and gain
some time against the white knight and
black black has lost time with a bishop
white has lost time with the knights and
it's unclear who that favors um so
there's lots to consider here whether
magnus can allow this knight to jump
forward i mean he probably has to allow
it but uh magnus if he doesn't castle he
might try and find a more useful and
more urgent move example he could move
his knight just pre-pre-empting the
white knight jumping forward just so the
black horns can step forward he can
think about developing this bishop maybe
offering a trade at some point or bring
it even the whole way out because white
hasn't stopped this lots and lots of
choice here for magnus and uh i just
have a question for you because i'm just
looking at this position on the ghs
website and i'm just checking the
current database and uh
it's only been played twice before and
both those kind of positions they
revolved around the white bishop
actually developing to the g5 square
and so
you see that black has reacted with
actually pushing the rook's pawn one
square forward to the h6 just to stop
that idea
and uh when black just ignored it and
just castled then uh a very strong grand
master actually andre vela keaton did
develop that bishop there you know pin
and maybe win
this tension actually is really annoying
for black and if you ever try and kick
this bishop back and to try and break
this pin then it does commit your pawn
structure you have to push forward and
sometimes what can consider a sacrifice
a knight for two pawns just to open up
the black king but even if white doesn't
then yeah it's never clear whether this
king is weak or whether black is
actually the one attacking later on with
some porn pushes so
um will we see magnus castle nope he's
gone for the move ivanka suggested he
may be just slightly afraid of castling
because the white bishop could jump out
instead magnus has pushed his pawn
forward to cover the g5 square
okay interesting can we say anything
about the two player's ambition in this
game yet or is it too early to call
i think it's maybe too early to call um
napoli actually obviously he's ambitious
he's keeping all the pieces on the board
something that we maybe wouldn't see in
the royal pairs or in
some other openings
but then again it's still very very
early days and uh
this type of position it might look
balanced it might look relatively
symmetrical but there's so much life and
there's so much potential for both sides
yeah most probably i would predict that
this what magnus is playing now is what
he would have played had never played
the italian opening in any of the
previous white games it's i don't think
that he has specifically changed into
this setup for this game because he's
seen the lead he's just playing his
preparation for the match the the lines
that they were checking the the months
prior to
to it yeah we saw that a couple of days
ago um when jan played the english
opening despite the fact magnus was
already a couple of points up in the
match he didn't play the most solid
reply he's played the most principled
reply the most ambitious just because
as mentioned that's what they prepared
beforehand yeah coming back magnus
carlsen leaving will be a quick reply
now by um
do you think he is still in some some
sort of preparation definitely
definitely yeah
i'm not so sure it's hard to say because
knight a3 white's last move putting the
white knight on the edge of the board is
the type of move that if your opponent
retrieves the bishop you just play on
autopilot in a way and yan occasionally
does bluff
he's done that before yeah i think it's
it's very unlikely that you make this
knight a3 move if you are if you don't
know what you are doing actually yeah
because uh
in most in almost all other lines the
knight goes instead towards the center
so this is a it's a very specific
reaction and if you make such specific
reactions uh it's usually because you
know what you are doing
on the other hand nepo has been
playing quite fast
in situations where
most people would have thought a bit
more so far in the match
and it could be a case of this but i
think it's simply too early in the game
for uh for that i mean he uh
he should really be
knowing what he's doing here
yeah we'll find out a lot i think over
the next few moves right about yan and
whether he's gone deep with a plan
um whether he's analyzed more deeply
here okay yeah and uh do you think that
uh napoleon will
play this night jump to attack the
bishop as you've highlighted do you
think he'll play
a little bit more in ivan sarich's style
which is a croatian gm who just put his
knight onto the c2 square
okay what do you think tough question
i'm going to pass that one to nils
because it's too difficult
yeah i think i think the knight will
will go to b5 okay at some point the
only question would be then
do you do it immediately or do you make
another move first but i don't really
see what the other move would be
currently so current position yeah yeah
i mean it's really the most natural move
i think
to jump forward yeah yeah and the other
plan your vanco mentioned is to drop the
knight back with the idea of trading off
these dark squared bishops at some point
for example if black castles
i guess this is what uh evan sarrich
played here ivanka yeah he did the
bishop forward and the argument is that
the white knight now is nicely placed in
the center of the board these two pieces
are very flexible
and uh this would just lead to more
maneuvering i would say roughly balanced
nothing too special
maybe this is solid but uh not as
ambitious as the other move the other
night jump exactly for for jan here i
mean the
the thing he's trying to create is some
sort of imbalance like uh either in the
pawn structure or in the material
distribution like trading a bishop for a
night night for some sort of imbalance
and just trading the dark squared
bishops most likely black will then also
be able to trade the other set of
bishops we will get the position
with only knights and the pawn structure
almost identical
there is simply not enough imbalance to
create like real uh real winning winning
chances i think so uh he's
looking for uh for ways to keep it more
let's say complicated
so maybe instead you know you take the
santa you put the knight somewhere
either jumping to b5 or c2 and then you
push in the center my favorite move
exactly yeah exactly and uh maximum
tension i guess one question though is
if you do push in the center you do have
to kind of sometimes consider this
bishop coming out and here i'm not so
sure maybe black should get castled
first but um this might be a bit of an
annoying pin once you've pushed forward
in the center you can
find yourself in a situation where you
can't keep the tension anymore i was
also wondering in the current position
if white wants to stop this plan if
white pushes forward a pawn just to
control the square to stop the black
bishop or knight using does black get
ambitious here yeah i was going to say
that i always get nervous about that
kind of porn move ever since i saw i
think was it levon aronian he just wiped
the floor against the vladimir kramnik
yeah i think it was the other way
the other way around
the floor
exactly that was in the world but it's a
very common idea it's one of these
that's why this composition is so
popular on the highest level and also
why it's so complicated because this
move that black played the pawn to h6
it's a very natural move to stop the
white's bishop from coming to g5 and
white plays exactly the same move h3
with exactly the same id and it could be
even a big mistake because black has not
castled yet because the pawn can come
forward and this is like
most players i think at least on a
little bit lower levels they would make
these moves without really going so
deeply into these nuances but the
stronger players they are
like there are so many levels of each of
these small small looking moves and from
the outside you would think that it
doesn't matter you just make them in any
move order but i trust you there can
easily go one week on each of these
nuances so this is like don't try this
at home kind of opening if you're
playing a game tonight with your family
well if you have an open entrance
started it for half year maybe don't try
it at home but most people don't luckily
so
and it's it's funny just opening the
italian game with white developing the
bishop to this square this is what we
would maybe say is a beginner's opening
this is one of the first openings you
learn in chess but then again it's also
one of the most complicated uh
complicated openings in chess so yeah
it's a real paradox so what would you
recommend for beginners to chess what
opening should they just learn and
stick to for the first you know year or
so
what opening is the easiest to get some
sort of
we're going to get so much blame if we
suggest things
and actually i would think what they are
playing now is not uh it's not a bad one
because both sides have developed
exactly yeah you take center you take
the center exactly you castle i mean
magnus can castle on the next move if he
wants to yeah it's already like
most of the successes you need in the
opening stage yeah for both players
at home yeah if you learn it now and if
you enjoy this opening you can use it
for life it works at every level right
beginner club level even world
championship level it's actually a good
one
but i must say most people start off
with a copycat variation
which is you know you you develop your
king's pawn they copy you move your
knight they protect the pawn and then it
continues
until someone gets a trap in
usually
because white starts first exactly
um to avoid that trap i always say like
push the push with the queen's pawn i'm
a big fan of this queen's pawn push
and uh meanwhile jan
thinking for a bit longer so was his
night move knight a3 was that just
kind of playing one more move beyond
opening preparation just to kind of
get it down on the board or has he
indeed gone deeper maybe just trying to
recall something he studied before
as we mentioned a bit of an odd move
order an unusual move order from magnus
carson and maybe that's just thrown jan
off slightly yeah i mean we also
actually cannot rule out that it's the
last move that threw him off because he
played his night move quickly magnus
replied with the pawn one step forward
on the side and now he's thinking so
i mean you said that this was played uh
before this pawn move
uh but it could be that it was not the
main focus of uh of jan's preparation
maybe he expected magnus to castle
immediately it could be it it certainly
could be i mean it's only ever been
played once before so it's not likely
that you would have dedicated all your
efforts into quite a rare line no
definitely definitely and this of course
is all it's the the signum of magnus
opening preparation in general that he's
he likes he would not avoid the the
entire opening because he likes the sort
of classical
uh way to play like right that's what he
said kids chat like develop your pieces
get your kin and so on
he likes it because he's sort of a
traditional player but he really likes
to have his own twist and preferably as
early as possible and this bishop move
definitely is very very typical of
magnus
approach to
openings yeah we should mention as well
that this isn't jan's first choice
opening he was mostly relying on the roy
lopez for the first half of the match
then it wasn't his second choice opening
because that was the english and now
this is his third choice the italian so
he can't have gone that deeply into all
the nuances of these kind of when to put
the bishop back when to develop the
knight to a3 all these uh all these
little details so
i should also mention i think i can off
the top of my head pick out two
instances in the match where as soon as
jan was out of opening theory he
continued playing the next move fast and
then he realized oh maybe it wasn't so
accurate and then he had a long think so
there was a couple of games with white
where he prepared extremely deeply
deeply to move 20. and then magnus
played something he wasn't sure about
and then he reacted and then suddenly it
was just equal so um yeah so jan maybe
with this knight a3 move just playing by
instinct
maybe he hasn't gone that deeply
it's quite interesting those games that
uh they earlier played especially the
ones that you're talking about where
napoleon has been playing with the white
pieces and could have pushed a little
bit harder they've been thrown to the
computers
and now the computers have gotten a hold
of it and started playing this out so i
just love that concept
these are testing these positions out
computer versus computer
and mostly the results been the same
right i think so
and uh interesting tweets out there in
the twitter sphere
yeah and we do
we have something wrong here you might
go we should actually talk about that we
should we have some fantastic viewers
all around the world and we're so
grateful for every single one of you uh
but one in particular
came to oslo yesterday yeah
from finland came to the studio and
brought for us some uh finished
chocolate from fazer so they sound
delicious would you like one i would
love one we'll add to the festive
spirits yeah so thank you very much
and
maybe later
very good very exciting flavors david
milk chocolate dark chocolate and
blueberry truffle i'm scared if i have
one i'll have the whole box
well thank you very very much yeah so
nice wow
holiday spirit you guys getting presents
already well jana pognyarchy thinking
for 11 minutes now that's uh that's new
it seems he's been playing so fast like
up until like move
20. previously on the match maybe he's
upset that he's not getting any
christmas presents right now
um yeah i mean as nils mentioned it's
quite possible that he'll be thinking
for a while here and then maybe he'll
speed up later when he gets exactly more
familiar this is what typically happens
also in this position he knows what
position he wants five six moves later
he just doesn't remember the most
accurate way to get there like she he
knows the queen should be there bishop
should be there let's say knight should
be there
but was it the queen first or was it the
bishop first or was it the night first
and then he's really trying does it make
a difference and so on and that's that's
especially in an opening like uh like
the italian here this sort of slow
where you can make all these move orders
and so on it happens very very often and
i've been sitting myself many many times
trying to recall
and that's
because it's even more annoying because
if you don't have any clue you will
think for yourself from scratch and you
will make some normal moves but if you
know specifically which position you
want
then you really want to be able to get
there yeah and then you really don't
want to make the wrong move order and
then you can spend eternities without
getting anywhere that's why sometimes
better to know nothing at all so you can
approach the position fresh
rather than knowing too much and then
getting confused and maybe aiming for
the wrong position by accident yeah i
mean it sounds like uh it sounds like a
joke that it's better to know less or
even nothing but it's actually very true
yeah
it's it's actually very very true
especially in this kind of positions
yeah we've all been there confused
ourselves by accident yes we have this
expression actually in in the english
women's teams a little more
a little knowledge it's a little bit
dangerous
and uh exactly for the same reasons you
know you end up playing that plan even
if you get surprised you play the plan
that you prepared at home and you don't
necessarily think about the consequences
so yeah the pitfalls of preparation
sometimes it's good to freestyle it but
uh well is that something you aren't
sure to have done you know when he maybe
lost game six
and game eight just completely
freestyled yeah
uh possibly or is that too dangerous
maybe what i would have done but that's
why i'm not here playing championship
yeah freestyling is dangerous it could
go very right you could be inspired on
the day but it takes a lot of energy to
freestyle especially if you're making
things up from move five it takes a lot
of energy you burn a lot of time on the
clock
it can backfire as well so at this level
i think
yeah freestyling maybe
not on the menu yeah and
i have a few questions for you from our
viewers and
the first one is from felix rodriguez
who asks
why is the world championship not held
between the champion and the one who is
highest on the rating list
why a tournament of candidates if the
achievement of reaching the top of that
list is a major achievement
so uh this is an interesting question
definitely why not just have a cut-off
point and go
number two on the rating list or number
one
let's get it very good question i guess
rating can be manipulated in a way you
could play some players get rating by
playing in strong tournaments testing
themselves against the best some achieve
rating by maybe playing slightly lower
rated tournaments and just beating lower
rated players so
rating is a sign of maybe form but
it's not necessarily the be-all and
end-all and i guess you could also reach
a high
rating and then just stop playing for a
year sort of yeah but it's also nice
that you have some tournaments that sort
of has uh
a little bit more importance like now we
have this for instance candidates
autonomous that is such a such a nice
event to follow it's so exciting
everyone is preparing so hard for it so
many nerves like if all tournaments were
only like we were only playing for the
rating then all of tournaments would be
the same importance and then
you would lose some some of this element
so i think it's a nice
it's a nice mix however what they did
now uh
for the candidates they removed for the
next candidates they removed rating
spots whatsoever exactly eight players
used to be two by rating like the two
highest rated pairs and they removed
them and that is maybe taking the other
way a little bit too extreme especially
in my opinion
uh because what if fabiano cariana
didn't win the turn now he did exactly
win a tournament so he is qualified for
candidates but it would be a big shame
right if fabiano cariana didn't play the
candidates
exactly so that i i thought was a very
nice balance to have for instance what
they had two spots out of eight yeah and
but
no spots at all that feels a bit uh that
feels strange yeah in the other way yeah
i guess there was also some reaction i
mean our good friend anish giri um in
2019 i think he he didn't play in the
ground swiss because he wanted to
maintain his rating it was too much risk
involved by playing if he lost some
rating he wouldn't have qualified and i
think if we rely too much on rating then
maybe it just does dissuade players from
taking part in certain tournaments but i
agree with nils there should be some
importance attached to it but not too
much it shouldn't be the only thing
and there's only now two spots left in
the candidates 2022 the two top two
finishes in the feed a grand prix
2022 will you guys play
so uh
it's a bit of a sore question for me so
actually in the grand swiss of course
the top two qualified for the candidates
and then places three to eight qualify
for the grand prix and guess where i
finished guys on tiebreak
i finished in ninth so um that is harsh
i'm hoping there's a reserve list and
someone drops out but uh if not then
i'll happily just watch the watch the
event it is i mean a lot of strong
players a lot of young hungry players
actually but are those the only who get
to play the grand prix
um there's some qualified from the world
cup as well some qualified i think maybe
by rating so yeah yeah it's a variety of
players and those will be some exciting
games to watch okay okay yep because uh
what is it seven players is confirmed uh
magnus or young no six players of course
magnus zoryam um uh team rajabo wild
card young christophe duda winner of the
world cup karjakin runner up in world
cup frusia and coriana from the grand
swiss so who should be the next two
players then who would uh you know the
chess world hope for
he's maybe like ding lyren should be in
there maybe loren for sure yeah yeah
maybe levon yeah and if you're mvl yeah
actually basically yeah in two spots and
so many elite players to choose from yes
yeah
wesley wesley
do you think he should get a spot
because he's like the fisher
world random champion
world random yeah
title but actually i meant the official
random yeah
um
not really no it's too much of a deal
too much of a difference we have a movie
you guys yeah and he won that title a
few years ago long pulse
moves his back his knight backwards okay
and ivanka mentioned that this has been
played before um this is maybe a more
typical maneuver than jumping the knight
forward
simply because
the black bishop isn't always available
to be attacked
but slightly surprising the more solid
approach there from yan in a must-win
situation yeah it's very timid i mean
especially if his idea is to follow up
with the trading the bishops which i
guess it is
it's actually not
that it's uh that's one idea certainly
which is on the board oh it's on the
board okay actually it's the most
typical plan um once this knight reaches
the c2 square to support the bishop on
e3 and we will see a trade of these
bishops now we'll magnus rate it or
most likely
most likely yeah but he doesn't need to
do it necessarily not entirely because
isn't it a point that you know then the
white knight will be quite good so
wouldn't it be nicer for magnus is if
the the white bishop came to his
territory definitely but on the other
hand
when if nepal will take on the next
movie you have to take either with the
rook
which makes it harder for the rook to
get into the center later on you have to
use one more
most probably to go go back again or you
have to take with the knight when you
move away from the center
so it's sort of that's also bad yeah
okay so it doesn't sound like this
necessarily is a good trade for magnets
no but on the other hand he gets rid of
one set of pieces which moves the game
closer to equality yeah there is one
small point that we can we can say that
makes the the trade somewhat logical for
ariane and that is that magnus has spent
one move dropping the bishop back which
means that he has lost some time
especially if he takes
on e3 so this would have been
even less tempting for white if the
bishop hadn't already lost some time so
in that sense it's logical but it seems
still uh
quite soft i have to say yeah yeah just
to illustrate your point nils uh for
example here if black had castled for
example if white trades the bishops off
now black has moved the bishop once but
he's happy to trade off but uh yeah just
a few moves later well actually here we
saw the black bishop drop back so he's
lost a move with this bishop and in the
current position if we fast forward and
then yeah he would have lost another
move with the bishop if he does capture
so yep you're right kaya i actually
think maybe we should do a bet here but
i'm not sure i'm not sure which is uh
which is correct bishop takes bishop or
you wait to let black uh let white
capture on his terms for example if
magnus waits then just to show nils's
point either the black rook will be
misplaced on the square maybe it needs
to drop back later to centralize itself
or the black knight will be on the rim
which is not ideal either so if he waits
what will he then do
that's the question i think that's
exactly what magnus is asking him
himself right now he knows that if he
captures the white knight will take back
and white has two strong pieces but then
again uh what's a useful waiting move i
mean maybe you bring the rook across
maybe
the other tempting option is to offer
the trade of bishops
but this is always risky and i know
magnus himself this pawn structure he
prefers being on the white side right
um he's slightly reluctant to accept
this pawn structure with black because
long term
you lose a lot of flexibility they might
become targets these pawns in an end
game white will always have a tiny
advantage so and of course he's watched
the queen queen's gambit yeah he's
watched the queen's government and he's
and he's uh
against these uh double pawns in a game
against uh vishyana and yes i remember i
was just shocked i thought wishing
island was a little bit better in that
position but magnus played around those
pawns and showed how inflexible they are
because they can't move forward and the
critical game against sergey karjakin
in 2016 the game that magnus won to
strike back was against these pawns yes
that's true is that one of your best
memories as a second nils that that was
very nice yeah i mean
yeah that relieved a lot of pressure
from
yeah
from the team game 10 was it when he
made the comeback
yes i think it was game 10 yeah because
he lost with white in game a yes is it
quite emotional being a second i mean by
emotional i mean like oh yeah is that
anger
happiness uh the whole array i mean it's
very tense especially
when luckily like it's only been these
two games where magnus has been behind
like night because he lost game eight it
was game nine and ten until he won so
it's only been like two days but uh yeah
there was definitely more i mean you
could definitely feel more pressure
on the team like
and actually like the clock was on yeah
you had to win one of the following
games to uh to equalize the match
uh on the other hand one thing that is
actually quite nice with being a second
in regards to tension is that uh we are
not really following the game's life
because then you sleep then we are
sleeping because we have to be fresh to
work uh in between the games yeah so the
only time when we really have like
complete time off it's when they are
playing because then anyway we cannot do
anything yeah so
like especially these long games i mean
if you follow it live it's very very
stressful but if you just sleep you wake
up and you check the results so it's not
so bad yeah
and that i know in
in 2016 you guys were in norway right we
were in
yeah but 2018.
where were you thailand in thailand that
must be so much nicer that was very nice
yeah especially some of the other
members of the team really thought it
was a bit too cold and dark yeah in
norway in november
oh wow
is very very nice it's very very nice in
the summer but it's also a very very
long time to be there alone for one
month in november yeah with the same
group of guys yeah yeah yeah yeah no we
we got along very well but uh yeah a
little bit too long probably
especially compared to thailand yeah now
one question i'm kind of maybe you don't
need to answer but uh i've been reading
some historical books about uh
gary kasparov's match against anatoly
karpov the long match that was
eventually cancelled and they're the
seconds actually they've written an
account of what happened and they say
you know sometimes when things didn't go
well there would be like this volcano of
emotion coming from gary right directed
at his seconds and his second just like
we're we're united by the common cause
of helping gary win the world
championship so let it slide yeah is it
kind of like this kind of football
manager situation i mean it's it's a
little bit different for us because as a
team
well i haven't gotten any confirmation
of where they are now the team but it
would surprise me greatly if they are on
on location i mean yeah probably
because they liked what it was with you
guys in thailand right so they want to
keep the team in a different time zone
exactly for the sleeping reason yes
exactly and that
in that regard it's it's it's also quite
nice because all this tension that can
be like we are simply not there like
this is actually uh peter heine
nielsen's job to handle uh handle this
and to take care of magnus and to uh
sort out these things yeah yeah and then
we are just sort of doing the work we
are we are being told so
uh
so for us as sort of remote seconds it's
not really an issue in that sense it's
all on ph shoulders yeah oh
have there ever been any incidents of
magnus losing his temper or the second's
getting emotional getting too stressed
or in general is the vibe quite chill
just focused purely on the technical
stuff we are focusing purely on on the
technical stuff yeah but no of course
it's uh it's tense especially as i said
when he was trailing in the match then
it's really uh the pressure is on but
from our perspective
i mean it doesn't make that much like we
are trying to come up with the best
ideas the most dangerous ideas the ideas
that we're giving the highest chance of
winning yeah and for that it doesn't
really matter that much whether he's
behind or not like we are just i mean we
are professionals we are trying to do
our job in the best possible so that the
fact that he lost game eight didn't
affect at all the opening choice for the
next two games
no it affected the opening choice uh
somewhat but it didn't really affect the
sort of the way we work let's see
and i have to put to you a question by
anizan maruf who asks on twitter
does the second prepare all the major
openings for instance a reply against e4
c4 d4 etc or just what the opponents
play
uh
so just what i mean it's tricky isn't it
yeah typically
only what the opponent plays yeah but
nowadays
all opponents are able to play
everything yeah so you anyway you have
to prepare everything wow but like if we
could make sure that okay netflix is
only going to play e4 in the match there
would be no reason to prepare anything
else but simply you cannot go to a world
championship match it's 14 games you
have seven games with white you cannot
have prepared only one first move no it
doesn't make sense and therefore also as
an opponent you have to expect
everything so
i guess the only time is if uh
was playing
i think even machiavelli would
mix it up yeah it would mix it up a
little bit that would be interesting
yeah you always need a plan b in any
situation right exactly exactly how
about uh each individual role are you
just focused on one opening for example
is magnus saying okay nils focus on the
italian or focus on the spanish or is it
kind of everyone has different ideas
they all contribute do you all kind of
brainstorm together
it's a little bit of a mix and i think
also this greatly depends from team to
team like okay now i've been working for
magnus but other top players have a
little bit uh different uh systems uh
but generally speaking if you have some
you know some really uh like
interest or some line which lies very
close to your heart you are going to
spend more time on that but it's never
going to be the case
that one guy is like solely responsible
for a specific opening no it always goes
through all the people just okay you
have some favorites you spend a little
bit more time with that but everybody is
contributing to everything
i guess it's better that way just in
case one person's in charge of one
opening that openly goes wrong then they
get all the blame it's better to share
it around
and talk about sharing when you guys are
working
do you share a room or is it like every
person in the hotel room uploading to a
cloud or something like me no we are
usually uh
like working in in one room together
that's how it used to be yeah yeah okay
but that's how jonathan rouse and i
think when he was a second for victiana
and he kind of described it as working
in one room everyone on that laptop not
that much talking and sometimes someone
would go hey
i found it does that did everything yeah
yeah no that can definitely happen yeah
yeah but also you have to well also i
should understand that it's
it's we are working it's for so long
yeah like let's say we have a couple of
training camps it goes on for maybe
three four months
you're not going to be want to talk even
even if you're a good friend you don't
want to talk for seven eight hours
straight every day for four months
it simply doesn't
doesn't work that way so i think it was
actually jonathan rosen
visited the vicious camp once
and they were working for a couple of
days and then they had the rest day i
think they had they were free one once a
week or something and on the rest day
rason suggested that other team members
let's do something fun
they just looked at him like he was
completely crazy
they really think we want to spend the
day with each other like when we are
finally free yeah
i mean
and it's not because we are not getting
along we are not friends it's just them
the sheer amount of hours it's at some
point it gets too much yeah everyone
needs a break right well
the micros has been on i guess young as
well going to training camps before the
matches that is very important is it
important that it is also do you think
magnus and mabion also chooses people
that he likes you know that he's gonna
hang out with on the training camp for i
don't know one two three four weeks or
is it just the chess oh something
happening in dubai magnus okay
did it sound like the arbiter maybe
sneezed
[Laughter]
something distracted him it sounded like
a sneeze didn't it yeah it did get
magnus out of his uh
uh thinking there that he has been in
for 11 minutes
maybe he's uh taking a look at the clock
then also but yeah sometimes that's a
good thing if you've been thinking for a
long time sometimes you just get too
into the position too caught up in your
own mind sometimes a bit of distraction
helps kind of trigger you and get kind
of get out of that uh this kind of
zombie mode and back to uh back to focus
so maybe we'll see magnus play quickly
after being distracted oh that would be
interesting but yeah i'll try my
question again do you think for magnus
it is important to choose people that he
likes to hang out with as well yeah
definitely definitely yeah yeah
it sounds a little you know you would
think he only chooses people that
you know i like you i want you in my
team because i like your openings no it
has to be
of course the chess skills are the most
important factor but you cannot spend so
much time with someone you dislike i
mean it doesn't make sense yeah no it
has to be both yeah yeah i do actually
know of a i can't name names in this
story sorry but i do know a top ground
master who as part of his team had
someone that he didn't get on well too
well with so they were all working
separately and um one day they uh
the grandmaster came into the room of
his second he was like okay what have
you been looking at and it turns out the
second was just playing computer games
all day so
um yeah so i wouldn't name it
so
no comment but
yeah you definitely have to get someone
uh that you work well with yeah you will
have to pull in the same directions
mentions
all right well which direction is magnus
uh pulling
it's there like there is two moves in
this he's either gonna take
or
could he move his bishop back just to
not trade them off it's possible um
actually in some scenarios you can drop
your bishop back but it is temporarily
at least a passive square and you need a
few moves now to improve this piece for
example if white takes a timeout
maybe you can drop the black knight back
again if white's a bit slow then you can
maybe just push a pawn and eventually
you could build a pawn center and this
bishop might maybe will come to life
along this diagonal eventually
but in the current position it just
looks too passive and
it just takes too long to get that piece
active again also magnus is happy with
the draw so he wants these bishops to
come off he just wants to do it on his
terms and in the right scenario uh nils
are you
decided on which one to go for to take
or not to take to take this bishop and
allow white to trade the knight
and then maybe just make a move or i
mean that would be my initial reaction
but now we've had some time to
ah finally he does it yeah i was just
about to say that i might have changed
my mind
[Laughter]
and anyway so
luckily i was not in time
so we did see a capture here it is the
most normal reaction i think it should
be it should be said the others are
interesting but
uh this is most normal and now we
strongly expect the rook to come to uh
yeah to the open file or maybe the black
knight may drop back and re-route itself
to this side
just to clear the way for this pawn as
well um okay meanwhile we do see yan
capture with the knight we expected this
knight to take back because the white
rook would make no sense on this square
and also white's knights now look pretty
impressive it looked very nice and also
sort of shifting towards the black king
so will they now stay on that side for
the rest of the game do you think
possibly it's hard to say where they are
going
they are very nice
they look nice but there is one downside
with having especially this knight on e3
and that is this pawn push in the center
that you is sort of the the main plan
for white to push it's now a little bit
harder to achieve because the knight on
e3 it actually blocks the rook from
protecting the pawn so if you push in
the center then you might actually lose
a pawn on on e4 so that is like the the
single downside
that is why uh
i mean it's not everything is not so
great for white it's actually a little
bit tricky how to manage to in this pawn
push
yeah and magnus as predicted um just
shuffled his rook across making it even
more difficult for white to push the
pawn for example there would be a trade
and black's rook as well looks at this
guy this undefended pawn in the center
so magnus just passing the move
back to yan and uh also if young does
nothing then maybe we'll see
this bishop trade offered at some point
for example if yan just pushes upon now
we will see magnus take back with his
rook most likely because remember he
doesn't like these kind of doubled pawns
in the center so if he had taken back he
would have got these double pawns
uh meanwhile okay jan just gaining some
space fighting for space on the queen
side pushing this pawn forward
good strategy if you're playing magnus
uh we've just noticed in the champions
chess tour that magnus always likes to
expand with his pawns on the sides of
the board
so
that's true that's true there is another
actually
more specific point of this last move a
white also because if we go one move
back
uh one move that uh white often wants to
play in these positions is to develop
the queen to b3 to put pressure on the
diagonal towards black's king and also
actually put pressure on the pawn on b7
if black develops the bishop but here
you always have to reckon with the
possibility of black pushing the side
pawn one step forward attacking the
queen and sort of
i mean pushing it backwards again so by
playing first
his own pawn to
to a4 to the side then on the next move
he's ready for for the queen coming out
to b3 which i think is his
at least one of his main ideas to put
more pressure on black's position yeah
that's a really nice tactic there
actually nils you mentioned that this
move it looks very tempting you're
attacking this pawn and if black defends
it for example with the queen maybe now
you can push your pawn forward but uh by
playing a4 attacking the queen after
bishop takes pawn the king moving across
it's actually hard to defend this guy
there's only one square with which you
can do this from and now the black
knight comes over attacks the queen and
whenever wherever the queen moves the
bishop finally does drop so yeah as you
mentioned yan just pushing this pawn
gaining space but also wanting to bring
his queen out next maybe all right well
magnus is uh thinking they are equal on
time magnus zenyan here in game 11.
let's go down to dubai hear from tanya
what's going on around the players now
tanya
a lot's going on here the hype is real
kaya this place is full we've got grand
masters we've got fans from across the
world because this might just be the
final day of the world championship
match we are nearing the end either ways
so we've got lots of spectators
lots of fans from around the world and i
do have one of them with me right now uh
tell us your name and where you're from
hi tanya my name is evgeny i'm coming
from russia to support jana in this
match
that's really nice here now you've
traveled all the way to dubai just for
the chess yeah absolutely that was
actually my purpose to come to dubai to
see and support jan in this game and the
match has been has been very challenging
so far but i i'm still full of hopes for
a comeback from iran's side you have
ginny you mentioned that you're
supporting yan he of course needs all
the support you know what a fighter he
is
what are you expecting from him today
um i'm expecting a hard game you know i
really joined the
top record game of 130 moves or whatever
and i think if he's going to do
something same today or he's going to
surprise magnus in some kind of unusual
debut or the game is going to be hard i
think i'll be completely satisfied so
i'm pretty sure magnus is very
hard not to crack but i hope that young
will do his best today to do that well
we've seen what jan is capable of at his
best he can just do just about any
miracle uh he is such a fighter now you
have guinea how big a deal is it for
russia to have yan fighting for this
world championship match i mean it's
amazing to see the kind of support he
has here that's absolutely amazing for
my country actually after sergey karakin
has made so hard competition with magnus
in 2016 that's another attempt we're
having in a couple of years so i was
really fond of coming here and to see
how young can beat magnus it's going to
be a big challenge for him to achieve
that but i still believe that russia has
very strong positions in international
chance and that world championship title
can come to russia
uh a couple years from now or whatever
it takes but we're definitely going to
do that
thank you so much for joining us you
have guinea as we can see so many fans
and supporters of yan here all hoping
that today jan does what needs to be
done
all right thanks so much tanya
interesting viewpoint from dubai there
and uh magnus he is still thinking about
his next move and that means we have
time to talk about some world champions
finally it's been a while we started
this project
and then so much has been happening in
dubai we we sort of uh we stopped for a
little while there we did yeah there's
been so much action going on uh on the
chess board we haven't managed to get
through as many world champions as we
wanted to yeah but we're going to try to
get through them today um give everyone
a little history lesson of
the famous predecessors to magnus carson
and uh well you can see the chap up here
is a legend of armenia and that is t
ground petrosian and uh
cool name it is tigger and prescription
yeah and it's amazing because a lot of
people actually in armenia have been
called that as well there's many people
called tigran
as well yeah because he's such a big
hero because he's such a hero over there
he's like
chess is extremely popular uh over in
armenia i remember playing over there a
couple of times and uh it's it's you get
flocked on the street sometimes with
your famous chess player and uh he's a
very famous character and
he was he was a great chess player um
in some ways he's kind of remembered i
think for the wrong reasons he he was
remembered for being rather a defensive
player um but in actual fact i i think
that's kind of wrong okay um he was
actually a brilliant tactician and he
spotted tactics especially in blitz
chess
extremely quickly and i think his real
strength was um was the fact that um
basically he saw the danger coming so he
could spot danger a mile off and this
helped him sort of prepare for that
danger and be like right i'm going to
play a very safety first move and that
kind of looked defensive but it's
because of his tactical vision that he
dodged a lot of bullets basically um but
he was yeah a real real hero
was he caught a little bit of like uh
a niche geary that you know was almost
impossible to beat at the border
[Applause]
a niche famously had all draws in the
candidates and i i think that was a
little bit unfair i actually think anish
you know we're all big fans of anish
over here of course had a fantastic year
as well he's had a great year winning
more games than ever basically but but
he but he has remember magnus even said
it he's one of the hardest players in
chess to beat oh and we have to have a
move by magnus okay uh well let's have a
look so um a very standard move now
magnus as the panel said brings his
bishop out and this is just aimed at
swapping off all the bishops and i think
to be honest this this was mentioned
this was very likely to appear
i mean my thoughts on this game the the
big game going on today i i'm i'm
slightly surprised uh that yan went for
the italian
the reason i'm surprised is that
it's not that yang can't play these
positions he's brilliant in these
positions it's just that magnus has so
much experience
in these very subtle
positions we have a couple of exchanges
there so the bishop comes off the more
exchanges maybe the nearer draw it gets
but you know magnus has had this kind of
opening in in previous world
championships he he knows a lot about
the subtleties it seems to me like he'd
be very happy uh with the black pieces
in such an opening so it kind of
surprises me uh that yeah i'm waiting
for this all right
do you think david nils ivanka
could this game uh be a draw is there
still a bunch of play in this
um personally
although i think maybe a draw is the
most likely result i think there's so
much life left especially while queens
remain and there will be pawn breaks
later white will try and break through
in the center we'll see night jumps
also i have memories of a very similar
position where wesley so outmaneuvered
magnus on the champions chess tour this
last year so still a lot of life left
and
it's balanced but that doesn't mean draw
necessarily all right well remember
everyone if this is a win for magnus
carlsen then the match will be over
today janna pognach is basically in a
must-win situation to have any hopes in
this match and we're going to go quickly
down to dubai
i think it's luna standing with the
fashion icon and
magnus is best friend i guess
that is absolutely correct it is owner
and it is the fashion icon manus pasta
once again and magnus
if magnus wins today the other magnus
wins today you will have to go back to
dreary cold no way are you secretly
rooting for a draw today yes
now i i've actually extended my stay a
little bit i can't i can't think about
the minus 10 15 and the slope i honestly
i can't think about it i'm dreading it
so bad do you feel bad for the guys in
the studio in oslo yes
100
but i'm from a worse part of norway so i
they should feel even worse for me then
there's the other magnus magnus carlsen
who's playing do you think that he will
be very satisfied with a draw or do you
think that he'll try to push if he gets
the chance
he's gonna push if he gets the chance
there's no he's obviously satisfied with
the draw but uh
if he gets the chance he can't help it
he's going to push 1 billion
the champion can't help but last
question for you there was a rest day
yesterday did you get a chance to hang
out with the champion and what did you
do
we played some football seven aside
fifth ball against the uh the french
staff of the hotel actually barefoot
seven aside football and it got very
heated very very heated words were
exchanged a little bit of pushing yeah
it was fun good fun we won you won and
they did they know to treat magnus with
the proper let's say respect so he won't
get injured nope
[Laughter]
we we tried to tell them beforehand a
couple of them took it easy but
magnus obviously gets quite fiery so he
was he plays a little bit rough they
they got into the competition and yeah
it's it it snowballed from there
so thank you very much yeah the champion
here is always ready for the fight and
maybe even also in today's gay game even
though he would of course be very
satisfied with a draw thank you very
much
thank you
and the mind is a very nice beauty tool
scarf there i think also for magnus been
to the dubai
market probably on the rest day as well
magnus playing some football we are
waiting for the next move by the world
champion he is uh still thinking he is
number 16 in the line of official world
champion since the start of the world
championship matches tigran petrossian
he's number nine uh we already went
through boris busky and bobby fischer
who came after him but we didn't have
time for tigger and projection and we
obviously have to do him because as you
said he's such a big hero especially in
armenia and he lost his title then in
1969 to boris buskie what was his era as
a world champion was it was he a clear
number one was he dominant in his time
i think he was pretty dominant yeah very
dominant his starter chess is uh really
worth studying i i'm known to be
a really crazy player
and people i can imagine yeah you know
let the beard loose a little bit on a
play and
people would probably find it hard that
one of the books i enjoyed the most was
actually tigran's best game book because
it's kind of the opposite to what my
style is but i think he's a really
really good player to study because if
you want to learn how to and a lot of
people don't do this they only look at
their own moves but if you want to get
into your opponent's mind and try to
think of things that you know you need
to worry about then he's the guy to try
and look at look at his style and it
kind of teaches you how to avoid uh
nasty ideas your opponent's coming up
with so he's yeah a real and again like
a great world champion yeah and so and
what you say also is if you want to
get great at sort of a little bit
defending but also tactics then this
could be a world champion to study
definitely yeah they've all got
something to give
and this guy certainly yeah yeah oh
ivanka is this maybe then one of your
favorite world champions we do know you
love all the tactics
uh yeah he's definitely one of my
favorites because um he's such a clever
player you know always anticipating the
threat and the attack way before it even
came so definitely one to study and he's
actually like a precursor to my ultimate
favorite which is like cop off anatoly
karpov
enjoy him well on that
anchor let's talk about the next world
champion then so obviously spassky
fischer we talked about them so now we
are at the world champion number 12 must
be anatoly carpo this is someone that
everyone knows right yeah what a what a
great chess player what a great man who
is this guy
uh well karpov is a legend i mean
they're all legends but the you know
karpov came along he became world
champion and he had what a lot of people
would say very distinctive style of
chess it was uh very positional he was a
bit like you know strangling his
opponents little by little uh bow
constrictor kind of style of chess and
um he he also you know it has some very
interesting world championship matches
and uh well probably the famous of them
was in 78
and he played uh his rival uh victor the
terrible cauchy not because he's
terrible chess just because he was you
know a bit bit raw and uh these two
hated each other yeah basically yeah
there's no point skipping around it i
mean um they absolutely hate each other
and this this world championships in
1978 was just a marvelous drama or of
craziness i mean you had so much stuff
going on i mean uh victor basically you
know karpov brought a hypnotist along to
sit in the front row to try to hypnotize
uh victor victor that came along with
the black sunglasses trying to get those
glazes back over to karpov apparently
they were kicking each other
under under the chess board so they had
to put up a barrier
and then carpool i mean i think then
coach noyes team got some local villains
um bailed them out of prison
i mean it was a complete like so soap
show i mean like you know you think
about these soaps this is like
craziness going on and i thought it does
yeah it's really really really cool i
mean like probably one of the coolest
world championships even like yogas were
brought to carpool's side and victor's
like what is this this is chord language
from you cannot have a purple yoghurt
when you play me uh i don't know if my
russian accent is very it's still very
good
um there was loads of stuff going on and
uh um i've had the honor to play coach
noy on three occasions he was always
quite nice to me but he had a bit of a
bit of a fiery reputation
my brother the border outside the board
as well um everywhere okay everywhere
but he had a very tough upbringing uh
did caution i've been brought up in
stalingrad and uh coach was kind of like
um i suppose a little bit of the bad boy
the soviet union carpals rather than
poster boy a bit more of that a bit more
of uh you fit in well with what they
were doing and uh yeah i mean i think
we're still awaiting a move uh or yeah
the main game so um but yeah it was just
a very interesting world championships
and uh my brother actually my older
brother actually played karpov
and drew of him in a symbol which is
quite strange simultaneous with six
people wow um and i remember a funny
story from that was that uh
afterwards there was quite a lot of
press there he was the only player to
draw
and the press um came up to karpov and
it was in london and they were like oh
can we can we interview he's not
speaking
english and then he said to my brother
want to analyze the game mate we didn't
say it like that but he was like and
they analyzed the game perfect english
and he was he was a a real gentleman so
for that reason a bit of family
connections and you know i've got a lot
of love carpool yeah how cool and
nelson you told me actually before
before the show today because i thought
the musical chess was based on the the
big 72 match between spassky and bobby
fisher
but actually it is based on that
legendary match in 78 yeah on the 78
match i mean the the very famous musical
uh tim rice i think uh i think it was
based on this one night in bangkok
all the drama that happened you know you
could write i mean there has been movies
i think in the making coming up on this
match but many stories we actually have
a move as well so let's just very
quickly see what magnus has played on
the board um he's played a very sensible
move his pawn is attacked and he just
removes this pawn from the danger he
shoves it forwards one square just
securing that area of the board and um
again my thoughts on this is it's um
i guess fairly even but there's a lot of
play left in the position the pieces
remain on the board maybe i'd rather
slightly be white here
it's in equal positions it's it's often
who has more plans more pawn pushes and
i think again as uh all the panels said
uh white always has this big pawn push
in the middle that he can he can prepare
for a long time so slightly more
flexible for uh uh for white this
position and david we do see the bar
saying 0.5 advantage for iana pogniacci
is this looking good for white
um it's looking as simon mentioned maybe
slightly easier to play for white but no
real advantage yet it's unclear when he
can break forward when he can achieve
any kind of long-term advantage this is
the type of position where if the
queen's come off or if white isn't
energetic maybe it could just fizzle out
to pure equality um
yeah nils you think the same
yeah definitely i mean it's it's
slightly more pleasant for white you
have a little bit more maneuverability
it's easier for white to push in the
center than for black
but those are sort of
uh temporary advantages like black can
reroute his knight from from c6 for
instance
and uh
like
i mean the logical uh sequel a logical
sequence of moves will bring the game
closer to equality by every move so
something
really is special must happen for white
to sort of break through or increase the
advantage and uh
i guess it's quite unlikely that uh that
something like that will happen but
it's a position that uh i think
magnus with white would feel also quite
confident in putting this pressure
trying to slowly grind down the opponent
but
as black i think he's also very content
and feels it's very solid yeah i fully
agree and i think another player who
would love this position is actually
karpov himself simon okay yeah certainly
i mean karpov was was very famous for uh
they call it and i think prophylactic
play just really seeing his opponent's
ideas a bit like tigran um seeing frets
and he would always
realize what his opponent is trying to
do and stop him doing that i'm looking
at this position and i actually you know
i've got a crazy stupid
english school of chess move english
school of chess basically means you've
gone a bit mental it's that you if you
played like this in russia you get
thrown out there you get thrown out the
school but i i i remember in an earlier
game and this was i think game six that
critical game where um actually yan uh i
think it was that game had the white
pieces um it was one of those games he
could have gone g4
in that game no okay i love it i love it
we've got some laughter there
you suggest the most crazy move in the
position simon and you've got a picture
of anatoly karfur behind you maybe one
of the most sensible players in chess
where's shaw's david what is this crazy
simonides he's probably rubbish let's go
through it simon talk us through it
i mean he has to win right i mean this
is kind of a stupid move but uh because
you give up a major major square but it
just reminds me of a moment earlier on
in i think it was game six could have
been wrong where at some point white
could have just gone for g4
i think maybe maybe game five yeah that
was the one game five and had jan played
g4 in that game he would have got a very
substantial advantage according to
matthew sadler who who had that twitter
profile you ivanka mentioned about
computer chess uh i i mean i don't
actually like it because it gives up the
square next to it this major major
square but
you know i do have what we call a hook
the pawn on h6 and i might be able to
push on and open up the file i have to
say the more i'm looking at the more i
think i've just got completely mad but i
want some violence on the board anyone
think g4 is going to happen i think if
you play this move you first of all has
have to consider what happens if black
were actually to take the pawn
that could be a very
quick turn of events for uh for white
because after
quite recaptured with the knight then
the rook comes
to g6 and now we see that it has created
a very unpleasant pin towards blacks so
it was white knight so maybe we go king
h1 first i think the idea actually i
think the id definitely has a right to
exist in this position as you say
like
he needs to do something along those
lines it's just when you make such a
move it has to be uh
timed very very carefully you have to be
very very accurate but a move like king
h1 with a long term id of g4 i think
definitely very relevant for the
position yeah i think they're pushing up
the pawn like david highlighted as well
it might be slow play might be fast
played with that g4 idea okay so we'll
keep this one in mind for a bit later
maybe yeah definitely johanna pomnyacci
is thinking will we see this crazy crazy
move uh by ginger gm simon williams
we're gonna go down to dubai what's uh
happening tanya
a big moment in the game it's a
strategic fight and as the iconic match
continues there's so much going on in
the chess world to tell us more about
all the action that we've been seeing
the last couple of days i've got with me
grand master director general of fide ml
sutovsky and well thank you for joining
us hi tanya good to see you you as well
now emil there's so much in this match
to be proud of for fide can you
contextualize a little bit for us what
this success has been and is it a little
bittersweet that the match will end
probably sooner than expected
well indeed it was a major effort and
you know we started it more than two
years ago the first negotiations took
place in august 2019
and it took a lot of time to you know
to have all the arrangements and then
pandemic came and we had to change our
plans and actually
not only for this event we had we had a
pandemic effect on
impact but i think overall we can be
quite proud and i want to thank also
expo have been instrumental in this
success
obviously the championship is
actually the first championship under mr
dwok presidency and for us it was
important also to have it on a high
level
both in terms of financial
because you know the prize money has
doubled and
i think uh also the entire
venue and all the related was uh on the
new level
of course uh
you cannot avoid some minor glitches
here and there and it's understandable
we know that not everything was perfect
and as you indicated i've been
quite a top player in past to to be
perfectionist you know and we felt that
here and there we could do better and we
will do better but
overall we feel it was a success
absolutely i think it's been an iconic
match and an iconic when you're breaking
all viewership records ml what do you
think has been the reason for that
well
honestly i mean we could
count it as a great success of theater
but it was i mean
accumulative effect of everything
starting the pandemic effect queen's
gamut effect and hopefully some work of
hours but also you guys i mean you have
been doing great job and your studio is
awesome and then and i praise it
chess.com has been doing a fantastic job
as well so we
we have all this interest to chess
booming and uh not the least we also try
to you know to change the format a bit a
bit more dynamic we play if you paid
attention for the first time ever places
three
one day orphans and two which allows us
to play all the weekends friday saturday
sunday we always have a game we also
change the starting games of times of
the games because typically it would be
3 p.m local time wherever you play but
here we realize that being in dubai it
would be very uncomfortable for
especially for american
audience but also for europeans
and we moved it and i think 430 is a
great time and and all the asian
countries could enjoy it as well but but
also
western hemisphere so we thought about
these little details fish tanks they're
playing in i think it creates an
opportunity for spectators to have some
special experience
inside the playing call
they can talk they can discuss maybe not
loudly but still they can use their
mobile phones but also the players are
not disturbed and there's a lot of
little things which you
basically you may not notice them but
say they are part of a bigger picture
and i think we are quite happy about it
yes you mentioned earlier we are a bit
unhappy that the match which started as
very interesting and equal quite uh
seems to be like
almost i wouldn't say i mean we
shouldn't exclude the the possibilities
of a comeback but almost decided at this
stage and it's a bit of disappointment
but then it gets sport you know and when
they have a champions league final and
somebody wins 3-0 what do you do i mean
you do not you do not kill yourself for
staging it you say sport i mean and
i think it's uh it has been so far a
great ride and i hope it ends also on a
high note
absolutely emil you mentioned it's been
a great ride also fantastic to hear
about the details as you were mentioning
now with everything going on there's
little time to rejoice because of the
situation with kazakhstan not being able
to host the world rapid and blitz an
event that of course the chess world was
really looking forward to
what can the players chess fans expect
from fidei what is the next step
well you know we are we have mastered
the art of crisis management this one
and half years were especially difficult
when we had to take quick decisions soon
unfortunately we couldn't do it in
kazakhstan because the government just
imposed restrictions and the government
was very you know key into stages on a
high level but it didn't happen
uh but luckily you know we are we are
quite amazed quite an experience and i
can already announce now in lives that
we have already new location for the
event
yes when it's going to take place the
same days in warsaw poland
and this
morning we got a letter signed by
non-lesser prime minister of poland
supporting the event
it's gonna
go in the same full swing
and we expect it to be grand and and
really really great we know that poland
is emerging to be uh chess empire chess
superpower of represent and results of
yanduda are are great and i'm happy that
our team managed to do this so quickly
i'm actually proud about it because uh
you know uh it's not it's not a miracle
it's not that we're pulling something
off it's just some work which we have
been building up because sometimes the
success which comes it comes as a factor
that you have already some reputation
and uh also you build build it up this
is the whole when you have a crisis
situations then you have unexpected
resources to come so there is no deus ex
machina there are some things that you
you basically prepare to it to happen
and i'd like to thank the federal vice
president lucas turley who was
incredibly instrumental to this effort
the whole day yesterday he and
[Music]
myself we spent over this process and
and eventually it succeeded and we can
confirm it now we're looking forward to
welcoming players in in poland in just
10 days from now well it's amazing to
hear thank you so much emil for that
news and congratulations to fidei for
their solution approach all the time
we have director general of fidei emil
satovsky confirming that the world rapid
and blitz will take place the same dates
in poland wow great news thank you so
much tanya breaking news from dubai the
world rapid and blitz will take place
over christmas over the holidays it's a
move to poland great great news we're
going to talk more about that but we had
two moves in the game simon
what just happened that's right so uh
two very sensible moves they don't want
to start throwing the g pawn up board
quite yet
uh instead yan just centralized one
piece that's not doing anything he
brought this rook to the center of the
board
often a good idea to line your rooks up
against your opponent's queen even if it
seems it's not doing anything at the
moment if the position suddenly catches
on fire that rook will be ideally placed
and now a typical maneuver from magnus
this knight which we've seen many times
before moves its way here and that's a
rather city square except that it's
trying to bring its way over towards uh
the king's side and maybe eventually
towards uh white's king maybe we have
one more move as to speak
and the other move a very very cautious
move petrosian-like move actually h3
just uh giving a bit more control here
so
i don't think anything
real fireworks wise has appeared on the
board nothing nothing that's shocking uh
as yet but um uh they're building up so
it could it could easily come to life
very soon all right yeah what do you
guys uh think uh david nils yonko what's
happening on the board i would echo
simon's thoughts um i'm slightly
surprised by this last move i thought
it's a bit vague and unnecessary but
um nils can you explain this last move
by white to me i mean the rook move the
night move both look logical but this
one
yeah
it's surprising but also i would say
even more surprising than the move
itself is the time spent behind it
because this move if i
uh so correctly it was like almost
instantly played very few minutes and i
think for white in this position
uh in order to achieve anything like as
we said if black manages to regroup in
time black would be completely fine so
like the onus is on why to create
something quickly and for this you have
to be really accurate you have to think
very carefully on each move like
how to make the most
after the position immediately
and then i think in general you cannot
play moves like h3 so quickly
like this sort of vague slightly
improving moves you have to be more
accurate you have to think deeper and
for that you also need to spend more
time so i think nepo here is
uh repeating a little bit of of the
problem they had previously in the match
that he is uh sometimes playing moves a
little bit too fast and sometimes
missing uh
critical opportunities uh to put
pressure yeah just not sensing the pace
of the game or the critical moments
exactly exactly because 102 moves more
like this in this style and black will
have solved all his problems whatsoever
yeah flat just moves the queen brings
the rook to the center maybe later
re-roots the knight then black's
actually ready to open the center at
some point and
yeah it feels extremely slow i don't see
the point at all of this last push i'm
going to make a confession i thought it
was a great move
okay enlighten us what's the idea behind
it you wait you wait and see and you
just say hey you know if you step
forward with the queen maybe black can
start maneuvering a knight
somewhere to the edge of the board white
can uh yeah yeah to that square okay and
then jump into yeah exactly
and plus i got a bit enthusiastic with
simon's idea you know reinforcing the g4
square
but that's why i'm learning from you
guys you guys are like no no no you've
got to act now you've got to do
something concrete so
thank you
thank you thank you
for listening maybe you'll be right
ivanka maybe we'll well maybe we'll see
napolesi just
go for an attack and crush carlson you
never know but uh yeah i mean the reason
i guess we're attracted to this one is
just because you can bring the rook
forward and i think this pawn push now
is maybe less attractive because black
can immediately profit from the f4
square simon alluded to this earlier and
your move as well bring the knight to
the side it looks nice and attractive
maybe in conjunction with a pawn move
but even if i ignore i mean maybe i
could push forward just to stop your
knight jumping in but even if i ignore
i'm not sure trades are really going to
help wipe that much because black now
will be ready to push forward in the
center and i think solve all of his
problems and there we go magnus does
indeed bring the queen forward who's got
the better plan right now who's got the
more effective plan we'll wait and see
all right
we know we do know one plan though and
that is that rapid and blitz world
championship will take place in poland
we had breaking news a few minutes ago
starting i think it's december 26th
and the big question is of course simon
david nils ivanka will you guys play
um yeah i mean i i actually prefer
warsaw as a venue um especially around
christmas time this beautiful old old
town city there so where it's kind of
tempting i mean i'm not really in the
david nil you know these the league of
these players but i can maybe punt a
couple of g4s and have a bit of fun so
uh i i love the idea of spending a
couple of days just playing blitz chess
which is much more uh light-hearted than
the serious stuff so i might i might be
convinced what do you reckon david could
you hold my hand over there i'll play if
you play simon
okay
it's super tempting like you say
poland's nice and you get to test
yourself against the best why not why
not who needs christmas and new year's
celebrations
who wants to see family you know
and it's so entertaining as well for
everyone else i will be having my
christmas holiday and it would be so
nice if i could follow you guys play
some blitz and wrap it down there nils
ivanka what do you think
i am it's much more likely when it's
played in in warsaw than in kazakhstan
for sure so but uh well i have to think
about it
no unfortunately it will be feliz
navidad for me and i will be enjoying
just the company of my family
not this time all right well but it is
great news it will happen in poland
magnus carlsen has said that he intends
to play let's see if also jana pomnyacci
shows up and what players will show up
to fight for the two world championship
titles in rapid and blitz this guy
karpov he kept his title for 10 years
actually and when we started talking
about him simon you described him as he
liked to
squeeze and just push and squeeze and
keep the games going for a long time
sounds like someone else
i know well certainly i mean a lot of
people have compared carpal style to to
magnus's style um
carp off you know at the time uh was
considered one of the best end game
players ever
the best kind of positional he did moves
which people didn't really understand
they're like why did he do that move it
doesn't really seem to do anything but
then later on 10 moves later it became
apparent that he was he was doing
something really strong and uh magnus
carson often does the same kind of thing
he plays a move and you're like hang on
a minute that's that's what's he doing
and then 10 moves later you're like ah
yeah so there's definitely more
similarity between i would say karpov
and uh magnus carson than some of the
other players not not meaning that uh
magnus carson can't play in other ways
as well
all right but
do you think this is one of the biggest
inspirations then for magnus carlsen
karpov i think so i i think everyone's
learned something from karpov karpov had
a very distinctive style he was very
good at avoiding danger
and taking his time and he he had some
amazing games
so yeah certainly
and
we'll move on then to the next
world champion and and that is the guy
that most people are saying even magnus
carlsen is saying the greatest chess
player of all time this is a legendary
picture from the match in i'm not sure
if it's 84 or 85 they first played in 84
it was cancelled after
i don't know how many months a very long
match but then they played again in 85
karpov and kasparov
yeah i mean
we could dedicate a whole show
just to the great kasparov and
i think it's kind of considered by a
number of uh
the best players in the world that
kasparov was the greatest chess player
of all time
and one of the things that was you have
to say he left as a legacy was that he
was uh world number one for like 20
years and he won everything so he won
world championships okay he did lose it
in the year 2000 but he was still world
number one every tournament he competed
in he crushed his opponents and he was
such a powerful
guy at the board he had this kind of
aura
and the way he played chess was quite
phenomenal because he
loved attacking and he could see like
electricity coming from his hands when
he was playing it was like he was some
kind of x-men he literally he would
hover over and he was really passionate
and he just oozed electricity with his
moves and energy and that energy is is
quite special and i suppose if you're
going to compare him to a player you
wouldn't necessarily say magnus carlsen
but uh ali raza farouza is someone who
when i think of kasparov i think ali
raza kasparov very similar style you can
kind of see uh kasparov i think in the
way that ali raza may be magnus's next
challenger um the way they play is very
similar but he was such a powerful
character he played aggressive openings
he tried to win with black a bit like
bobby fischer um king's indian defense
really exciting get gwen jose's course
for chesapeal great course and he was
just a great energetic exciting player
to watch so quite different karpov
he and i guess he is the youngest world
champion of all time became a world
champion at i think maybe 22 years old
yes yeah
yeah if he wins could be also they then
overtake that title but um
was this was was he great at everything
gary kasparov at the chessboard um yeah
i don't know about his cooking
he was he was brilliant at everything i
mean all world champions have to be
great at every era of the ball every
area of the game so endings openings
middle games so he was really good at
everything but his tactical vision and
using the initiative so if he ever got a
slight chance to attack he would just
poo
bulldozer his opponents with amazing
tactics and as we speak we have one more
move uh which okay we can play on the
board so i thought that nice i thought
you guys loved that night where it was
well the night was okay but he's making
some sense with this porn move the night
has come back and sometimes in life and
in chess you have to go back to go
forwards
and you can see clearly the idea is for
that knight to
jump forwards uh to this square maybe
trying to put some pressure on on
magnus's king
but of course this is going to
mean more exchanges it's kind of a
logical idea i think uh david and niels
and jovanka i i guess this is something
which makes a lot of sense after after
the last move that was played h3
yeah we see this pattern quite a lot in
this type of opening but here as you
mentioned simon it's only going to lead
to more trades at the very best for
white and just it doesn't really suit
the match situation for napoli um
if knights come off even if white gets
the ideal scenario and gets two or three
moves i'm not exactly sure what the plan
is after that so
um nils yeah i guess i mean he wants to
go up with the knight and try to bring
like if there is a trade he wants to
take back with the pawn so he gets a
pawn closer towards the black king
then he can slowly try to build up some
sort of uh
initiative on towards black's king like
uh maybe even use this open file uh open
h file for the rook later on after he
improves the king
something like this exactly king comes
to g2 then rook comes to h1
the knight will have possibilities to
jump forward there is an open edge file
uh
if he gets this position
i think it could be quite dangerous but
here we have given a given white like
three or four moves extra for free and
even then it isn't that clear so it's
it's slow but
it does at least create some sort of uh
plan long term let's say like there is
some uh
let's say how to say it's it's now
possible to uh you know vision a
scenario where white is actually getting
somewhere which was almost impossible to
do before yeah at least gives him some
purpose right exactly exactly i mean we
were fiddling around with the pieces we
couldn't come up with a plan really but
at least he's uh come up with something
and we'll see how effective it becomes
all right well magnus is thinking again
so let's go back down to dubai what's
going on you guys
a lot actually the chess fever is on in
dubai it's a packed auditorium inside
and we can see behind me as well so many
spectators for the online the on-site
commentary that's going on down there
and of course it is a strategic battle
right now on in the game a slow position
but with big potential to blow up and
i've got with me grandmaster alejandro
ramirez ollie would you agree with that
absolutely it's very slow and as you
mentioned very strategical i think
tim yan was unable to change the spirit
of the position they weren't able to get
a really big fight instead they're
getting the typical stuff they've been
getting with white throughout the match
a slight positional pressure maybe you
would say you'd rather be white but look
at black completely solid completely
defended everywhere already a pair of
bishops off the board if you are in an
absolutely must-win game as many people
see this one to be
well i don't think this is the type of
position jan wants
so are you saying that you're surprised
with yan's opening approach going for
the italian today
honestly it's difficult to recommend
something when you're playing magnus
carlos and of course but when magnus
wants to be solid he's solid and in this
one it doesn't feel like white's getting
quite enough of course the italian has
something that jan used before but he
has some bad memories with it remember
that he lost against wesley so in that
2016 crucial match against the usa uh
that pretty much cost the team russia
any kinds of of chances for a gold medal
and in this case it's just i see the
position i see this night jumps but are
there going to be enough
ali can you highlight some of the key
features in the position for both white
and black currently
white is trying to maneuver he just put
this knight from f3 to h2 he's gonna
hippity-hop over to g4 hope to get some
space advantage on this side hopefully
transfer the rooks create some kind of
pressure on the king side with some kind
of luck he goes d4 but at the moment
this is all fantasy how is he going to
implement all of these things white is
also worried about this knight jumping
to f4 the pawn break on d4 is met with
this very very strong weakness on e4
it's very difficult to defend this pawn
comfortably and then push this one
forward uh rook 81 to me seemed like a
very slow move and i'm still trying to
figure out how it uh forms in the
overall strategy
very interesting now alejandro given the
math situation i'm going to ask you
how long do you think the world
championship match is going to last
i don't think that jan will overpress
today but i also don't see magnus
cracking so i do predict the draw and
winning with black when magnus carlsen
wants to make a draw against you forget
about it
all right thank you so much for that
alejandro that we have it grandma's
alejandra ramirez with his insights in
the current position
thank you so much tanya and alejandro
and uh yeah we are still waiting for
minus to make his move he keeps uh
thinking today magnus carlsen
what do you guys think about the
situation right now four minus is it uh
a lot to think about
yeah we've actually just been debating
some moves here in the studio
there's plenty of options um it's clear
what jan wants to do next we did
illustrate white's plan by retreating
the knight wants to spring forward it's
the g4 square next and he's going to do
that against nearly no matter what
magnus does so
um here we were debating whether magnus
just takes another timeout just slowly
maybe improves a piece i was attracted
to moving that black rook in the corner
which isn't doing anything at home
asleep just bringing it to the center
but it's not clear where that root
belongs it's not clear that actually
helps anything um concretely so another
suggestion i think from your banker was
to push forward in the center yeah but
you have to use the
the little expression that we have you
go backwards i go forward and i can see
that magnus has made a move and is gone
actually for your approach
we know magnus he invites every piece to
the party um this rook was doing nothing
so he does centralize it uh just to show
what we were discussing in the studio
here we were thinking about black's pawn
pushing forward and uh after the white
knight jumps to the g4 square then the
blackboard maybe could push forward even
more so the nature of the position would
be completely changed here this however
would also make the question of what
happens if there are some captures in
the center of the board and maybe magnus
felt that having the rook on this d8
square does just make things a bit
better for him later when he does push
but uh the big question now and jan asks
that question immediately is what
happens if white does jump forward with
the knight
an immediate reply by napoleshi and okay
will we see magnus take this piece nils
wasn't so enthusiastic about this
decision if black captures here
yeah i think i mean at least if white
recaptures with the pawn there is some
some potential to create something on on
the king side for for white later
exactly but it's as we mentioned it's a
long way away and uh well black
will be able to counter in the center
there will be
plenty of possibilities for counter play
so probably this is also fine but
i think from magnus perspective it could
be that he wants something even more
like he doesn't want to change the pawn
structure
as we were talking a little bit about uh
previously in the in the show that uh
what napo like one of his main goals in
the opening or in the position in
general is to create some sort of
imbalance
some something to play for
and uh taking there would at least
create some imbalance it could be that
this imbalance is
maybe even more favorable for black than
for white but it's still an imbalance
it's still something to play for as
white so yeah different pawn structure
maybe strong or maybe these are just
double pawns which uh beth harmon had
those nightmares about
um okay so big question for magnus to
take or not to take he's had this
question before uh if we remember with
the dark squared bishops whether to
trade or not to and it cost him a lot of
time on the clock so i wouldn't be
surprised to see him think for a bit
longer here i guess the options are
maybe just leave the knights he will try
and break through in the center at some
point or does he retreat does he step
back avoiding this trade he could even
maybe
this is provocative but he could even
step forward maybe trying to force white
to make a decision if the knights come
off now then at least the pawn structure
hasn't changed and
black does have some ideas of using this
rook
against the white king um but then again
white might just retreat white might
step back and argue that okay suddenly
this g5 square is nice and juicy black
has lost all control over it
so uh okay huge amount of choice for
magnus wow yeah
it's gonna spend some more time then i
guess
for sure
most probably yeah because also if he
makes sort of the right decision uh it
could be that his position is
like very very safe
if he managed to liquidate in the right
way maybe push in the center so that
everything gets traded off then maybe he
only has to make
you know two or three more
decisions in the game before it's
completely drawish
whereas if he doesn't make the most
precise move now he could end up in some
defense where he has to defend for a few
more hours with
lots of decisions on each move and so on
so i think it's very reasonable to like
try to be as precise as possible in this
position as black interesting all right
well what will minus carlsen do while we
wait for his move let's go back down to
dubai to rooney and i have to say it
really seemed like you enjoyed the rest
day out and about in dubai yesterday
well absolutely kai this place is
amazing it's just uh you feel very small
because everything is extremely
extremely big and i you also feel quite
weak i saw you know decent
club player level chess player when you
go around here at the expo and like it's
like you can swing a dead cat over your
head and you're bound to hit a good
chess player i just ran into uh mithal
hi hi uh first of all i would like to
get your um you know impressions of the
match so far yeah it's been an
interesting match and uh yeah for sure
till uh
especially till seven eight games it was
really interesting and right now of
course there has been a bit of bad luck
for nepal nyashi with two one move
blenders in the last two games
but
yeah i've been excited to follow the
match and
today it's an uh
interesting position i think he he has
got some advantage with
the with the italian and
yeah let's see how it goes
and you are 15 years old what is your
immediate goal right now in chess
right now immediate goal is to become a
grand master uh
as soon as possible hopefully in the
next
tournament that i'm playing because i
need one more now so you need one more
norm and 20 more yellow points because
you are 24 24 80 is that correct yeah
and what what is the next tournament
what is the next thing in chess for you
uh yeah so next time playing cedges in
spain
and from there the plan was to play in
world rapid blitz uh
i was not sure but we were planning and
but right now it has gone been cancelled
from kazakhstan so we'll see uh what's
happening next well they actually just
got some information in the studio so it
is still taking place at the same time
the the rapid places just in a new
country so i hope you can
come and play
what is it like being as a chess fan
here in as young as a chess fan here in
dubai
yes it's very uh
it's a
new experience for me because wherever
i've gone so far to uh for chess it's
only to play and this is the first time
i'm here as a spectator and it's the
first world championship so yeah the
atmosphere is
incredible a lot of great players around
it's fun interacting with all of them
and yeah it's great
thank you so much that was aditya mithal
another great hope for the future of
chess thank you so much for your
thoughts and insights and back to the
guys
and it looks nice behind you there as
well i don't know with should we call it
christmas lights are you getting any
sort of christmas spirit in dubai
well you know i'm from scandinavia so i
needed a bit of cold and a bit of snow
really but they are really trying they
have like leprechauns everywhere there's
santa claus everywhere and like
christmas trees but it doesn't work you
know completely for me like with the sun
and and everything so um well they're
trying
good to hear all right enjoy yourself
rooney thanks for the report from dubai
we are getting into the holiday spirit
here in the studio we have a christmas
tree now and
well christmas holidays could be coming
up today if magnus carlsen wins this
game do you see chances for that right
now david
i think i think all three results are
possible as nils mentioned this is a
good moment to invest some time because
the next few moves will kind of
decide the course of the game over
the rest of the middle game maybe we
could even see lots of trades the center
explode open
and
yeah i mean magnus i think the result is
far from his mind right now he just
wants to achieve a position where he has
some stability where he has a clear plan
and where he can neutralize uh the
ponies so
yeah it's uh it's article i still
maybe think the white's position is
easier to play but if black is accurate
surely there shouldn't be too many
problems
do you think guys
yeah for sure
magnus i mean black is completely
fine here and objectively speaking there
is no doubt like no weaknesses all
pieces are working there is no grounds
to be to be worse but
still it could be like white has
slightly more flexibility slightly more
possibilities
of course in this sense also more
possibilities to overpress or go wrong
i think if if magnus was white
he would start to just trade pieces and
and make a very comfortable draw but
with nepal being white having to push
there is definitely uh possibilities for
all three results wow
and meanwhile black does capture the
white knight so he does change the
position very slightly um so the
imbalances that niels was mentioning
it's minuscule here just the pawn
structure white's pawns now on the
g-file doubled but they do control a lot
of squares
and that's why we were reluctant to
go for this night trade it feels maybe
as if magnus could have tried to achieve
something just without uh commitment but
then again maybe he sees a direct way to
solve his issues which might even
revolve around pushing the black deep
one forward right now just to make use
of the black queen and the black rope
behind it
if you can open the position then maybe
black's major pieces stand well and why
was it better for jan to take with the
pawn and not the knight to get that
knight further up on the board looks
like a nice square for it yeah good
question um so if we can show this
position
jan did in detail with the pawn but if
the night captures then i guess although
the knights further up the board it's
also on a more vulnerable square so this
night later on might well just get hit
by a pawn and get forced back where it
came from i think jan wanted to trade uh
wants to recapture with this pawn
because he feels this structure is more
promising this pawn for example controls
the f5 square that the
white knight might want to use later on
and meanwhile magnus did react instantly
so he spent a bit of time and then
played a couple of moves in quick
succession he has pushed in the center
making use of these two pieces
and if we do see yan take i don't think
we will but if we see yann capture in
the center then everything might get
traded on this square we could see
knights leave the board queens leave the
board and if it comes down to rook's
pure rook end game this should just be a
draw um if anything white has to be more
careful here
because black's rooks are a bit more
active so right now
he's asking the question magnus he's
saying do you want to take me if you
take i'm going to be happy to hoover off
everything from the board and make this
draw um if jan doesn't want to do that i
think neil's earlier mentioned to me
maybe just waiting just pushing a pawn
creating a nice hole for the king to sit
on
but then again this does give black a
lot of time to get organized at some
point black might consider trading and
planting all of his pieces on the same
file maybe he needs to build up for this
first though
and yeah maybe some more maneuvering
ahead if magnus is feeling a vicious
maybe he can even try and play for the
win at some point by gaining space in
the center
to find out yeah it feels a bit uh
how to say wishful for white to play for
instance this g3 kingdom like
he knows that it's not going to work but
he still has to try it sort of thing
wow okay
fire on the board yeah completely
different than everything we expected
there wow okay
yeah explain yeah uh explain explain
nils i was going to say jan explain what
you're trying to do we want to really to
hear jan's explanation now because now
it's getting really complicated these
four pawns looking at each other this is
quite rare yes it's it's very rare and
it's very sharp and it's at least to me
completely unexpected i didn't say
didn't anticipate this move at all but
uh yeah he's putting pressure he's
utilizing the fact that his rook is on
the same file as as magnus queen and
this is a typical thing in chess like
even if there are some pawns in
in front of them or in between them uh
these pawns are likely to uh disappear
and then that will be a problem so it's
something that you in every line that
you calculate you always have to keep
this in mind it's very unpleasant to
have this rook against the queen
so that is one of the reasons and
otherwise
yeah i mean he's uh
really reaching the the climax of the
game i guess like yeah and now it's a
time for concrete measures now we have
to go into the calculation zone and just
work it all out because uh
the danger here for yan is if magnus
navigates this
he will be completely level and there
will be no chance that magnus can go
wrong
so uh we have to break it down what
happens yeah it's either going to be
very very strong for yan or as ivanka
mentions these four pawns will disappear
and everything will get traded and it'll
just be a draw so it's not going to be
very very bad for him then i it doesn't
feel like it uh i'm also judging by the
evaluation bar this is not a blunder by
white so
if it's not a blunder then he should be
okay and uh yeah okay as your ivanka
mentions what's going to happen um we
start in every position as usual by
looking at the forcing moves that would
be either black capturing this one or
like capturing the other pawn um which
one are we most tempted by here which is
the most forcing do you think i think
the most forcing is to capture that one
you have now and the dark squaring yeah
and this would ask white to maybe
recapture with the rook uh maintaining a
pin now so black's pawn in the center is
stuck you cannot move
but you can attack it right yeah exactly
the pawn on e4 now will be taken by
black's rook
and for every
every trade
now we are going to create another set
of rooks and we also have traded the
pawns so this looks uh very very safe
for black as far as i can see if
anything blacks might even win upon
temperature it might even be pawn up at
the very least no risk so i would assume
that his id after black captures on d4
is to take with his pawn in the center
as well
okay with e takes d5 and now it's
the knight is hanging for white but also
the rook is hanging for black
and the big difference if black now were
to take back on
in the center with the knight then white
can take with the rook on d4 and now
there will be no rook trade yeah and now
this pin with the rook towards the queen
is beginning to look quite unpleasant
actually but still
not clear at all what is going on but
it's weird there's pins everywhere right
this white knight is pinned but then the
black knight maybe is the more
vulnerable the two yeah and i mean
it's very hard to say what is
what is going on here next move white
can just shift the rook across and two
rooks teaming up against the black queen
looks scary for black exactly so okay
this is one of jan's ideas if black
takes this pawn and the other option of
course is if black takes the other pawn
and now i guess we'll see white capture
in the center
yeah that seems very likely yeah hitting
the black queen as uh was mentioned and
when the black queen moves
what next that's the question both of
these pawns are extremely weak
can white win one while preserving his
own i guess one question for example
would be whether he could just move his
knight out the way
defend his pawn and let's move try and
gobble up black's weak horn
in the center as well
yeah that feels like a very uh very
tempting idea yeah
it's
hard to say how to hold the pawn on uh
in the center yeah on the other hand why
it's this double pawn that he created
for himself in order to get some
initiative it now also could turn out to
be quite a big weakness suddenly you
want it back where it came from yeah now
i think if we can drop it back then
that knight would simply win a pawn in
the middle of the board but now that one
might fall and change the rules for
chess first right please let pawns move
backwards
in order to win something you also have
to sacrifice something so but but even
with the weakness of the pawn this looks
quite promising for uh for white right
yeah i would uh
it feels to me more likely that he will
go for the other other trade but hey so
the other trade in the current position
so taking this guy
yeah that one looks like to me it looked
to me like you were trading even more
let's say which is always nice when you
are playing for or when draw is a good
result i'm wondering whether after pawn
takes after the e-borne capture is
hitting the black rook whether black
needs to actually capture
yeah maybe just move the rook definitely
yeah definitely very interesting for
instance rook there and then the queen
attacks the rook and then this was my
issue i think you have to put the rook
on to the f4 square and then
this looks like another let me go round
now it's on a roller coaster usually
these rooks are not
going in that direction and we get
trapped yeah yeah now for instance yeah
white pushes the pawn up and well
it's too uh
too much is hanging from black i think
and as soon as you move the rook away
then the
center does fall so and uh yeah of
course not enough time to ever capture
this knight because the rook was always
attacked although although
specifically here when you said it it
seems to be very reasonable yeah okay
actually suddenly yeah yeah yeah white
king is open and maybe we'll see some
kind of forced draw if the white king is
uh unable to find shelter black and keep
giving checks yeah this looks
this looks good for black but this way
there were a lot of questions during
this i see that you're looking quite
confused kaya but uh yeah i'm very
confused
we are also very confused
we uh we are completely confused here
what is going on but i guess
at this point if you notice
my cross in the
i guess my question is
uh
are you applauding on the publicity here
because it's giving us and obviously
magnus something to think about and
maybe
really for the first time in the match
risking a little bit yeah on the one
hand yes that's absolutely true but
there is also one downside of this and
that is that it's very forcing and if
magnus makes the right decisions the
whole board could get liquidated
immediately like we could trade as we
saw in some of the lines uh i mean
basically the entire board gets uh
disappears and it's an immediate draw
so that's the downside
but then again i mean if magnus is as
surprised as us psychologically it's
hard
and he knows that um
i mean this downside for white it is
maybe quite a narrow path that black has
to find maybe black has to find a series
of three or four
really really difficult accurate moves
yeah
and i mean apart from this line we
showed right at the end there nothing
else looked that convincing for black
and as nils mentioned even that wasn't
forced there are options for both sides
on every turn
so a lot for magnus to think about here
seven minutes already and i wouldn't be
surprised to see him invest another 10
minutes or so even another 20 minutes to
be honest because if
again if he makes the right decision
there might not be any more decisions
left to make in the game so
but on the other hand if he spends 20
minutes and doesn't find anything
convincing then it could be really
unpleasant so so is this a situation
where he as well will be thinking about
the clock a little bit because the clock
could be it could be important to have a
lot of time for the rest of the game
if those trades doesn't happen if they
don't happen yes for sure but if he
finds a way to trade safely then it's
not going to be an issue so is that
basically his goal now yes
find a move that has everything trade
trading off yeah and i just checked the
computer variations and i'm just looking
here that black only has two choices he
has to take one of those pawns if he
doesn't
it's going to be lost well let's get up
stockfish though which one
luckily luckily those are the most
obvious moves in the position but yeah
as you mentioned you've anchored which
one and wow stopfish spoiling it for us
apparently both moves are fine
but
both moves are fine maybe that's an even
more difficult choice
because how do you compare the two how
do you weigh them up they look
completely different to me they lead to
different types of positions um okay so
only two moves that magnus can choose
here because the third one gives a huge
advantage for jana pogniacci yeah the
third one i think just loses a pawn
essentially um a very important pawn
yeah yeah one of black central pawns
will just fall off if black does
anything other than capture in the
center right now and magnus clearly not
comfortable he was looking behind him
there may be distracted by some noise or
something seemed to happen with his
chair as well the arbiter had to come
over and
i don't know fix something
hmm
okay so two moves
should we have a vote what are we gonna
do
i predicted the one that is given the
lowest evaluation by uh
0.1 no and not of course because of the
evaluation but uh because it seems to me
more likely to generate even more trades
it's 50 50. i'm so tempted to launch our
guess the move challenge right now but
it's a 50 50 choice what do we think
guys should we ask our viewers what they
think or should we delay that for a bit
later there might still be some critical
moments later in the game no i think now
it's maybe i think there might also not
be any more particular moments
okay guys it's time for guess the move
magnus has two sensible choices what's
it going to be which pawn is magnus
going to capture the center of the board
guess the big time guys
[Music]
okay so it's a difficult moment for
magnus carlsen it's a difficult moment
for all of you at home as well what is
black gonna play here send us your
predictions send us what you think is
the best move or send us what you think
magnus will both be attracted to is he
gonna capture upon in the center he's
been spending 10 minutes on this move
already so he could move any moment now
tweet us using the hashtag c24live and
we'll pick a lucky winner yeah and uh
one of the last chances as well together
the great prize in this competition it
is a great prize it is one year
membership to the fabulous website chi
chess which which allows you to put up a
position on the board and you can search
that position on chess databases chess
articles chessable short and sweet and
of course youtube so fantastic prize so
tweet your answer using the hashtag c24
live hmm all right well who knows how
much time you have minus personally is
still thinking there are two
quite obvious moves you said in the
position to to trade off the pawns but
magnus is in a very comfortable
situation in the match right
could he be taking some risks there as
well
possibly but it's not even clear how to
take risks in this position oh the move
is coming they're coming oh okay which
pawn has been grabbed it's the d-pawn
magnus has played e takes d4 so
capturing on the d4 square heels your
first instinct as well yes
okay so we will live to see the
ramifications of this move
looks like uh jan's back at the board
he's about to move as well he has
started to make his moves very quickly
again yeah and he's not very much at the
board which is slightly surprising
because this feels like you need to
calculate quite a lot it's really sharp
yeah
jan's last decision so forcing that he's
asking questions of magnus and there we
go as predicted he captures this pawn
yan he is now hitting the black rook in
the center of the board
i'm hoping our viewers were in time to
submit some move suggestions there
they're normally very very fast
uh nearly as fast as jan making his
moves yeah is even faster
critical moment again for magnus they
keep coming these critical moments for
him but but
i mean what will he do now
how many options do you see him having
now he said they're going to take that
white pawn in the center of the board
but that looks a bit risky that looks a
bit risky but it could also be that it
simply works there is nothing direct and
then it just equalizes the game but he
must have already calculated this right
when he was calculating for 11 minutes
there
what will happen with this move and then
is it to move the rook or to take the
pawn that's the question move the record
take the pawn and uh the players often
we see them spend a lot of time when
it's maneuvering when it's planning we
saw magnus burn a lot of time where to
put the pieces but
as soon as it becomes calculation just
very short sharp variations they are
fantastically good and
have we predicted all of this because
magnus does indeed bring his rook to the
center guarding the black pawn so if the
black pawn is captured in the middle now
by white's rook or by white's porn we'll
just see a bunch of trades everything
get eliminated
magnus is really trying to force the
issue and he did
the confidence trick that every single
player does when they're feeling ready
and
very pleased with their position they
make their move they walk off yeah
when you see that happening you should
be a little bit careful
and
you know david mentioned that a lot of
time was spent by magnus but i have to
say the viewers were quick with their
guess the move answers
and we do have a winner
the one-year membership of g chess goes
to chessplayer01 who said guess
correctly the move he takes d4
so yeah you have a fabulous resource at
your fingertips enjoy congratulations
yeah definitely chessplayer01
that sounds like a very nice name to
have on twitter as well i wonder if it
is a famous grandmaster maybe
i think i saw neil's tweeting
i remember one winner was simu
[Laughter]
so yeah chess player one or maybe it's
the who the first grand master of all
time who was that
question when was the grandmaster title
invented sorry 70s 60s 70s
we'll have to have our historian simon
williams check that out
tweet us if you know the answer at home
yeah uh because there were lots of
players who were grandmaster strength of
course but fidelity introduced the title
quite late but i think at least they
introduced
like retrospectives yeah but also many
grand masters at once the first time
like they awarded the title to a to a
group of people who uh
yeah just went exactly like i don't know
how many but maybe 10 or something like
that 15 grandmasters at once yeah and
then they invented this whole system
that we have still nowadays and the
federation the
fee day i can't remember what it stands
for but the federation international
there's a sex it's like the government
body they kind of didn't establish until
1920 something yeah
and i think we have to show uh the move
that's just landed on the board white
did indeed retreat the queen hitting the
black rook um just to explain why white
didn't capture the pawn in the center
for example if white captures with the
pawn then the black knight simply
captures this pawn and
the queen the rook defend this night
perfectly and uh we would just see a
bunch of traits i think there's just one
small tactic i want to show here after
knight takes night after uh okay
actually black can take this night with
his queen maybe but after rook takes
rook there would be queen takes night
and now white could try flicking in a
rook check which is a nice distraction
tactic so for example the black rook if
it catches this rook would drop the
black queen and white would win some
material here but maybe the simplest of
all for black would be for example in
this position not to actually rush to
take the rook off the board but first to
capture the knight and now after queen
takes queen uh there would be an
intermediate move as vishnu where rook
takes rook jack first is flicked in and
only now does black take the queen so
you always got to look out for these
tricks these checks these captures and
uh black is at least fine here because
this pawn is going to drop potentially
and maybe as well whoops
the pawns on the fourth rank are also
vulnerable black would be doing
fantastically and likewise if
black uh if white sorry had taken on d4
with the rook we were the same
we would have seen the same or similar
idea black can take this pawn at any
moment you don't actually need to rush
so instead of walking into that tactic i
showed maybe black can just wait a move
or two for example just push a pawn and
this pawn will fall eventually um that's
why ianna pognechi decided to drop back
hitting the rook and magnus has indeed
shuffled across to the f4 square we
mentioned this earlier
it looked clumsy it's very rare to see a
rook on this square
but if it works it works and the same
issue if white captures on the d4 square
now then black is just going to capture
the other pawn and everything is going
to get hovered off
what do we think guys is this
is this conceivable for white pushing a
pawn forward attacking the black brook
is this the last
attempt it might backfire though it
might backfire yeah and also it might
still be this uh
black gives up the rook in order to get
perpetual check yeah so this almost
trapped it can retreat but this would
lose a pawn so instead as nose mentions
you give up the rook you capture the
white knight and once the rook
disappears black can take this pawn with
a check if white wants to win you have
to run away with the king if you run
this side the black queen will continue
checking maybe you can even take this
pawn with check um so if you run the
other way this is the big question
but this king is running out into the
open yeah it looks uh inside yeah
insanely dangerous for for white
actually like yeah yeah for example the
black knight could jump into the game
and the white king in massive danger wow
yeah and the material gain is even not
that great yeah look for a knight only
two points but desperate times calls for
desperate measures you guys let's go
back down to dubai tanya you're in the
lounge i understand where team carlson
is following game 11.
god there's so much buzz and hype inside
the chess 24 lounge come on in with me
and i'll show you guys what's going on
here
we've got magnus's sister ellen is there
henrik's here and i've just spotted the
mustache guy as well hey how's it going
it's going very well thank you
what was that like on live television
getting a shave
um
yeah i was kind of weird to be honest
and i don't think i'm
supposed to be called the mustache guy
anymore like former mustache guy or
something but uh no it was it was funny
it was funny to be honest it's super
nice to have you here with us enjoy uh
lots of action here we also see
uh partners of chess24 here and i also
spot morton he is the former president
of the norwegian chess federation hey
hello
how's it going it's going very great
it's very nice to be here i can imagine
especially given the mad situation with
magnus being having a three-point lead
that's a good feeling that's a very good
feeling and for some of us who have
planned this trip for more than
just a few days we actually maybe hope
for a draw so we can prolong the match a
little bit
definitely i understand that now you
have been for
the london world championship match as
well as the new york world championship
match and now you're here in dubai
how's this different
well first of all being present in the
world championship match is unique it's
historical it's very nice
to be present here the playing venue
is very very good
there is also room for more spectators
than earlier so more supporters can come
and join and it's it's very nice
i can imagine it is a spectacular venue
now magnus says on the word of his fifth
world championship title uh of course
that's that's huge
tell us a little bit about his
contribution to norwegian chess i mean
is it accurate to say that he invented
chess in norway is that close to the
truth that's a nice metaphor yes yeah
without him we would not been standing
here
having the chess brokers all over the
world and in norway it's uh
he's really popularized the sport in
schools and there are more members than
ever in the chess federation so indeed
he has really done everything for
norwegian chess
that's really nice to hear and tell me
if he does he goes on to win this title
what will that mean for norway
that we can keep uh well developing like
we have done and we still have of course
we are proud of him being the world
champion so uh that's very very nice
thank you so much martin for joining us
uh what can i say it's a bit of a party
today here in the chess 24 lounge of
course the game is heating up so back to
you guys
thank you tanya so nice to see uh the
moustache man again back in he's in
dubai now he was in the studio and we
did shave off that massage and i wonder
maybe simon could you be next
it's just not happening all right
you keep that razor well away from me
all right
so uh i would never touch the ginger
beer no i would have legendary no i'd
lose all my strength which you know it's
not that much but anyway um but yeah um
yeah great to see the moustache guy i
think he's been the legend
broadcast now people loved him which is
fantastic and uh yeah i mean this game
at the moment it seems like uh magnus
has
found a very good way to to deal with
that slight pressure which uh yan was
putting on the position so
i think they're in the lounge of chess
24 lounge most of uh magnus's supporters
will be be pretty happy i think at the
moment so we are waiting to see what
young pogniacci will do he's been
thinking for five minutes now on this
move and talking about legendary
moustache man legendary beards we are
talking about the legend gary casparo as
well
known by most people also magnus carlsen
that's the best chess player
ever now what will it take for rangers
carlson to overtake that sort of title
um quite a lot i mean uh basically uh
you know gary did rule the chess world
for about 20 years and he won everything
so not just the world championships like
if it was a big tournament wake and z uh
other big tournaments he'd win it yeah
uh magnus carson um could well be a
stronger player at the moment with the
advancements in chess but he needs to
dominate the chess world for a bit
longer he's doing a great job at the
moment obviously by by uh taking the
lead in this match but he he needs to
again just just really maybe get a
couple more years of domination under
his belt to to get that legendary status
or well he's pretty legendary at the
moment yeah more legendary status
um
gary was just so dominant and he was
such a scary player to play yeah and you
imagine even when he retired uh was it
2005 he was still world number one
he was still world number one and i i
really like this this way of retiring
you know retiring at the top i mean who
knows if magnus is going to do the same
maybe he'll be like after this match
she'd be like that's it that's me done
i'm gonna do other things now i've done
it i've done it all you know uh i doubt
it because he's got hopefully someone
like uh ali raza what i call him the
razer
sharp attacker and i'm sure he'd love to
play a world championship match against
him i mean we all love to see that
that'd be fascinating as many other
players he could of course play if he
wins this world championships when he
wins this one yeah exactly
well so even if gary he retired in 2005
he lost his world championship title in
2000
to vladimir kramnik and uh you were
present were you i was yeah i i was i
was a
little ginger
without the bed baby ginge and um it was
quite funny i i i wasn't really sure
what i was doing with my life um i ended
up here somehow and i got a phone call
from my friend and he said simon i i
know you need a bit of cash do you want
a job at the world championships it was
in london uh in the year 2000 and he
said uh you can have a job um in the
theater showing people to their chairs
so i was like wait yeah i get i get paid
to watch the world championships to show
people to their chairs 10 pounds an hour
not bad for a youngster yeah and i got
there really excited so i've shown
people to the chairs thinking gary
kasparov what match is going to be
sacrifices every game bang bang bang
kramnik probably going to beat kramnik
berlin
that's when the berlin yeah that's when
the berlin started berlin oh no berlin
end game end game yeah berlin
i was like okay yeah you're right but
that's when the berlin started but uh so
uh vladimir kramnik he had huge success
with it even even if it's not the
favorite opening right he did have huge
success with berlin he did it was an
inspired opening choice um brilliant
opening choice he worked with gary
kasparov four years previously i think
when gary was going towards the world
championships and
he found the way to cause gary problems
gary was this big fire energy on the
board and what you do to fight to put it
out you throw water on it and he used
the berlin named after the berlin wall
because you put up this strong wall of
defense and he played this in every
possible game he could against gary and
gary with the white pieces was visibly
annoyed by this great defensive opening
and kramnik won one great game with
white and that was i think enough to win
he just
really took the sting out of gary's
explosive play yeah and so the shift
happened gary caspar was no longer world
champion it was vladimir kramnik we know
well he's even played in mel torture
champions chess tour fantastic chess
commentator but as a chess player and as
a world champion what was he like
he he was he was a brilliant uh chess
player throughout his career he's one of
the young and the last soviet world
champion
um and he was very very talented at a
young age and he had this uh maybe we
have a move oh yeah so we do wow we do
have
g3s g3 really been played yeah okay
we're about to see a result okay i think
there's this yeah definitely this must
be going to a draw right no no no
jan has chosen to fall on his sword this
is just a blunder um wow he's just i
think he just knows it's one last roll
of the dice
a draw today and the match is almost
over anyway and uh
right now it's the variation we showed
black can just take the white knight the
black queen is going to come in it's
going to be a deadly attack and magnus
is going to win
wow this is unbelievable is about to win
the game and therefore yeah the 2021
world championship match
wow
there we can see the stockfish
suggestions as well if magnus doesn't
find this move he's actually almost
losing so he has to find it
for sure he's seen the idea we can see
magnus as well
zooming in just working out the
variations but um
yeah i mean it's no surprise i think
even this variation the most white can
hopefully draw anyway so it's no
surprise that black will be able to find
a winning variation later we'll show it
as it comes but um
nails you shocked are you surprised i
mean magnus looks very surprised and i'm
i'm equally surprised yeah that's very
it's a very very strange decision yeah
and magnus finds the right yeah of
course he's played it yeah he played it
like it's down the good night early for
us then there was no other
but jan forced magnus to find this move
there was no other logical option for
the norwegian he had to take the white
knight he's giving up the black rook in
the process but then the black queen is
going to jump in the black knight is
actually it looks like it's not doing
too much but it's within striking range
of the white king potentially
and
okay some
problems there maybe something with
arbiter yeah yeah it looks like maybe
magnus has had something going on
because
he had to get his face in didn't he one
more time he's like yep i'm here yeah
i've done a good job uh so well done
arbiter you got your moment of fame yeah
because will this game be over in a few
moves if that's what's happening i think
the world championships could be over um
just look at white's king um and maybe
we should follow it on the board because
the white king is just too exposed here
and i think yeah i don't know what's
happened with jan he's he's better than
this and uh i love jan as a player but
um he he probably doesn't want to be
here anymore
yeah and uh just to show some variations
i mean once the white king does get
checked black is about to uh have his
rook captured black will give this check
the white king has to move most likely
this way is the safest but that looks
like a few options here for black many
many options they are very tempting
maybe
give a check with the queen looks like a
very simple way the king has to go
upwards probably
and then now for instance just take the
pawn on f2 removing the last defender of
white's king next you can bring the
knight or even the rook towards uh and i
mean you can't even take this pawn with
white because there's gonna be a track
exactly the skewer the white queen will
fall and as you mentioned once white
just moves the rook now you bring the
knight in and i mean how's this guy
going to survive like even even
materially speaking you're not doing
badly with black here you have full
material equality you just have this
huge attack for absolutely free
i mean
it looks
and also as you were saying a couple of
times already that the maximum white can
hope for here is a draw yeah in all the
lines and like why why would you then
play it with the
with white yeah it's very strange i mean
in all of these variations black will be
able to just give loads of checks at
some point if he wants to um also in
this position you could consider maybe
even just capturing this pawn maybe even
um
whoops sorry if the king goes this way
maybe capture this pawn some lines you
can even go this way i'm very tempted to
jump this side
but okay we do see this position on the
board right now um the rook was indeed
captured and then black gave a check
and the reason we're expecting this way
is just because there's more shelter if
you step the other side it feels like
sooner or later there's going to be a
deadly check
um i mean you could take it
on while you think and
then get on with it yeah and then i mean
the knights coming in yeah even the rook
will at some point get lifted up here
can swing across white's king is just
naked and it's doomed
wow there's no way it's going to survive
this attack i find it it's very
surprising this um this this the way
it's happened because uh
jan must have realized uh what was going
to happen and he's decided literally to
just go down this way self-destruct yes
wow
wow well remember everyone if magnus
wins this game it's over he's going to
be the winner of the world championship
match he is getting very close now jan
he did however leave the board it's his
intention to keep playing this for a
little bit longer do you think
very soon he's just going to offer his
hand and and say the words i reside he
needs to play on i mean
black isn't winning well it is winning
but it is not checkmate just yet you
know he hasn't kind of gotten that
material gain
so you know
magnus still has to finish off the job
so it's just about finding those moves
that david suggested knight takes porn
it's a great tribe i quite like the
queen giving check but uh i i think
napomiacci just didn't see it wasn't in
his radar that magnus could capture the
night
i think he was just so in his mind just
thinking i attacked the rook rook moves
i have a great position and he just no i
didn't
know that like
it's uh
there is one thing that doesn't make
sense with this and that is that he
would be almost winning if the rook had
to move
and he would
not believe that magnus went into
something that is completely lost for
him immediately so he has to have
considered
the knowledge this is such a strange
decision to go into this because you
know we were discussing other moves you
know we were discussing what happens if
white jettisons are pawn with d6 but not
this if he missed something though
i mean maybe he's just assuming that
magnus is happy with the draw maybe he's
hoping that magnus gives a check and
okay he has actually given the check
maybe he's hoping that in this position
magnus is just going to keep checking
and the force to draw
but there is no way that magnus will
keep checking
and also yankees are forced to draw in
different ways without any risk right
in an earlier position yeah yeah from
his perspective it's a huge risk without
any benefit because magnus can still
make it draw however he wants okay and
he has indeed gone back this way um as
mentioned going out into the open it's
just too risky black will play ponte
spawn and this king will just not
survive in the center of the board
facing off against all of white's pieces
so he has indeed gone back to where he
came from but now magnus if he wants to
give us an extra day's entertainment
tomorrow then he'll give a check and
just repeat the position with a
three-fold uh with perpetual check but
that's very unlikely i think yeah never
gonna happen but how will he how will he
actually decide the game instead maybe
bring the rook up yeah
that's his main defensive id but uh even
even we should show this rook yeah
and after a check there is this nice
move queen takes rook uh giving up the
queen because you attack the black queen
in the process exactly so this would be
a big blunder on magnus's partner you
shouldn't go for this necessarily
so okay what's he going to do is he
going to give another check and then
think
he could do that it would be quite
practical especially considering he has
a little bit less time so he gives
himself a bit more time to think to get
close to move 40. yeah they get extra
time and one thing i was just pointing
out to nils actually as well um black's
knight could join the action for example
if he gives another check black's knight
could spring forward and i had this idea
that after pawn takes pawn i could just
give another check and this is going to
end in disaster for white because for
example if you block with the queen
there's a night check and a checkmate in
the corner and uh this type of idea i'm
sure there's very many variations of it
many alternative routes but this type of
idea is on the cards if magnus is
accurate and yeah i mean with 45 minutes
on the clock you can't imagine magnus in
the current position
taking the draw or missing the win no
that's very very unlikely uh
so maybe one takes pawn as well it's
very tempting any options yeah many
that's the only problem maybe too many
attempting options but okay jumping
forward he only needs to find one and
that's it yeah jumping with the knight
you can even take the central pawn with
the rook i think it's also not
even taking here yeah yeah yeah even
this looks very strong and as nils
mentioned if we do a quick count yes
it's rook for night but black actually
has two pawns
uh black has a four versus two advantage
on the king side on the right side is it
down to the pawns why this is better for
magnus because you know you would think
too
the king to the king yeah look to it
it's got no cover
that is so open yeah that's the main
thing and when you have a queen sniffing
around and followed by rook
you're in big big trouble and a knight
is the magical number and it's like oh
nice and queen that the best combo when
you when it comes to an attack so even
if white can swap off a set of rooks the
queen and knight together especially if
black has a couple of pawns
i mean they'll can they'll form a
long-term attack even if magnus misses a
short-term win wow
the bar is saying 9.1 advantage for
magnus carlsen what could be the last
game of the world championship match but
is it again options
the problem of all the options i'm
having a look here and so far i've got
four lines four lines all completely
winning for black so i mean the most
convincing it says actually in this
position just pawn takes pawn
and then once the queen slides across
bring the rook up invite everyone to the
party and that is just game over wow and
the problem for
for napoli actually is that the kind of
combo of the rook and the queen
controlling and dominating checking the
king is uh
well it's something that we kind of
learn
when we first start to play chess and we
see that magnus just working out the
variations he spent three minutes maybe
he'll spend a few more but for sure he's
seen that idea ivanka
for sure he has seen it yeah maybe we
can just show this on the board just
very quickly before magnus moves uh just
as evangel mentions pawn takes pawn it's
a check you have to take with the queen
so you don't even have to calculate
anything here if white takes with the
king there's this nasty skewer
so after queen takes pawn just bring
another piece into the attack rook up
and rook across and it will cost white
a lot of material to stop this or it's
just going to be checkmate and nothing
else to do for example if the queen
steps across you just pin it and win it
and
yup you win the white queen it's just
game over
nothing else to do for example if you
try to stop this
after pawn takes pawn if you try to stop
it by pushing a pawn this pawn is just
captured by the white uh by the black
knight and again routine ritchie sixth
deadly threat
i see no other defense
it's just resignation looks like regular
resignation immediately yeah yeah so
this is
maybe the most straightforward you can
be a bit fancy about it but just taking
this pawn and bringing the black brook
up
and we will see
a world champion
wow
wow
well that escalated quickly
simon john isn't even sitting by the
board he doesn't want to be there what
do you think he's doing in his lounge
now
i'm
i i don't know i don't think he's going
to be very happy that that's for sure
and
it's very it's very strange um
what's going on yeah but to be honest
because he didn't turn up with his
normal trainers i think that's the first
sign there might be something in the
camp which might be uh affecting him
he's much better than this he's he's a
much stronger player than his show in
this world championships he's a
brilliant player
and something seems to have been a
little bit off um and
it's a bit disappointing i feel for him
because we all have bad times we all
have something going wrong and in chess
at this level it can be amplified very
much and
just the decision he's made here is
really really peculiar it's kind of like
okay i don't really want to play anymore
uh to me yeah i don't know what how else
to explain it because uh
the tactic was fairly simple um he could
have gone for another game and he's gone
for this so i i i feel for him uh
actually um i feel that something's not
quite right he's a much better player
than this and
he shouldn't be remembered from this
world championships that would be very
sad yeah i have to i have to agree with
simon there and actually i think it's
the fault of the
well not the fault it's that it's the
case of the format because if we look at
the games of uh old you know we see
karpov kasparov they kind of had a
similar situation you know where karpov
raced to the lead
winning three games and it looked like
kasparov was on the edge
winning four games even but the thing
was the nature of that world
championship match was that it was the
first person to score six wins
and so you know and
because of this kasparov was able to
kind of like steady the ship by having
like 18 drawers and he didn't care you
know but he just did anything he could
to draw because he was so afraid of
losing and he was able to kind of
recover from these devastating blunders
that he'd made meanwhile time is not
napomiashi's friend in this type of
match you know he has made terrible
blunders and he's not been given the
chance to kind of make those quick draws
and just recover his kind of psyche
instead he's been forced to play again
and again and i think what we're seeing
here is just someone who's cracked
and the pressure has gotten to them and
i totally agree with simon um he
shouldn't be judged by this match he
shouldn't be judged by these blunders i
mean napoleon is a fantastic player and
i think if he were to
be in this exact same situation maybe in
a few years time
he would be it would be a much tougher
match for magnus yeah with experience as
well yeah you're right jan is a beast
he's here for a reason he's one of the
best players in the world he's beaten
all the top guys he's beaten magnus
several times it's just it's unfortunate
that after that kind of marathon game in
game six it just feels like he never
psychologically recovered i think that
was just the one game the one turning
point if he'd won that game which was
very possible we'd we'd have seen a
whole different match maybe jan would
have been the favorite um but
yeah it's just been a tough few days for
him and
we're expecting magnus now to find the
killer blow yeah
one of the caleb lawson i guess you said
four four winning lines
wow
most probably has seen a few killing
blows already and he's just double and
triple checking which one is
the cleanest but uh we've all been there
right when we know we're winning we just
want to we want to get the game over
with but sometimes it's better to sit on
the hands it's very professional not to
play too fast in this situation yeah
just
take five ten extra minutes just double
check because
a win is a win you gotta make sure you
actually get exactly i agree with you
there niels you know you need to sit on
your hands not get that rush of blood to
the head because i remember watching um
in fact england's number one michael
adams and he had a mating one
and you know most of us i think would
have just go mate in one just let's play
it but he was like
30 seconds later
but it was just we were wondering like
how many games do you think he saved by
just keeping a cool head and just kind
of
making that calm choice
i mean that's rather extreme mated one
but yeah in general it's always good to
double check things yeah if you've got
the time
wow oh i can't believe it that this
match could be about to be over of
course magnus also has to find the right
moves is it
okay here he comes here he comes he
brings his knight forward also winning
i'm pretty sure this is strong as well
as we mentioned queen and knight
together facing off against the bear
king i should just spell the end but he
does have one tricky move that might
like throw a spanner in the works
psychologically at least and that's
that's actually to push the
d-pawn one square forward okay that
would be tricky so
yandere slightly frowning
maybe uh maybe he spotted a simpler win
from magnus and he's surprised that
magnus didn't find it but
maybe we can show this uh move you
mentioned ivanka the one last remaining
hope for jan is to actually throw this
pawn down the board ignore the king
forget the king it's doomed anyway just
throw this forward
who needs a king
the whole idea is to just block this
rook's entry into the game so for
example it can no longer use this square
as a launch pad and uh if it does take
the pawn at least you get a set of rooks
off the board probably losing anyway
yeah that's uh
it's uh unfortunately it totally doesn't
work you know as well but it's still a
nice i i actually think he will play it
very much in his style such moves
from his checkmate's coming anyway
pretty much yeah yeah it doesn't help
but still yeah go down in style exactly
yeah
yeah a little bit uh i mean he's making
it that's somewhat more complicated
maybe than necessary with this knight
five but yeah it's easy to say um
he does play it immediately yeah
this kind of moves uh
i mean he would find any sleep yeah but
it's just amazing the time consumption
for jan he's played so many
kind of
instant moves at critical moments and
he's still got more than an hour on his
clock he won't take that time with him
to the next game yeah
that has been one of the big problems
for him right in the match definitely
definitely and definitely in this game
as well yeah lots of these very hard
decisions were played very very fast
he has more than half his time
left on move 27 like yeah
that's that's too much definitely in any
situation yeah it's tricky avoiding time
trouble of course you don't want to be
low on the clock and for that to cost
you later in the game but then again you
can't
i mean against the top players in the
world you just can't play instantly when
you have four or five options on every
turn and i think just a few slips here
and there just led him towards that
blunder early on earlier on and
yeah for magnus though there's been a
lot of focus on the blunders that jayana
pognat just made
actually little focus on on magnus and
you know he's played well maybe you know
in game six
that was extremely impressive and people
acknowledged that but later on it's been
more talk about the blunders does magnus
also want to finish this off in style
you know win it in a great way
he would love to and he's about to and
he's about to yeah exactly yeah
yeah i mean actually that's not
something that's very true you know
janna pomnyacci's blunders has kind of
detected from how incredible magnus has
played you know he hasn't
barring some points he hasn't seemed in
too much trouble he's been very well
prepared
and
when he's been given the chance just
like magnus carson himself said he's
been relentless
very very precise so
i mean he's played great what can i say
and nils you know him better than most
um what would you say actually separates
magnus from the rest from the
yanupornichi's from the fabiana carowan
is it just that he never blunders or he
does more than that very very rarely
yeah like in this game i mean he was in
danger in game two
and in some very brief moment in game
six
with the with this time travel and so on
um but that's it yeah all the other
games he has been in complete control so
now he's simply a
[Music]
very very stable incredibly stable
player
and right now sitting there
he sees what you see right that it's
very likely he's going to win this game
do you think he's thinking about the
situation the match as a whole
wow it's probably over or
is he quite good at just next move i
think he's thinking exclusively about
the next move wow i think that's
impressive i mean it would have crossed
his mind that he's winning and about to
finish it off but then i mean players
like magnus they're good at kind of
putting that to one side actually yeah
that could also be a an answer to your
previous question david that's what
separates him like that is one of the
things that really separates magnus from
the other top players even i think yeah
that he's incredibly good
at forgetting what happened before like
wow maybe now he's calculating lines and
at some point he realized oh i could
have won instantly on the previous move
it will not really affect him at all
yeah whereas i think for someone like
myself i would be quite annoyed and say
spend a bit too much time thinking about
that
he's incredibly good at not doing that
yeah you can actually see it on on him
in deep thought and this is live footage
from
the chess 24 lounge with team carlson
amongst others
but look at that
the mood is just
you know you hear it talking
and there we have a tour director from
alto to champions chess tour arcus from
chess24
do it there we have henry carlson the
father of now
the world
champion the one defending his title
look at that norwegian flag can they can
they start celebrating now david uh i'm
they're ready too yeah
i think they're a bit like magnus they
won't celebrate until the final
checkmates on the board until the final
handshake but
they know it's close and since they're
playing through the game is that correct
i think they're just trying to find that
killer blow yeah just like magnus
and we're of course looking for that
killer blow as well just as they are in
the chess 24 lounge can can you see it
simon a killer blow on the board here
i'm yeah i think
you can simply take this pawn
uh my old man leg's now got a chair
perfect
i'm getting ready
oh we're being the oldest person in the
studio
david was complaining about his birthday
the other day he said oh i feel so old
and i was just like
david yeah you've got you've got a
telling off for that so uh sorry dude
but it does it of course it looks it
looks like the end now and uh
yeah i mean fantastic from magnus
carlsen as well we've got to just remind
ourselves how how brilliant he's been
he's uh he's played great chess he's
defended well he's taking his
opportunities and that room is going to
be a very happy room very soon i think
so uh yeah we're about to see the
celebrations which is i think going to
be great yeah wow
i wonder if uh so obviously the match
was supposed to last until december 14th
or 15th with uh tie breaks today is
december 10th
it's probably going to be finished a lot
earlier than planned so i wonder if
these people will stay in dubai to
celebrate enjoy the sun or if they're
going to travel home immediately
now i was actually in london in 2018 on
the final day i was just a spectator
just no affiliation with either camp but
um yeah at the moment that
magnus did win the tiebreak against
fabiano the room erupted and his camp i
mean they were celebrating throughout
the night i think they've regretted
booking their flights for the next
morning so i'm sure they'll be out there
in dubai
including magnus yeah i'm just uh
enjoying the moments and oh and i
thought i saw a little smile on his face
and here comes the move is it the killer
blow he was exhaling there maybe he i
think you're right nils i think he
realized that there was an easier kill
definitely on the previous move and just
the reason he's exhaling maybe slightly
frowning smiling um reacting is simply
that he knows it's not as easy as it
should be still winning um assignment
mentions black and even just take this
pawn uh black can flick in a queen check
first but
uh yep still a little bit of accuracy
needed i think that's the thing he
mustn't get
obsessed with the idea that
he's got checkmate or something on the
board it's just he has to give a check
and capture the pawn that's up for grabs
sometimes
it's difficult to see the simplicity
when you're looking at a position like
this and you're thinking where's the
immediate
where's the kind of immediate win but
i'm saying that in terms of like winning
a queen you know winning a rook and here
it's it's not quite about that yeah it's
more more case of like the position just
being winning in general i think
you just like play normal moves and
eventually you will win but uh i think
the game will go on for quite a while
there is no
like
way to force resignation very quickly
but uh i hope it goes on so well yeah
the prediction challenge
shall we show why like the game won't
end in the next uh
few moves so what move are we expecting
here we think maybe just capture this
pawn to be safe yeah capture the pool
give a check
first people might be asking like why
not just bring the knight to the edge of
the board to the h4 square and you know
thread and checkmate in two ways
yep threatening two different checkmates
in one um the white king looks like it's
stranded but i guess
you can take the pawn yeah i guess you
take this pawn i mean it's still surely
losing but it is losing um yeah after a
night check we see oh i should also
mention the queen now does cover this
square so there's no checkmate by the
black queen but after this knight check
thinking marching forward the most
tempting here i mean again many options
actually you can even just take this
rook but uh one option here would be
giving a check this is a skewer and
after king takes knight you take the
white queen
uh i guess the final trick is that white
can capture this pawn and this pawn is
slightly tricky to deal with
for example you don't have time to come
and take the white rook although
actually maybe even this is strong but
uh
just in case um you don't want to allow
a white queen on the board you don't
want to allow
any potential counter play
of course you could move your rook
across this looks like it's winning as
well after white challenges your rook
maybe you can bring the queen back but
some stuff to calculate here you don't
want to risk this is definitely not as
clear as you want it to be definitely
not no
um because white does have this really
really strong pawn so that's why magnus
is maybe hesitating maybe this was his
first intention it's most probably what
he missed actually yeah that he thought
that he will win the queen
win the queen and then uh yeah just the
game would it would end but in fact this
pawn on c7 it survives yeah so yeah
yeah yeah exactly real thorn in the side
um so if magnus doesn't go for this
maybe because there's too much to
calculate too much uncertainty then we
might see see him just give a check for
example
the white king sidestep and then now
just capture this pawn
to be honest i'm not sure which way he
should recapture with the pawn or with
the rook both look pretty good yeah it's
very hard to say uh yeah for example if
you take with a rook just for
simplicity's sake after a trade here um
the reason black is still winning not
just short term but long term is that
you can't even take this pawn
safely uh for example after a trek
maybe you can't take the spawn maybe
it's the best bet but uh maybe but it's
yeah it's also uh yeah you can at least
recapture it and
you can at least recapture this pawn
next and yeah for example if the queen
does come across there is this checkmate
pattern again of the queen trapping the
king in the corner queens and knights
just too strong and as niels mentions if
the king moves you can just take this
pawn
the game goes on but black is actually
okay on material and the white king is
too open
the more i look at it the more i think
maybe it's just easier though to capture
um not with the rook but with the pawn
just because in that variation this rook
is actually always hanging so uh for
example here you could even just give a
check the king moves and now take this
pawn and you win this rook on the next
it's like the rooks are really badly
placed yeah somehow it works like that
and this knight is so beautiful on f5
like yeah the knight that black has it
can never be threatened by one of white
spawns
and it's close to the white king it's
also protecting black's king
as it's at least as strong as the rook i
think that's basically it
and here comes the move
he does play this knight to the side of
the wood is still winning we should
mention should mention yeah but it's not
as easy as
as it was before
okay so this is ten minutes the last
yeah the two moves have not been very uh
clear-cut yeah for uh maybe a bit of
nerves
yeah starting to tingle
um yeah just he knows he's near the
finishing line and when you're near the
finishing line you do get a bit tense
you get a bit tight and as mentioned
white does have to take this pawn with
uh his own pawn because now the white
queen covers the second rank
now i will be expecting a check from the
black knight
i would assume so but it's not uh maybe
it's not forced but uh i'm expecting a
check with a black knight and then maybe
just knight takes rook on the next turn
but is it possible just to grab the pawn
and keep that jack in your pocket okay
so grab the whiteboard now yeah yeah
take that white pawn on d6 that's
actually another one and then do exactly
the same on the next move instead then
you have gotten rid of this dangerous
oh that's just mean
yeah i mean it's still not so maybe
clear but yeah the white queen still
can't get to the assistance of the king
yeah exactly basically like uh doing
exactly the same just give up the rook
for the pawn
yeah so you just take this board now
with the black horn and next move this
is inevitable i like this i actually
meant to take with the rook
which is very okay
which was a very strange uh way maybe to
do it but let's say white takes with the
rook threatening a check yeah so white
has to capture this rook and now you can
check we do exactly the same and we have
simply traded our rook for white spawn
yeah but this pawn was very close to
queening so
yeah so now it will be a queen versus
two rooks here the queen is definitely
superior because the rooks can't
coordinate and also
look how open the white king is yeah
we'll pick up probably a lot of pawns
quite quickly and should be winning but
again this is winning yeah long term
it's not immediately but it's not
immediately winning it's not as winning
as it's supposed to be in the position
so it's more like
2-0 uh in a football game rather than
five zero exactly exactly like things
can still go go wrong so
actually yeah maybe taking with the pawn
makes more sense
and then just keeping this one up your
sleeve for later because now you do have
an extra form with black and this is
unstoppable i said like i mentioned the
queen can't come across to defend on any
square because there's always a nasty
night check and a family fork
i was wondering whether the queen can
kind of like position herself a little
bit better in that
the move before
she can put herself on the e2 square so
that when the knight comes and gives
check the king can run up the board
without uh worry okay yeah this is maybe
the only defense maybe the best defense
after knight takes rook oh yeah knight
takes broke yeah but i mean here black
is only one point only one pawn up weak
king also so better position apart from
the pawn but
again very
much less clear than it was a few more
moves before
no he's probably also getting a bit
nervous when he's so close to finishing
that's the only explanation for missing
these easier wins earlier because it was
really especially this uh
yeah i mean earlier he could
there was very very simple yeah i was
actually the computer as i
can yeah but it's like you should
you're threatened and there is simply no
way to defend the end of line i mean
it's also very human and just to
illustrate that one more time if we go
back
so instead of this night move uh just
looking for checks that's what we teach
everyone when they start the game checks
first the queen has to recapture and
then you just create a threat and it's
game over then instead the game goes on
now
should go on a little bit but okay well
let's see what happens here instead
magnus is given a check
okay
slightly surprising because now once the
king moves there won't be any knight
jumping in with the check
is he intending to give two checks and
then think more i mean this repetition
that we were talking about before i
think that's quite likely just to get
closer he will give another check on the
next move and then it will think again
what is the most accurate way wow
well it could be getting very close for
magnus carlsen i wonder we don't know
where in the world his team are we're
you know thinking they're somewhere in a
different time zone than dubai but what
will they be doing now
else depends how professional they are
no if they are very professional they
will be sleeping because they have to
work tomorrow
but from experience i can say that
some of the teams they are normally also
following the critical moments
of course i never did it i was always
sleeping
good boy but
i saw some
some of the team members
of eagerly following the games yeah but
we haven't seen a repetition of moves on
the board instead the knight has come
and attacked the rook bar is going down
yeah the bar is not that happy still
good
still strong for black of course black
in
no danger ever really unless there's a
massive blunder because he can always at
some point regain the rook for the night
maybe and just be a pawn up
and white will always have the wiki king
but very very strange yeah the way to
this is giving white some options as
well um there's one trap in the position
um there's one move that white
definitely can't go for um white can't
play pawn takes pawn as he wanted to
earlier because now after pawn takes
pawn we see the idea behind magnus
kind of arranging his queen and knight
like this we'll see a check and next
move just a checkmate because suddenly
this file is opened up so the white king
is cut off it cannot run away
uh but
okay if we forget this move for white
there are options suddenly the queen can
maybe move yeah maybe there's a swing
you swing it over yes that looks like
the queens to the f2 square this way
so maybe this square
and uh if we do see a trade
we can see black regain the rook but
i'm worried what's happening here after
pointing yeah
yeah it's not not the way suddenly it's
white winning yeah here white is winning
suddenly white would be winning because
this point is too strong and if you try
and block it or move your rook away to
cover this then the white rook comes up
and white is the one making a queen so
you'll be slightly careful yeah
absolutely if the white queen does swing
across what has magnus got up his sleeve
gotta have a check right it's gonna be a
chat i think you have two checks
actually you can check with the knight
or yeah i didn't see that one either
with the knight or actually also with
the queen yeah with the queen was that
was my intention because now the white
queen can't block because when the rook
when the knight does capture the rook a
movement yeah it's with the track it's a
check but this is just one pawn up in
the rook and then yeah yeah
this is probably winning probably
winning but again very very far from uh
how winning it was before this one will
still go on another 10 20 moves at least
yeah another maybe two hours yeah
no no but i think it's not even that
clear if you are
winning it yeah i mean it's winning but
yeah it should be with the rook on the
open file and it's like
but it's like 80 yeah something like
this and probably i would estimate wow
unless you're magnus then it's 100 maybe
but either way this is on the board yeah
even with magnus yeah he plays queen f2
so now we're expecting a queen check
from black we mentioned this other track
with a knight but maybe this is less
effective it's less effective yeah it
can run and this knight might be
misplaced
okay so
really strange decisions we might be
headed to this rook and game wow the
game is
nearly guaranteed now to go on quite a
lot longer okay well then let's also go
down to dubai aruna standing with
someone
very interesting to hear from
absolutely kai i am here with the man
himself the big thing the grand noir
peter heiner you are the coach of magnus
carlson how how do you feel right now
well when we had some time to get used
to it as the match was going uh well
recently but of course it's uh oh it's
exciting and it's a bit uh surreal that
it's uh gonna be over so soon it's
something we've worked for for well a
long time obviously and such and also
it's been unexpected it's today and not
tomorrow but uh well we're just uh very
happy what can i say
and the matches of colton actually over
because the game is not actually over
but how
how big is the risk of magnus will throw
this away
well i mean well as far as i can see he
gets an ending a pawn up which looks uh
completely winning according to the
computer well if he doesn't win it they
have to play tomorrow but that was
expected anyway i mean it's just a good
match situation so
well it's too early to celebrate and
you're not going to get me to do that
but it's hard not to be optimistic
obviously i understand that
and you're the man with the opening plan
how big how big of a role has the
openings played so far
well
i'm part of a team who's doing the
openings but i'm the one on the spot
here and uh well i think we always say
that the less of a role he played the
better is for magnus and i think well
openings has not been decisive in this
match she has been
the actual player on the board and i
think magnus himself and others like me
said before that well we have no doubt
magnus is the best player in the world
when it comes to playing chess at the
board and i think he's proven that and
in that sense uh the strategy has been a
success for us in matter of
having things decided at the chessboard
let's say that magnus wins this game
would you say that magnus won this world
championship or will you say that nepo
lost it
i mean
well a game of chess is always decided
by a mistake i think that's the logic uh
of course but well no it's all credit to
magnus he's put a lot of pressure on
nepal
and uh
well you have to provoke mistakes and
magnus has done this beautifully i mean
he's made very few mistakes and he's put
a lot of pressure and to do this in
combination it's very impressive i mean
so well it's obviously
magnus who has pushed him very hard and
out of his comfort zone all the time and
this is the way to induce mistakes
thank you so much peter there you have
it from the man himself finally out from
hiding it's been so hard to get an
interview with this guy thank you so
much as you can see the the vibe is just
like crazy here but the game is not over
yet what do you think will happen the
next couple of moves guys yeah
definitely thank you so much for
bringing peter heine nelson out of
hiding
interesting to hear from the the big
coach right
he doesn't seem to worry though yeah i
think the reason he's come out of hiding
is because he probably did see that
strange mistake from jan earlier
and uh yeah he's confident we're less
confident on the show maybe after these
last couple of moves but still it does
look quite promising for black
and yan finally spending a bit of time
what do you think is he going to block
this check with the white queen is he
going to move the white king
well if he moves the white king he might
be in serious danger in fact immediately
lost because then you can't actually go
knight takes work okay so he's only got
two legal moves in the position
um this is a check you have to either
block it with the white queen which
we're expecting and we'll come to this
in a moment or you have to run away uh
and now you mention your banker just
knight takes rook yeah and now the thing
is that you can't go okay you can take
the knight and that should be i would
put the chances of black winning that at
pretty high yeah almost almost 100 times
but i mean the whole point is that you
can't go pawn takes pawn you know and
get a nice powerful rook because of
course you have queen um two g4 check
and what does the undo there's a skewer
and this rook would fall so it looks
like he's gonna have to block with his
queen that's the only option um he did
go for it and now we will see queens
leave the board and now the knight will
capture this white rook we'll see
another trade and then at the very end
black will take this pawn it's three
versus two on the right half of the
board but more importantly i think this
uh the black crook is more active than
his counterpart it's already threatening
to infiltrate and go after the white
pawns we're about to reach this position
and if white's rook steps up maybe the
simplest actually is to come behind and
to start going for some of white's
remaining pawns here
um more active rook and with one extra
pawn magnus should win but still some
work to be done ah
interesting stuff
kenya on the ponyachi save this and take
it to one more game in the world
championship match let's head down to
tanya what is the mood there now tanya
is people
looking at this to finish now
oh
absolutely kaia i'm once again inside
the playing when you the playing hall
and as you can see behind me it is
absolutely jam-packed uh magnus carlsen
is on the prank on the verge of his
fifth world championship title
both players are seated they haven't
moved and that's a rare sight usually we
always see one of them uh getting up and
moving around once again inside the hall
i can't speak too loudly i don't know if
you guys can hear it but right now it's
just amazing to see the crowd here every
time a game ends there's a massive
applause a massive applause and today
it's going to be deafening
but yes as you mentioned the sequence of
moves has just happened i think a lot of
people expected it to finish a little
earlier uh with more dynamic more
powerful play by magnus but magnus has
chosen the strategic approach of going
into the sun game so probably a little
more to play but this is an amazing
crowd in here
wow
i almost start whispering myself that is
very cool tanya and i can just imagine
the applause and
the cheering from the crowd if the match
finishes today and uh i don't know and
how much time will this game now take
it could take a bit longer um i think it
would definitely go to mu 40. um we've
seen that in the past from jan even when
he was losing
uh he forced magnus to get to the time
control and magnus doesn't have that
much time he's got 20 minutes now to
make the next seven moves um so
yeah i think he'll play to move 40 and
then he'll reassess
but
myself and nils were just analyzing some
variations then it does look like black
should be able to win in quite a kind of
direct manner
um just by bringing the black rook now
down to the second rank going after
those white pawns over there on the
queen side
that being said some calculation needs
to be done yeah it's like uh it's most
probably winning and his big favorite to
win but
we should also not forget about the
history of the game like probably he
there he's fairly convinced that he
missed some very simple wins before
which
could be a bit uh disturbing he's very
good at not having those thoughts but
of course when you are so close to
defending your title they they do creep
in so yeah and this is the best
positions had in the last 12 moves so
yeah that tends to help
psychology
but uh maybe we can show justice
magnus's thinking
i think there's two approaches one you
just take it really slow you maybe just
centralize the black king you start
pushing these black pawns inching them
forward but
there's no given that maybe white will
find some counter play by pushing pawns
in the center or by pushing pawns on the
flank and uh you have to work some
things out so magnus he'll be most
attracted to going direct bring the rook
forward in any position you want to look
for threats uh this attack's important
and
okay there's no chance you can trade
rooks now because black has an extra
pawn in the kingdom game this will
simply win the game long term and uh
okay if you can't trade the rooks you
have to push forward you can't go
passive with your rooks and now we were
debating this rook sliding across um
maybe you could also use the square but
yep the rook sliding across a trade of
pawns and white rook trying to get
active you need to get this piece into
the game black will take upon and now i
guess the idea is to deliver a check
and now white will maybe regain one of
these two pawns but the problem is that
black's rook can just slide across and
in a position like this one where yes
the pawns are all disappearing the issue
is that black has the passports this
pawn running down the board and when
white takes the time out to go and stop
it you will see that white's rook will
be tied down is he gone for this magnus
he is going for something like this and
it's a two point advantage for black but
it's not just this pawn and this pawn
being passed it's also the fact that
he's gonna have to do
well white here is gonna have to deal
with two flank pawns running it's like a
two horns
how do you stop them both um this pawn
is running this pawn is going to tie
down the white rook and yes white has a
passport himself
but
yeah that's not going to be enough
surely wow what do you think simon now
is it getting close for magnus carlsen
yeah i think it's getting closer it
reminds me of a story that uh ivan
sokolov told me once he he was playing
for his country on board one against
gary kasparov when uh kasparov was was
world champion and he got a winning
position and he thought okay i'm gonna
enjoy this moment i'm just gonna you
know gary was very uh or you know very
emotional knew he was losing and he
could have played very quickly but he
thought you know i'm just going to enjoy
winning this game so he played very
slowly he saw the pain on gary
kasparov's face you know he took his
time enjoying the moment and uh maybe
maybe magnus is is doing a similar thing
here possibly enjoying the moment um
it's clear he's going to win he's the
best endgame player ever um as long as
he doesn't uh think too much uh about
becoming well being world champion
yeah that sounds so mean it is mean the
chess players can be mean you know you
have to always remember that quote you
know
chess is a street fight
when your opponent is down you kick them
it's a cruel cruel game we have it's
very fun as well
i mean
yeah totally but uh one thing that i
kind of wanted to stress here i think
magnus has to maybe abandon this concept
of letting um just having control
complete control he has to maybe embrace
the fact that he's material up that he
has passed pawns and moves that i can
see that would not be necessarily the
best would be actually just to slide the
rook and try to keep those queen side
pawns contained because maybe white can
activate the king instead this is magnus
to a t precise
he's just getting ready to push up his
pawns on the right
and we saw some variations where the
white rook came up and checked the black
king the black king forced to kind of
abandon some pawns by going to the side
he's just created a nice safe haven for
his king and yeah those black pawns
those two over there on that side
they'll start inching forward soon
meanwhile jan is going active with his
pawns
and
okay at least it's definitely not easy
now
it's not easy at all no no no yeah some
work has to be done
um i was going to say a few moves
earlier magnus's biggest opponent is
himself because
i mean he is the only one getting in his
nerves of the only thing getting in the
way of winning but now it's not just
himself he has to contend with jan who's
defending quite well over the last few
moves okay white's rook is at least
finally active
all right well the game is not over uh i
do not are people sort of able
to hold off with a celebration here
well not not really to be honest i am
here with
one of the most famous people in the
entire world at least until you lost the
mustache the
former mustache where i mean as a friend
of magnus carlsen chest fan how do you
feel right now
i'm feeling really excited that this
seems uh
this seems to be going the way and
magnus might be uh world champion yet
again after this game i believe
how do what how easy do you think the
position is to play
um it seems to me that magnus has
consolidated quite well and that he's
got a healthy extra pawn and i
yeah magnus is the
master of endgames and he will
surely win this
he will surely win this but magnus he
says never ever celebrate before the
match is over are you changing it a
little bit here because everybody's
celebrating
i hope i'm not uh
and i hope uh
now magnus will win this i'm quite sure
he uh he has full control of this i'm
sure i would like to personally thank
you for losing the mustang so i can get
back in the competition for best beard
with ginger gm and then i would like to
ask you do you have any questions or
messages you would like to send to
anybody uh yeah i have one question for
the studio uh directed to david uh david
what happened on the good night on
tuesday the world wants to know guys
okay
uh directed that directly to you i hate
you you're christian uh thinking like
girls
um yeah
so i've played him i must mention i've
played mustache man young christian many
many many times and i've won every
single game but on tuesday he finally
got me
after having many beers
no comment
well well well well
i bet a lot of beers
plus it's been in the studio learning
from you as well david exactly so he
knows he knows your style now he knows
the tricks i was just being generous he
needed an ego boost before going out to
dubai before hanging out with all these
superstars you know exactly just being a
good friend yeah and oh and what was the
clock times were you equal on club yeah
yeah i mean he's a good player i should
mention really tricky really aggressive
and uh yeah you deserve that way ah
interesting all right well janna
pogbachie thinking about
next move is he desperately trying to
save this or will he
does he really want to be someone else
just finish this off he looks like he's
trying to save it yeah no i think he's
definitely trying his best here to see
if there are any chances
it's just one of those unfortunate
things you know you make one of those
huge blunders howler as we kind of call
him in the uk
but uh you know your opponent isn't
quite as accurate in finishing you off
but the position is still lost
you know but you would you will try to
save it and you can see he is working
hard but whether he wants to be there
the top chess players though they've
turned it into a skill just suffering
for hours and everyone blunders every
occasionally everyone gets outplayed you
have to be able to save these types of
games if you want to get to the top and
jan's done that plenty of times this one
i'm not sure he's going to save i don't
think he will but
he'll be looking for ways and
just looking off to the side there i was
just wondering whether he was looking
back to the past regretting that
decision of g3 earlier in the game
whether he's just trying to calculate
i mean what to calculate here one idea
could be running forward with the white
king over to that left side over towards
some black pawns but then black does
have this important h pawn harry might
win the game simon harry the h pawn is
black's passport after all
ah okay what's he gonna do he does
indeed run forward with the king oh wow
there's nothing else to do
is it vulnerable or is it uh great
attacking now
well the king is an attacking piece in
the end game it needs to get mobilized i
mean i always say visualize the king to
begin with in the opening and the middle
game as an old man nervy old man who
you're constantly having to justify
every action you take but in the end
game it's like he's just
shed his age and jimin
exactly become young and just imagine
them as like a young fit man you know
how
dashing
in the wind and he wants to be involved
he wants to steal all the gore glory and
so that's why the king should be
mobilized
unfortunately there is the issue of this
past aged pawn harry
that might be in the way of the king's
active dreams how happy are you simon
that harry is maybe the star of the
final game
harry always wins the day
i also find it quite funny you know
david always mentions oh it's a one-off
when anyone beats him it
we've heard that a is of times now david
so i mean
some doubts creeping in i think about
grand master simon we love to make
excuses the only thing i'm better at
than jess is making it
and look at that you're probably
actually did he just look at magnus
try to get some eye contact he he's not
about to give up is he no no no
definitely definitely not i mean he's
going active with the king and we could
show his plan and maybe there's a bit of
a race involved now as well it could be
because white wants to run over here
he's going off to this point and maybe
the poor next to it meanwhile magnus is
indeed pushing harry he wants harry to
become harriet uh by turning it into a
queen
um and okay uh have we seen an instant
move there by nepali no not yet i'm
expecting him to just run because what
else if you step back and kind of keep
an eye on harry running forward then
you're just going passive the king came
from here before and black has all the
time in the world to slowly improve
so he's going forward with the king and
uh it is indeed a race will the king be
quicker to gobble up these pawns or will
harry
win the day well it looks like the king
will be quicker
yeah let's uh play it out okay let's
play that let's say this pawn marches
forward again the king is getting close
to those pawns if the pawn marches
forward
i'm wondering whether you can get away
with taking this guy now um
and this pawn will be stopped by the
white rook that being said at the very
least that can just take this guy now
maybe there are options
and then maybe start just going for some
of these pawns
but then again some
some calculations still to be done if
white goes after harry and
i think black is winning still but the
pawns are starting to disappear so
um okay this is what jan is asking
magnus as magnus ticks down to 13
minutes
do you have time to push or do you need
to take some time out to guard against
the white threat of going after these
pawns i mean to stop this maybe you
could consider dropping the what the
black rook back yeah that looks like a
very decent move no yeah but then again
the white rook maybe will attack the sea
pawn and if then you push
because then the rook can no longer get
back to
stopping the pawn maybe not the spawn
that's at least an idea i mean either
here or on the on the previous move as
well yeah on the previous move yeah here
because now if you take the pawn with
the rook it's
very hard to get this rook back to stop
the pawn yeah yeah
even even impossible actually and it
comes with check as well yeah and also
uh if you try this then we should
mention the white pawn stepping forward
will not be able to help because black
just teams up the pawns together
these two pawns now will decide the game
gary and harry simon
look hand in hand looks uh looks
actually fairly convincing he had this
move a little move with the rook yeah so
maybe these are the two options for
black either running with a pawn strong
but maybe a bit too direct or just
stepping back with a black rook trying
to tie down white pieces to the weak
pawns
hey
magnus he shouldn't be in too much time
trouble he's got two moves to make one
more after he's made this one yeah
and 12 minutes should be enough to get
another hour on the clock and the bar
has gone up again for him now saying 4.8
it's liking it
more and more again for the for the
black pieces yeah i think the computer
it went down for a while it went down to
what was it plus high plus ones low plus
twos but that was simply because the
horizon wasn't deep enough i think black
was winning long term anyway but the
computer will see to a point and say
okay white's surviving but yan rather
than sit there passively which isn't
human nature which isn't advised in end
games he's gone for the active route and
that means maybe he's still losing and
maybe it's easier for black now
black's advantage growing but then again
maybe the path for black to win is
narrower so it makes a lot of sense to
at least try something
rather than sit and suffer and is it
some of the hardest thing you do in
chess to calculate these races
can be quite tricky yeah but on the
other hand it's also
like the lines are very long because
it's many moves involved but they are
not so wide there are not that many
options like if you are pushing the pawn
like it's it's only one move yeah that
you have to calculate on each turn so
both yes or no i would say uh
it can be it can be tricky but it in
some sense it's also easier yeah there's
different ways of calculation i mean one
of them is where there's loads of
branches where as nils mentions you have
to go back to step one and think okay i
have to look at these three moves and
after that i have three options against
each one and then you have to
i mean you can get carried away
sometimes calculating that but uh
personally i do prefer this where it's
just very direct i push you do that i do
this you do that and yeah it might be
five ten moves long each but
if you think about it if you break it
down logically and keep things simple
then it should be
i mean should make things simpler
well magnus calls and his clock is
ticking down he has to make another move
now to reach more 40 and he will gain um
another hour on the clock now simon were
almost through with the world champions
we covered uh 14
but we haven't talked about vichy and on
yet
that's right yeah the great anand yeah
and um it's a pretty we haven't had a
chance to uh get to him quite yet but uh
anand
was a hero for so many people and still
is um
we see now the generation of young
indians coming through and i wouldn't be
surprised in the next 10 years if we uh
if we don't have an indian world
champion and that's probably due to the
influence that anand had when he became
world champion and uh he is an amazing
player a lot of people say one of the
most naturally gifted players ever to
play wow
there was a great video of him actually
uh i can recall when he's
playing a blitz game so a five minute
game i think it's on youtube and uh he
sits there without playing the first
move for two minutes
uh and he's just thinking about his game
strategy which was which was uh quite
special but
uh yeah a a legend over in india and uh
yeah well i think we covered him now
anyways
exactly we're done we've done for
everyone
but he must be one of the most
influential people in chess just because
of the boom that he has created in india
and
probably in the next 10 20 30 40 50
years
maybe a bunch of challengers to the
throne will come from india yeah i think
if we look at the up and coming nations
we've got india
which is incredibly strong they've got
so many youngsters who are playing chess
and chess is massive over there so he's
done a great job of supporting that um
other nations well china was doing very
well recently with some players also
iran has had quite a boom of players but
india
i would expect a world champion at some
point in the next 20 30 years coming
from there yeah at least the great
vishwanathan anand who lost his title to
magnus carlson in 2013
and magnus carlsen for the fifth time is
about to defend
his world championship title question is
of course how long will he keep it and
will it be an indian player who comes
and snaps it from him who who among the
indian players today is the most likely
to be maybe the first one to challenge
the throne and in some years
good question um i should also mention i
think anand was the first indian
grandmaster and now they have over 70.
yeah wow there seems to be several every
year um i've played pragnando a few
times he beat me when he was 12. he's
phenomenal i played him in the grand
swiss recently and it was a really
interesting game um i would say him and
gokesh are maybe the two big hopes right
now but then again niihau sarin is
fantastic at the speed chess
arjun arigaisi broke onto the scene um
in our champions chess tour and he had
some great results recently so
i would say those but i mean i could
list another dozen yeah exactly who
could claim um it all depends on their
focus and their dedication and uh yeah
the world's uh they're ready to take
over and the women as well i mean
obviously our very own tanya
but women in india as well yeah striving
yeah you have some great players you
have a hampi canary she's one of the
highest rated women in the world she's
number three i think and then you have
harika dronivali also another grand
master
like and also they got the silver medal
at the women's world team championship
and just to name some talents that i can
think of also pragananda has a sister
who also plays chess and also incredibly
strong fantastic so uh again
doing very well the indian nation the
great indians but for now it looks like
norway will keep the crown magnus
carlsen is getting close to defending
his title
and will it happen in this game with a
win or
i guess a draw is the least like is the
you know a win for jan is the least
likely in this game
yeah that we can probably rule out
completely
there's a complete hallucination or
unless maybe magnus forgets to make his
40th move uh in the next six seven
minutes
yeah but it kind of it happened to me
actually once uh really yeah it happened
in in vikings waikanse in this
tournament i was playing in the french
grand master roma eduard and i had
something like six seven minutes
anyway on mu 40 i was thinking thinking
i was because i had a couple of
different ways to force a draw i was
thinking which one is more accurate
thinking and at some point the arbiter
just came
your time is out and i had not even
realized that i was getting low on time
at all
yeah that was a bit uh so it can happen
but i think in a world championship
match you're a bit more observant so
yeah
it's probably more dangerous to have six
or seven minutes rather than two minutes
on the clock because two minutes you
keep your vigilance exactly exactly in
the zone then you think about the clock
but eight nine minutes the minus now has
then it's more like oh i can think
slightly
especially when you're in the flow like
you say absorbed by all those variations
you just don't notice the clock i mean
lots of times i've been thinking and
then i look over oh gosh i thought for
20 minutes you know how that happened
there is actually another story which is
even weirder with the uh
former world champion vessel in topolob
he had a game he was thinking and at
some point he looked at the clock he saw
lots of zeros so he just banged out the
move oh no and then he realized he had
one hour it was like
it was going below one hour he thought
he was running out of time
and was it a bad move he made then
this i don't really recall unfortunately
but
i remember the the series and the
explanation
liking in cross-country you know a very
big norwegian sport they will be going
on their skis round after round and
sometimes they forget that you know
there there's maybe two rounds left and
they start to sprint and they go over
the finish line and they're completely
out of breath but they have to go two
more rounds has anyone ever gone too
many loops ooh
surely someone will step in and say you
can chill yeah well there's this
intervention right you're not allowed to
if they finish the race already yeah
because i think you you loop you loop
and you do a lap and then then you make
a dash for the sprint line
exactly you know if it's the finish of
the race then they start sprinting yeah
right but um either way
i doubt magnus will lose on time
it's very very unlikely yeah it's more
unlikely that anna pognancy will lose
some time but he probably will lose this
game still is that still how you feel
yes yeah it's getting i think more clear
than now than at the very start of the
of the rook ending uh
he's had to be a bit accurate magnus
he's had to be slightly clever with
where he put the black rook when to push
the black pawns but yeah it looks like
he's getting close now
and uh okay jan retreats his rook one
square
okay just guarding his pawns and note
how he put the rook on this square
rather than the square i showed earlier
on the analysis board in front of the
white pawn because now the white rook if
necessary can drop back down to the
first rank and stop harry from promoting
from making a queen later in the game
so uh maybe a clever choice of square
but
it feels a bit
just just instinct-wise it feels like uh
it feels like magnus should be on the
brink here of victory still and is it
about now pushing harry yeah it
certainly looks that way right when in
doubt push her past porn that tends to
be a good endgame strategy yeah an
excellent strategy will the other pawns
sort of follow to defend harry or is it
all about harry now he can go on a solo
run i think it's time to solo
[Laughter]
maybe we can check out what will happen
here magnus does have six minutes he
just needs to make one more move then
he's given an extra hour um so we're
talking about harry let's push the
h-pawn and assuming jan continues with
his plan to check really with the white
king
harry pushing forward even further king
takes pawn and
is it so clear
because now if black steps forward we
see the white rook step back
hmm yeah it's not uh it's not
entrepreneur because black and daddy's
here i can take a pawn but now this pawn
drops and white has hang on no no no
wait it's full
david clever clever is it nasty exactly
deflecting the white rook and after rook
takes rook that's the new queen
and that really is the the key line of
the of the whole ending i think yeah
once you spot that uh you realize that
there is no no more counter play for oh
and here it comes it will come most
probably okay it's move41 but the
players are still picking up the speed
and as mentioned after king to c6 black
is going to push this pawn we will see
this type of race happen white's rook
will step back and after black plays
rook takes pawn white cannot take this
because the root gets deflected and if
you cannot take it then
what else yeah that's what's the only
source of counterplay for for white if
you have to step to the side then black
can even just go and gobble up another
pawn black can maybe remove the counter
play this way yeah there is even no
threat because you can also not take it
on the next move yeah so bruce say spawn
again king takes pawn loses to this rook
check and then that makes a new queen
so for example if black goes after harry
then i think he could just step back
sorry if white goes after harry you can
step back and yeah too many pawns are
dropping
black will have a couple of extra pawns
at the end is this an expression close
but no cigar um
nodding i'm not sure how close though in
this case uh maybe you're only one move
away i mean if you had this position
with black's pawn back one square
then you'd be optimistic about picking
up these guys this could be quite clear
and uh
okay unfortunately it's not quite
working and every tempo is important yes
we're about to see this position king
takes pawn this game will end now within
within minutes all right well let's get
the picture of the two players up
here
it's mine okay minus leaves
it's not ready to defend its title
just to enjoy it a little bit more
that's right i guessed 42 moves in the
prediction challenge so i was wrong
we're getting some points maybe people
suggest 41 moves yeah because you get
more time you have some more time to
think about the situation and then
usually you resign and it's been correct
in quite a few games i think in the
match i think 41 40 43 has happened a
couple of times i think in the match 22
yeah i've guessed 42 the meaning of life
it's a good number for me i started
gaining a lot more points when i started
guessing 42.
before i was guessing 35. i was like 47.
i thought 50 must be a good number i
still want to know if anyone guessed 136
of the match
or even gained any sort of points yeah
in
the 136.
yeah it's also not great for him to say
he leaves the board that i would also
leave the border
to sit there and wait for magnus to come
back is uh
yeah
is it mean of magnus right now to leave
the board and hold this off no no no
no
you normally do this after move 40
because that's the time when
um you need to just kind of step up from
the board
go to the restroom and
just get fresh i keep forgetting that
chess players are normal people
only some of
us
and here he comes
magnus carlsen world champion
about to defend his title but he is not
staying for long two empty chairs at the
venue in dubai
but uh
it looks a bit funny yeah right do you
think he will resign on the next move or
um
no i think he'll play a little bit
longer
but
i think he will respect i think he will
he will take the pawn and he will resign
i think because what
yeah
what else can you do i mean
maybe white could take the pawn and then
allow the check and then you're fine
so you guys are predicting maximum of
one to two more moves i predict
resignation of on the next move by young
what do you predict
just because he's played on a bit in the
past i mean for example when he blunted
his bishop
a couple of games ago
yeah but this is much more lost than the
game in which he blunted his bishop yeah
probably equally lost but much more
straightforward yeah
yeah no yeah i think
let's say you would score less points
from this position than in that other
one
but we will see
how to disagree yeah we are wondering
then if this next move by minus will be
the last move of the 2021 v-day world
championship match
and he's taking some some minutes anyway
yeah
again very professional why not exactly
he has more than one hour on his clock
so
the most obvious move in the position is
also the strongest move most likely just
using the black rook to take a pawn with
check
and
yeah he'll play it within another minute
or so
but just
just looking over the variations
i always do that if i have a winning
move i just okay 100 sure i'm not
walking into a check i'm not losing
material not
uh not allowing any tricks
and
once he's
confident about that magnus will take
that pawn ah what else no no no you're
right but i think i'm changing my mind
now that i'm thinking about it i think
he will make a few more moves yeah
because he will
take the pawn he will move the king
and then he will attack the pawn the h
pawn harry yep
and then he will resign after that
probably but he will do that first
yeah but it's the final game you know
it's the final game of the world
championship match does he string it out
yeah
i don't think you resign if you're just
one pawn down in a rook end game there's
always chances no
i mean even the line we showed that is
winning for black
i mean you can still play on a few more
moves
yeah maybe
no i think he will he will try it like
until this
is also his other pawn yeah yep okay one
point down
for now yeah yeah he will soon v2 and
the key trick as we mentioned is white
cannot take that black pawn because you
walk into a rook check
i think you'll play on a few more moves
as well uh wow i did not expect him to
take it
black is now going to give a check with
the black rook
he keeps playing animation i think we'll
see him play on in this end game we're
going to see a situation where black has
a queen versus a rook and a pawn and
white still has this pawn now alice the
a pawn
running up the board
or ahri as simon calls her aaron
arrow
arie and harry yeah
okay so that's the check
the white rook is deflected
and black is going to make a new queen
okay harry becomes harriet
queen harriet yes
and how nice that we uh we haven't
almost seen it in the match right a new
queen on the board motion
here he comes
that is beautiful
and uh jan is banking everything on this
pawn now alice um it's gonna be hard to
promote her
black's queen is gonna retreat
centralized most likely and then black
can always give some checks
the white rook doesn't have too many
stable squares white's rook is defending
some pawns right now but it's going to
get kicked away from that post
then some of those pawns might well drop
i think this is the best practical
decision yeah yeah sure sure
yeah but it's not also
not a very good one yeah i mean it's the
best of a bad bunch yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i admire like i appreciate the fact
he's playing on yeah because now we'll
learn something about queen versus rook
positions
do you think
magnus can afford to get greedy
and uh
have the time to hunt down one pawn i
think so yeah that's what i would do i
think he would probably attack the rook
yes once the rook moves he will attack
the pawn
so the most magnus move right now would
be to retreat the black queen to the
center of the ball to the d5 square yes
attack the white rook from there and
he just loves his centralized queens but
all all queen moves are very reasonable
here actually
like at least three along the diagonal
but also just hitting hitting the rook
from from behind this
uh
yeah it's possible as well but is mine
is now making a long-term plan
or is it a few moves at a time no a few
moves at the time yeah he knows long
term he's winning as long as he stops
the white pawn from running too far up
the hood
and also as long as he makes a move that
doesn't let
jan push his pawn
queen e4 nice i was just about to say
this maybe
yeah
now there's a big big threat of the
queen retreating two squares up to the
sixth rank checking the white king from
the side and hitting the white rook at
the same time
and that white rook is not anchored it's
not supported yeah now you have to give
up something yeah
yeah if the white rook moves off the
third rank then all the pawns drop
yes
yeah
beautiful technique
centralized queens you see it all the
time
do you think we're going to see a
handshake now
you're impatient ivanka very impatient
i've been asking for every move since
move 23
no but i mean it's very difficult for
the rook the rick cannot stay on the
third row
so
okay he will maybe move the king yeah
i think
yeah the problem is
diagonally up i would say yeah
maybe we can look just to show the
threat
so black's queen has jumped back the
threat is this one to check and to hit
the white rook at the same time so for
example if white pushes the pawn the
rook drops next
so nils you're expecting okay me and my
arrows there you're expecting the rook
not to move because it does shuffle
across the third round if there's not
that square
there's always a check and a double
attack
and if you can't stay on the third round
to protect your pawn
i mean this is an admission of defeat
okay he's played it just as i say it
come on oh no he hasn't played it he has
gone for your move neil then the queen
can slide across to the a4 square and oh
no but there's a check
let's say and then he pushes the ball
one step yeah yeah okay sorry he gets
two squares forward then who knows
then anything can happen yeah nothing
can happen one skill step forward is
still sort of uh
not a big issue but uh so when i don't
think the black queen will decentralize
itself maybe we'll see just a check
first
because now if the white king uh if you
block for example your pawn drops um if
you step back there's again this double
attack
and then next move when the rook blocks
this queen captures the pawn and yeah we
have seen that from magnus he's gone for
this position check
and if the white king steps into the
corner then there's a check oh there's
not a check
that's the way to lose the game actually
yes this is the skewer and the queen
drops okay so there must be another way
to win this pawn maybe not immediately
but actually this is a position this is
how they play yeah the one trick i fell
into it will magnus fall into it with
the check
looks like it wins but no
um this actually loses for black i guess
instead of this maybe just stop the pawn
from moving yes move the queen one step
up probably this way hit the rook hit
steal the pawn in the center of the
board and stop the pawn from moving
forward
that's simply a bit too much
this looks like game over
yeah if we if we see this move it's just
the end too many threats this could be
the end uh this one and the nasty check
picking up white's pride and joy if this
pawn drops yeah it's just immediately
but also if if the other two pawns drop
then that's also immediately over so
white rook too stretched yeah
magnus definitely looks focused he looks
like he is definitely in the moment and
looking for the final moves in this game
and in the match
yep and he knows it's just one or two
moves away now wow look at the
evaluation bar plus 14.7 sometimes we
say don't trust it even if it's plus
three or plus four but here i think it's
uh it's very very trustworthy
yeah it's not a plus 100 yet so there's
no checkmate but
no plus 14 years but hang on a second
it's almost better
black mates in 28 according to sessions
in 2018 yeah
and here comes the move from magnus oh
that is uh
that is calm that is also very calm and
very nice yeah and and again following
the line of black mating in 2018. it's
the best movie do you think magnus has
calculated the forced mate in 28.
[Music]
at least now he's threatening my move
which was previously a blunder black's
queen going up to the d8 square checking
the white king and hitting the
whiteboard because now the white rook
when it comes up it won't be attacking
the black king the 8th flank very
sensible then to get the king out of
there it's also
a sort of move which typically forces
resignation as well because you're sort
of emphasizing the hopelessness of
of the situation even if white gets an
extra move for free still yeah it
doesn't help you so why are you even
playing on yeah that's the argument
white can't even push the pawn forward
right exactly queen steps up and attacks
the rook and the pawn i think this is
the final thing we'll need to show today
yeah um the white pawn if it does step
forward is close now to getting to a
second goal but now yeah as you might
mentioned double attack the only way to
stop this is by uh bringing the white
rook across but now after a check viking
steps back and this check finally does
win the hopeless the helpless white rook
and hopeless yeah agree
okay we see the white rook go up but now
the other pawns and central pawns drop
from white yeah not only does the pawn
drop but you still cannot push your a
pawn
i mean
it's yeah it's gone it's the same
technique as they say wow yeah and not
very
challenging technique yeah
yeah yeah here comes the move from
magnus and what will jan do okay he
didn't
and he finishes it magnus carlsen he
wins game 11. he defends his title the
norwegian winning his fifth world
championship match let's hear what the
players are saying
what
point so this time
yeah but in general
has taken his chances he has grown
endurance
and has been unbeatable fiona pomnyacci
after 11 games in dubai you guys it's
over magnus carlsen he keeps his crown
let's go down to dubai
all right i i think i did hear some
applause from dubai magnus carl isn't he
i haven't even seen a smile on his face
yeah magnus i'm sure we'll see him smile
in a moment just uh collecting his
thoughts maybe letting the moment sink
in and what a moment his fifth victory
in a world championship match wow magnus
carlsen it's over after
11 games
and uh now let's go down to dubai to
hear from the people closest to the
world champion
yes what a historic moment here with us
we have the father you must be a pretty
proud dad what do you have to say in
this historic moment
yeah he's become quite a decent chess
player
so you think he is playing
okay by now
yeah i mean
i'm not complaining and uh
today i thought
you shouldn't play for a draw you should
always play for a win
so with black against john the
partnership play for a win how do you
feel right now i'm joking by the way i
think miners would have been more than
happy with the draw of course
but we knew that scenario could uh could
arise because jan
he probably realistically had to take
risks today
because the draw then is too close to
the
to the to the limit basically
and of course a lot of people coming
over to and congratulate you you just
made this huge if you could just
pan out here to see the the vibe
so do you feel the support of all your
friends here and the norwegian people
well i mean we know this is covered a
lot in norway a lot of people are
following and that's of course
extremely important for us as norwegians
so
i'm glad that magnus
managed to win and
it's time for celebration
time for celebration there you have it
and magnus is now tying his favorite
world champion other than himself three
years ago of course cabo blanca being
the only world champion to win a match
with four wins 2-0 uh cabo blanca beat
laska in that way a long time ago thank
you
thank you so much and big
congratulations to henry carlson and
everyone close to magnus carlsen he
keeps his crown the fifth match he plays
he is still world champion after
dominating this match against jana
pognac and we are of course waiting for
reactions from dubai from the world
champion himself i think he's doing an
interview in norwegian right now but as
soon as he is already with uh tanya we
will head
down there do you think he is a little
bit surprised david that is over today
um relieved uh delighted i'm not sure
how he'll be feeling but either way it's
a huge achievement and well deserved
yeah i mean he's he was calm he was
cold-blooded and he took a chances when
they came yeah
all right and well
simon you're standing there with the
current world champion behind you this
is celebrations from the chess 24 lounge
we do see uh espanagestein was there we
did see henry carlson
some very happy people in this lounge
with magnus carlson defending his title
how much has he impressed you simon
throughout this match uh very impressive
um i think it is now time to celebrate
for him uh forget about all the chess
enjoy yourself and uh i wonder how he's
gonna celebrate and i i are you gonna
celebrate now everyone or now the
commentaries over not necessarily like
you know for magnus but you know just
celebrate we need some bubbles do you
think i think so i think so so yeah but
it's a relief because it's so much
pressure uh being in this situation of
playing uh the tension that people just
is so hard to comprehend like uh imagine
doing an exam a really important exam
every day for a number of days and that
stress you need to get out the system
and lots of happy people there which is
uh which is great to see yeah we did see
ellen his sister with her baby as well
everyone's celebrating and now let's
hear from the world champion
magnus congratulations on becoming world
champion joy relief shy of first
feelings
no i'm
relieved of course
and
you know it's hard to uh
it's hard to
feel that great joy when
there was the situation was so
comfortable
to begin with but um you know i'm
happy with uh
with a very good performance overall
you put pressure on you and you provoked
him to make mistakes four decisive wins
we know you're quite critical of
yourself but this match that must be
pretty hard to do
um
sure so you can point at
things you could have done differently
in every game of course
but
overall overall i'm happy with my my
play very proud of my effort in the in
the sixth game uh and that sort of laid
the foundation
for um for everything um
because um you know the the the match is
probably the final score is probably a
bit a bit more lopsided than
uh it could have been but
that's the way i think um some of the
other matches also could have gone if
i've gotten an uh
if i gotten a lead
magnus this is your fifth title where
does it rank amongst all your world
championship quick trees
no it's hard to say the last one is
always in in a way um
the
the sweetest but i'm just happy to have
one and finally i remember chennai the
first time you became the world champion
you were thrown into the swimming pool
what's the plan for tonight for
celebrations
uh i'm focused on the game
all right congrats
that was magnus carlsen uh happy
relieved about finishing the match now
after only 11 games we did see the
lounge with his close friends and family
celebrate what's going on in the
wherever in the world the seconds are
right now nils no they are of course
very very happy yeah like uh
it's uh
no it's a great feeling but it's also
like when you work with the world's best
player it's also
yeah it's likely to happen of course
but they should be uh probably quite
content with the work they they did like
he experienced very few opening problems
he put some pressure in a few of the
games so
uh no they are very happy and they are
for sure now celebrating i don't know
what time it is there but uh
yeah for sure yeah very happy yeah and
uh i guess it's a little bit down to
blunders brianna pogbachie that magnus
has been able to defend his title after
uh 11 games and it also happened now in
this final game david so should we take
a look at what happened here yeah uh
it's a bit inexplicable in a way it's
hard to kind of um read between the
lines here and kind of explain why anna
pomnechi went for this move pawn to g3
in this position he could simply capture
the black pawn in the center he could
capture it with his pawn or with the
rook and he would hold the balance an
equal game may be a draw but at least he
would live to fight until tomorrow
instead he did fatally open up his king
he pushed this pawn forward allowing his
knight to be captured and despite
winning the black rook after queen takes
pawn it was inevitable at this moment
that magnus would win the world
championship the white king was simply
too open and despite the fact here that
maybe magnus didn't find the clearest
the cleanest part of the victory
uh we did see him eventually win the
game he gave a check brought his knight
into the game and later on after lots of
exchanges he nicely converted a rook in
game bizarre blunder there by
yandaponnichi but then again magnus took
his chance when he came wow what has
impressed you the most with magnets
during this match uh nils
and not the stableness that i mean so
few bad positions in so many games and
that's uh that's very impressive yeah
how about you yomanko
i have to say exactly the same you know
how he's responded to everything with
calm and with confidence every single
opening surprise that jan and pommy
actually had repaired it seemed like
magnus had kind of figured it out and
prepared his own surprises and of course
the resourcefulness and the willingness
to fight willingness to fight and i must
say when he was given the chance he was
precise until the very end i mean what a
fantastic
achievement by the five-time world
champion yeah all right we're gonna go
down to dubai what are the reactions
tanya after mine is now defends his
title
magnus is at the world champion one more
time this is his fifth world
championship title and he's done it in
style in just 11 games kaya as we see so
many people around here uh waiting for
the press conference and of course this
is such a big moment i don't think any
of us could have expected the match to
shape the way it did i've got with me
hans hans what impressed you the most
about magnus in this world championship
match i think he took every single
opportunity he had
in game six this was clearly the
critical moment he was on the defensive
in this game i think you can ignore the
entire match and just look at this one
moment in this one game
magnus was given one opportunity he took
it he took full advantage and the rest
was history right he totally collapsed
but
the craziest thing about this match is
that if in games if one move changed if
john played one different move in game
six nothing none of this would have
happened i think that's the most that's
the craziest thing and what's so brutal
about a world championship match
absolutely and do you think it all just
comes down to that one game six that you
mentioned and we've never seen that in
the history of matches that
one game decides the outcome of the
entire match not even one game it's one
move it's it's it's a series one it's
ridiculous that one mistake can can can
change the entire history of chess it's
like a butterfly effect
absolutely thank you so much hans and we
can see there's such a big crowd here
guys what did you think about today's
game and the match and all
it was a thrilling experience i mean we
are just so feeling lucky that we could
witness that last move you know which
was decider totally game changer and you
were inside what was the feeling inside
the auditorium the feeling was great uh
i feel sorry for nepo you know we came
all the way from india to watch the
matches and i hope this is the end of
the tournament and you know we couldn't
see more matches so it's pretty sad but
then good for the magnus and uh he keeps
his world championship intact thank you
what about you did you enjoy watching
magnus play today uh yeah a lot
all right thank you so much and i wanted
to see the best of magnus and if you
want to get the best of magnus you need
weapo to nepo to win
and this what didn't happen yes so
that's what i was looking for that nepal
wins i'm sorry for this no you're
absolutely right and i think uh this
match of course uh we know what yana
pronouncing is capable of and we all
can't wait to see him back on the board
but this is magnus carlson's moment as
he becomes the world champion for the
fifth time oh fantastic thank you so
much tanya and we're gonna go also too
understanding with more of the people
that
obviously this means a lot to
absolutely maybe one of the unsung
heroes because is it true that magnus
actually learned just because he wanted
to beat you ellen carlson bigger sister
of magnus
well it's of course a great time to take
credits
and yeah that's one of their favorite
stories is how magnus wanted to beat me
when we were kids and that that was his
first motivator to learn chess yeah and
did he manage to ever beat you yeah
unfortunately he did so uh when he was
practicing for his first tournament yeah
he won a game against me and uh
i quit playing after that
[Laughter]
okay and as an older sister how do you
feel right now are you proud
i'm of course very proud uh it's always
really nice to see magnus perform at his
best and you know he spends so much time
preparing for this and it's
nerve-wracking on the way especially the
first games we were like really tense uh
how will this end but uh
now he got it quite easily in the end so
i'm very happy for him yeah and you know
him better than almost anybody how do
you think he feels right now i think
he's very relieved that he was able to
win this match in the end and also very
happy i mean he loves winning games and
he got a lot of one games here so that's
an added bonus for him yeah thank you so
much jalen carlson there you have it
magnus cast apparently loves to win
games maybe that's why he does it all
the time thank you so much
thank you to both of you big
congratulations to ellen of course and
the entire
magnus carlton family who must be
thrilled right now and uh simon can you
imagine what it's like to be a member of
the magnus carlson family today i think
relief is the first thing because
everyone's like being there through
distress so they can just chill get the
champagne out enjoy themselves um it's
been brilliant um watching especially
being on the chair there watching game
six and that was as han said the the key
moment of the match this a long long
game which was up and down and i think
yan he missed his chance in that game
bishop b2 and i think uh the rumors that
jan maybe couldn't recover from such a
bad loss they that unfortunately came
came true in the end and um i think uh
you know the other issue that jan maybe
had in this match was he was trying to
play magnus at his own game he was
trying to play long positional games
which of course he's very capable of but
magnus is the king
and the king can now celebrate uh as as
we probably uh will do as well so very
good match in the end and he's been a
world champion for eight years how long
will he uh he stayed the 16th world
champion without anyone taking the 17th
world champion title you think well i
mean uh how long's a piece of string uh
in magnus's case probably very long and
um i think the next world championships
is going to be fascinating people
talking about some of the contenders
which could come up we've we've
mentioned eurasia farouza which is
obviously the main name but there's many
many others will he keep his motivation
up uh well i think he's he's a born
winner and a born fighter so i expect so
so uh yeah it's going to be great to see
what happens in the future yeah
and in the very near future there's
going to be a press conference in dubai
to hear from both of the players we are
waiting for that so while we do that
let's have a quick commercial break
[Applause]
today
more than ever when the world comes
together to create a better tomorrow
it's going to be
larger
[Music]
magic with music with architecture with
colors magic with celebration with your
safety
from here there and everywhere for six
whole months day and night join the
making of a new world starting october
1st
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the new chess 24 playing
experience play in light mode or dark
mode choose from a range of time
controls or create a custom game and get
paired with players from around the
world fast
enjoy a polished playing experience
while making moves on a fresh responsive
board to claim your victories train and
improve with over eighty thousand
puzzles and that's not all
download now and discover what more you
can enjoy in our brand new app
this is john
john loves to study chess
this is david
david loves to study chess as well but
efficiently
john spends more time setting up the
board and figuring out what's on the
page of his books and he gets to study
david likes to take it easy
and use his time wisely
david has finished his exercise for
today
john should try the same
[Music]
now anyone can learn and improve their
chess skills with the world champion
magnus carlson
[Music]
the magnus trainer app is packed with
fun mini games in interactive training
content
playable anytime anywhere get the magnus
trainer available in the app store and
google play
[Applause]
welcome back everyone to chess 24 global
uh this is the last uh show from the
world championship match because magnus
carlsen has decided the match after 11
games he defends his title and is still
world chess
champion what a performance after 11
games we talked a little bit about it
and david do you agree with the market
that you would have been very shocked if
we would have said it would take 11
games yep
especially after the first half of this
event after the first five rounds i
thought there was no chance i thought it
was gonna go down to the wire maybe even
jan having some chances along the way
but it all came down to that game six as
the decided the turning point we'll look
back at that one game that marathon
eight-hour battle as uh the moment that
actually magnus clinched it
unfortunately jan was unable to fight
back yeah
and
the press conference in dubai will be
starting shortly and i can see a bunch
of
celebration tweets for magnus is coming
in yeah i am just having a look and
there's been a huge outpouring of
celebration on twitter everyone ecstatic
that magnus carlsen is the champion and
of course everyone is also
very sad but also very happy for janna
ponochi because he did play fighting
chess and there is that kind of moment
that david says that game six you know
it broke a lot of records but it also
broke nobody actually
yeah and at least he went down fighting
he played some really interesting chess
towards the end and
despite the few mistakes he will emerge
with a lot of credit
and maurice actually is sitting ready
waiting for the two players to arrive
i have to say you didn't you know magnus
didn't seem that happy
in the interview and after the game you
didn't see you know his hands in the air
you didn't see any sort of celebration
do you think he's a little bit tired
well i think he's he was still in like
full focus mode like he's still in in
the model playing where you are not
really thinking about celebrations and
stuff you're just thinking about the
next move and it takes some time before
you go you can switch off yeah
so we will see at the press conferences
if it's already time for that yeah
what is this moment like for yana
pognatchi is he just relieved now it's
over
um possibly he'll be heartbroken for a
while it's going to be hard to recover
but
uh your rank mentioned a bit earlier
today
i think he'll come back stronger
for the next few months it might be
difficult psychologically but eventually
he will be better as a chess player
because of this experience
i mean the preparation he must have done
that will come in useful and for sure
he'll he'll be back and here they are
the two players the world champion and
the challenger let's go ba down to dubai
thank you everyone welcome to this press
conference post game interview
i would like to remind the reporters
when you ask your questions to make sure
you keep your mask on and do not
touch the microphone at all
photographers
you
can take photographs but stay at the
sides of the room
first of all magnus let me say
congratulations on winning your fifth
title
your immediate feelings right after the
match has concluded
um no i'm
very happy of course i didn't
didn't expect it to um
to go quite like this
[Music]
um i think it was just um very good
professional performance overall um
and um yeah i've uh
um just no regrets at all just very very
satisfied you mentioned you didn't
expect it to go like this would you care
to elaborate
um
i mean
after five games there were five draws
and i'd had very very few chances to
play for anything more um and
then everything kind of
clicked
and
i think
yeah after that
it all went
all went my my way
and
yeah you don't expect to
necessarily
uh run away with it in uh in a world
championship
yan uh must be a difficult match a
moment for you can you share your
thoughts with us please
oh well first of all uh it was a big
experience which
unless i couldn't get um you know
another way in theory yeah like uh
reading some about some another matches
yes so
uh
of course uh
you know
the outcome uh i don't i don't think
it's anywhere close to what it was in
the match but
yeah i mean uh
some some bad news and good news good
news it was nothing about chess of
course
uh at least almost nothing about chess
but uh yeah the match of course consists
of many aspects and
yep and um i mean uh
it's not only not like that chess
preparation physical of psychological
preparation yeah when it comes i mean of
course it's uh it's extremely tense and
uh it's you know a little bit more
chance than i expected but
uh i guess uh anyway
uh you know the tension is not a reason
to
you know overlook some simple things you
would never
ever ever looking in a bliss game but
well
what can i say so i should
find out
why
did it happen and
improve
yeah you mentioned everyone saw that it
was a terrific fight five games even the
sixth game was a tremendous fight but
something seemed to have happened yeah
any any clue as to what caused this
sudden turn
just no idea so if i would uh if i would
knew you know what's going on i would
surely fix it
during the match yeah but
uh i guess
i mean somehow the
level of uh
you know these blunders is
much below even you know some
bad examples of some
bad and pathetic shape so this is you
know quite interesting uh
probably in uh in clinical meaning yeah
so uh well uh anyway yeah i should take
some time to to rest and then uh to see
what
what was uh done wrong
what has been done wrong and what would
gone wrong actually because once again
like chess wise
i mean okay i also found out some
interesting
you know patterns but uh
i don't think it has anything to do or
much to do about the chess
in terms of playing in a world
championship match
lessons learned now that you've had this
first experience
well you know experience
is never easy yes
normally you should to be
i mean the situation should be you know
tough
to gain some real experience okay
i guess it was a little bit too much
here but
i mean okay
so i have uh
i surely will i actually have some you
know some space to to improve and uh
well if perhaps you know solving some
puzzles would would fix it yeah at least
uh
i guess
in the upcoming events i would you know
show some some better performance
is it possible now to start thinking
about the future as the candidates
you're qualified for the candidates and
your desire to return to this exact same
stage
well of course it's possible to think
but for now yeah i guess it would be
more
uh clever more smart to take some time
and have some rest but yeah of course
you know this uh
these things which happened here they
never happened to me
basically any events okay
in my career i lost quite some stupid
games yeah but
you know
not
as many in
you know in such a few times
magnus how do you contextualize this
world championship match
compared to all your others
um
i guess it's
the most similar with
with my first match against anand which
was
quite uh quite even and nervous at this
at the start and when i got my my first
win it
um
it was kind of the same story that it
was
relatively um
clean from from there on out
um
yeah uh what what can i i say um
it's um it was just
um
um yeah obviously um he couldn't at some
point uh
show his his best chess which is um
a pity for you know the excitement in
the in the match but um
yeah i think uh
that's what happens um
sometimes when you get in a difficult
situation then you're
all all of that preparation everything
uh
doesn't necessarily help if you can't go
at the moment
final question before i give it to
the journalists
you said
earlier in a press conference that style
points don't matter
it's all about the win uh were you at
all disappointed that this wasn't more
of
the match that we all expected
no that's fine but uh
um that's why i'm fine by me so uh i
think um
uh game six was was excellent um and um
i mean regardless of um the quality of
all the moves it was uh was a great
fight uh and um
yeah i guess um it just decided
decided everything so um that's
mainly what i'm i'm taking taking away
um from from an excitement
perspective um otherwise
i think
at a certain point
um
you your best strategy can be just to
um
to wait knowing that you have
you have have the lead and just be very
very serious and
and and solid and that can be sometimes
be the best way to
to play for a win as well
open to the floor
mikelandchest.com congratulations magnus
on your fifth world championship match
win uh my question is for you uh when i
talked to john backstage he said that he
was a little bit surprised by the style
of your play i believe the word used was
conservative do you agree that this was
your style of play and if so was it
cognizant to play that way or was it
organic based on the positions that you
were given
i think a bit of both uh i definitely
played a lot more conservatively as as
black than i did in the match against
in the match against fabi um
with
white um i wouldn't necessarily say that
i was that
conservative
i was at least
trying some some different lines trying
to
uh trying to play
but
yeah you can see overall in
a lot of my my decisions um
when push came to shove skewed
conservative and i think
um
you know with uh without inside it
worked pretty well
all right um
giovanni tavara from the white house
club first of all congratulations to
both players and magnus congratulations
for bringing title uh question for
magnus
magnus here in uh um in a unique
situation where you won the
you claim your uh grandmaster title in
dubai won the rapid and bits in dubai as
well and perhaps if i'm not mistaken the
first player to win it in the same year
and you even celebrated your birthday
here during the world championships and
now the
world title so what is it about dubai
that seems to bring out the best in you
and
any plans to visit any
fund
places that are memorable like that
mcdonald's very far celebrated in 2004
or maybe even dubai chess club where
your journey as a grand master
officially started
i
i don't know i think
uh it's maybe a bit of a coincidence
that all these things happened uh
happened here um but um
uh yeah in general as i said before it's
um
it's a good place to um to play to play
chess here um
um good good facilities you kind of have
everything as well as um as a decent
climate so yeah um
i've definitely enjoyed
being here um i haven't laid any plans
at all um
after this um
i mean i didn't expect much necessarily
to be over
at this point so um
[Music]
we'll we'll see what happens
uh theo waits for leeches uh thanks to
both players for the intense match they
just played and congratulations to
magnus for defending his title uh magnus
before the match there was a lot of
discussion about the time that you spent
playing uh bulletin blitz matches on
leaches and whether or not it would help
your preparation uh is that just
something that you did for fun or was
there an intentional effort in training
faster time controls before the
match uh i'll tell you about what
basically i had
i had a bit of a cold the last uh
um
the last couple of weeks before
before i
i traveled here and i was
feeling
feeling kind of
miserable so
that's
why i was inside
uh you know blitzing and bulleting
more than
thinking of
preparation but
yeah i think it never
it never particularly hurts to
um
you know to to win some games uh gain
some
some some confidence so
but yeah for me it was more of a
question of
being pretty confined inside and
and
you know having to spend my time in some
way
thanks
peter shaw smith home of jess
uh commiserations ian congratulations
magnus uh on the eve of this contest
magnus
you said that you could live without the
world championship uh when you consider
your incumbency do you think one day
that you'll be able to leave it on your
own terms
or do you believe that one day
you might be left helpless in your seat
as you have left all the other champions
that you've played since 2013. thank you
um yeah thank you uh first of all um
let's um
it's a very good question uh i cannot
answer it right now
diane shabazz with the chest rom this
question is for both players
uh the first five games were drawn and
there were a lot of
there were some complaints uh about the
draws and of course that's a part of the
uh the match
uh but there was also some talk about
different formats we've had the 24 we've
had 12 and now 14.
would
the both of you entertain other
formats uh which would include other
platforms like um 960 rapid and blitz as
part of the world championship
yeah
well uh
i think we shouldn't um
forget that here is the classical world
championship match and i guess uh
it's pretty much uh
that's pretty much it yes so
there is always some space for i don't
know speculations and new tries but in
general
why not to separate like uh things like
playing classical
championship and classical chess at 9 16
960 and you know bleeds and bleeds and
so on
yeah it's
so it's um it's always a difficult uh
question really
i mean i've answered it so many times
before and it's really about
what you want
the world championship to be
whether you want to define
the the best player in the world and
what exactly that
means
um
and how you balance
that
with having an exciting sporting
context and
frankly i don't know
what
the right answer is is
i don't think we have it at the moment
um
that's something i've been
very um
um open about for for for a long time
but um
i'm definitely open for uh for ideas
thank you
um hans trustable first of all
congratulations to magnus um my question
is to yon
in the first five games i was extremely
impressed with your play and i think we
saw a different diane and
my question to you is considering the
candidates in june
how confident are you that you're going
to make it back here
well
more confident and than winning this
match at this point okay yeah but
actually well i mean once again yes so
this match
bring me
some reasons uh you know to be
optimistic yeah in
chess wise but yeah of course uh
you know the big uh weaker spots are
pretty much obvious and uh
you know first i mean if we manage to
understand
what what has happened then i think i'm
i have pretty good chances but you know
if i keep you know playing uh
worse than in bliss then
it would be tough
thank you
mikeline with chess.com my question is
for yon napomnishi we already spoke a
little bit backstage but one thing i did
not get a chance to ask you uh your
final three losses they were all marked
by relatively okay positions and then
they were all pawn move mistakes all
three of them um is there anything to
that is it just a small sample size
obviously there are more pawn moves than
any other moves but do you take any
correlation between that or is it just a
random stat
well uh i mean obvious uh you know
uh
it can be a coincidence then it's like
goes free probably three in a row so
that's pretty obvious uh something is
something is wrong maybe in the process
of thinking or something yeah but uh so
far it worked uh quite nicely for me
and uh i don't think it's uh it's a
reason to change everything uh
starting with the basement
but i mean of course if uh
i mean would it be i don't know some
tension or lack of concentration or
simply you know uh tactical blindness or
something else
but yeah i mean i mean it's uh it's a
big question which is i mean better to
ask yourself not after
you know such performance in
mh but yeah we only once and
so far
i have
you know i have to face the consequences
of uh you know
and to find out what's going on yet but
yeah let's see what uh what i can do
thanks
hanssourbakken nrk question to minus
how much does it cost you emotionally to
perform perform at this level that you
have done and do
um no it's
it's clearly a lot
a lot easier when
um
when the matches
has been
has gone the way that it
it has it's not been
it's not been an emotional rollercoaster
at all uh so i feel like i've been
very um
um
very uh very serious uh
and uh
in in a good mental state uh like there
are there have been a couple of
games where i was a little bit more
nervous than than others especially
before but um i would say um
overall um it's been um
yeah it's been it's been quite
quite fine emotionally thank you
uh congratulations magnus i'm nicholas
beck from often boston in norway um
there's a lot of talk about alireza
fiercia who's very young and already
qualified for the candidates um what are
your thoughts on him as a player and you
think he can be your next challenger
um yeah i was
i have to say i was really really
impressed with uh
with um uh with his performance in in
the grand swiss
uh and um in the european team
championship and um
i would say that motivated me more than
anything else
uh saranan from chess base uh ian tough
luck to you
magnus congratulations the question to
you magnus
in pure chess terms
what do you think were the elements
which
helped you to dominate this match just
pure just terms
it's hard to
hard to say
i think in simple positions i make very
very few mistakes
uh
and
that that helps like both in terms of
tactical and
positional positional things um
and um
the few times that
the position was very complicated
we both made some mistakes but
he made he made the last one so um
i think that was maybe the main
um
the main factor that i was
just playing better and relatively
simple positions but um
we really shouldn't
shouldn't forget the fact that this
match really really turned on
on the sixth um on the sixth game
but i think it goes to show
um that um
in the other matches that have been
really
um
that have been really equal really tense
um they could have ended similarly um if
if things have gone a little bit
differently at the start i think most
notably the
the the match against
the match against karaki
okay and uh in terms of
toughness of fight
from all the matches that you have
played so far the world championship
where will you rate this match
yeah i would say the
the start was
was was difficult very
very tense um
and um not too much was
what's going on uh but um
yeah after that it was certainly um
uh certainly one of the the easier ones
uh in a light vein many other questions
you started answering with
that's an interesting question you heard
the press conferences
did you really mean it or was it a
subtle trolling of the people
no it was never
never ever trolling um
i think it was usually a combination of
trying to buy myself time to think
which is
one of the oldest tricks in the book
and
also
genuine sentiment
thank you
may i request from the
reporters that you ask one question and
if you follow up pertain precisely to
the question that you asked there's a
lot of people online so
let's try to keep it short
norway uh congratulations to amongst
carlson
uh question from magnus um your tweet
tonight was a picture of kobe bryant
so you both have
five titles now so can you can you say
how important he has been for you and
what do you
think of him
oh i didn't didn't know that um
well what can i what can i say um
[Music]
he uh he's a he's a legend he's a legend
of um of the sport uh and
it's
that was an iconic picture uh to
sort of
allude to
excuse me could i ask you about the
tweak you had um
as far as i remember you had a tweet
after searching
two down five to go um what is that
still uh your aim
um
we'll see
hanzoni milligan um questions to magnus
so
considering the results of this match
many spectators might think that you'd
like to face jan again
but i think we've seen him show a
polar level of strength
does the does the strength that jan was
playing in
some parts of the match more worrying to
you as a challenger than another player
like fabiano or ding who is more
consistent but might not have a higher
polarity of strength
no i wouldn't wouldn't wouldn't say so
um jan was playing
well at
the start with
also with excellent um
preparation but uh
i was
i was doing doing okay as well so
um
i think um
we managed to see a high level of
of jan in the in the start of the match
but nothing that would um necessarily
scare me a lot or be
a lot better than
than
other other potential challengers so
based on that would you say jan's
experience in this match makes him more
of a threat in the second match
that's very hypocritical um
but um i think all all experience
if you can learn from it is good so um
i think he has a good chance in the in
the candidates so against anon did you
feel like it was harder in the second
match or do you feel like there was a
big change or
yeah psychologically it was a lot harder
um
because
yeah i was really
really really motivated for the first
first one and
the second one was more about
trying to get a job done thank you
theo wait for leeches i have a question
for both players
could they share anything about the
software such as chess engines or and
hardware as well that they use to help
them prepare for this match
yeah
well i guess
i'm just more or less
more of the same as
everybody yes so surely some stockfish
lila and
you know some
different
you know
uh some difference in jason as well but
uh
you know mainly mainly these two and uh
i guess this is pretty usual because i
mean
frankly speaking um
well at some point you know it goes
only for you know for memorizing that is
i mean
when humans are playing it's not so
important if you memorize the line of uh
i don't know 30 3 400 in january 500 in
japan yes anyway these moves are
good enough
um yeah you can ask me but i don't know
sure
thank you you should probably ask peter
instead sure thank you but i doubt it
will be very forthcoming
[Music]
uh sagar shah from chess base india
congratulations uh to magnus for winning
and and well fought
my question is to both the players uh
could you reveal some of the preparation
uh that was done and the seconds uh on
the team now that the match is over if
possible
well uh i think i have already said that
you know the team is probably
more or less the same as
as it was in uh
in april
uh
so
being given a chance i'd just like to
thank the team for the amazing work and
i apologize literally it didn't result
into something more
impressive
um yeah absolutely for me as well i'd
like to to thank my team for doing an
amazing job
both obviously to um
to peter
who is who is here and
to all of the the others at
different locations
for me it was
uh
yeah i think um
everybody from um
from the last match uh was there except
for uh
for neil scandellos um
sorry nils for checking you there
uh you did a wonderful job in
2000
2016 and 18 though um
and a couple of a couple of new people
as well
[Music]
india congratulations magnus so how are
you going to celebrate this iconic fifth
win
i haven't thought too much about it um
we'll
we'll have to uh have to see um
i'll be uh
celebrating by playing the world rapid
blitz championship as i heard that's
gonna happen um
but um
before that we'll we'll see um but it's
um
uh i don't know but it's a nice problem
to have
[Music]
this one has reached boiling point now
he's just given up a pawn for free he's
still got his pen in his hand he's
trying to figure out what the point is
after 22 minutes the move is on the
board he's finding all his moves so
quickly yeah very impressive i'm also
very surprised by yandere police's last
move he's gone for a queen trade oh he's
retweeted it i think he's missed a great
opportunity there in these world
championship matches you do not
get many chances or three i made that
move with three just over three seconds
left look at the bar what's happening is
magnus winning he's winning the computer
says checkmate in 38. the first decided
game and we hear applause from dubai
there we go the white queen going as
close to the white king as possible
and resignation it's over magnus
crossland is up by two points look at
this you
guys is what happened
did i just touch that piece and then he
made that move hold on that is an
insanely important moment we had a huge
blunder
game nine is over a terrible blunder by
anna pomnyacci
completely different than everything we
expected there this is quite rare jess
yeah he's putting pressure wow we do
have g3s g3 really been played
has chosen to fall on his sword this is
just a blunder and magnus is going to
win
and he finishes it
magnus carlsen he wins game 11. he
defends his title the norwegian winning
his fifth world championship match
congratulations to magnus girls in the
winning winner of the 2021 fiji world
championship match after 11
somewhat thrilling games some blunders
by anna pomnyacci but also some
fantastic play by the world champion and
we will go down to dubai again now to
get some more reactions from the people
close to
where this historical moment happened
today
that is right kaya here we have like you
won't believe the machinery going on
behind the scenes like i'm just mind
blown here we have
two uh extremely important people so
this is uh this is beyond and we have
bread am i saying this correctly so you
are ahead of security is that a is that
a difficult test do we have like
assassin and ninjas just attacking
magnus here is not used to be
back in the old days five
five championships ago
500 what kind of stuff would happen why
why does he need a security supervisor
well he doesn't need it now so i'm not
here as a as a bodyguard
now i'm dealing with
sports and uh um
i'm also his bridge trainer
yeah yeah
and
he's improving okay and and you are also
not here in your usual profession you
used to be his medical you're the chess
doctor like you're an actual doctor
right yeah it's true
i was with him uh the last four uh
matches as the doctor
so now i'm just here as uh his uh his
friend or his uh yeah
like uh on invitation only
can you can you give me a sort of an
idea what is what is your role is it
like he get food poisoning you have to
give him some meds what's going on like
the first time i was in india then we
were a bit worried about food poisoning
actually so that was why i was with him
and
for the other stuff is just
to make sure that he's
healthy and safe and like a security i
guess
you're pretty strong just by yourself
what do you think about the quality of
his chest
this match it's been brilliant actually
it's
iana's made a lot of
mistakes but
magnus has been pressing uh that every
game he should have been pressing so
he's he's done his job really well i
think
thank you so much for those insights
magnus he retains the title of
world's best chess player world champion
uh we also have the the owner of the
title of most amazing hat this is sam
the man from kyrgyzstan hey what's up
man
i am i'm quite happy um so so you are an
international master you are the head of
the of the asian chess federation and
you know magnets from way back so what's
your impression of the match so far
it's a very good match
i am fan of magnus and i am very happy
for him
for his one and i think he is a very
great
champion and he will be champion many
many years and i wish to him and through
his family
uh best wishes
okay so i called you sam the man from
kyrgyzstan can you tell me your like the
actual pronunciation of your name
samethey
i'm not going to attempt that but
for many many years to come you think
you will be championed well jan will
play in the candidates ali reza will
play in the candidates i guess it's uh
it's up to magnus to prove that he will
be a champion for many many years to
come so what do you guys think in the
studio how many years can he keep going
hmm
good question luna i'll bring it to all
of you right away yeah it's hard to say
allerisa furuja might have a few things
too
i mean he'll be challenging in a few
years but then again 31 years old i
don't think it's that old
really i'm hoping magnus can go on for a
while yeah i expect magnus to have his
eye on gary kasparov's record of 20 plus
years
and also you know he wants to be
six-time world champion yeah because
that is where the record stands maybe
seven times nils
yeah i think also it seems very likely
that he will go on yeah it was uh by the
way nice in the press conference you got
some praise from the world champion
so now we know you're not in the team
exactly yeah you chose us over them
right nils i chose to do some commentary
instead yeah no we love it all right
magnus is the winner of the world
championship match but who is the winner
of the magnus nepo prediction challenge
is it david owl he's been on top of the
table for so long
second place david
i'm always the bridesmaid never the
bride
what can i say second place but uh
papatronics deserved it definitely
congratulations uh i see the first
prizes to sign chessboard by minus
carlson so great prize for him but i
really have to say we do have the best
chess experts in the studio ivanka as
well 26. i know i made a little bit of a
late search after i started to be a bit
more conservative but yeah no i mean
what can i say and it's been awesome
participating in this prediction
challenge and very well done to all
those who have uh topped the leaderboard
especially to papatronics impressive
stuff and i'd also like to say that i'm
going to step aside in terms of the
prize so that tom morris and evie can
also get prizes i think just top three
there that is very nice because second
place is aim chess premium for one year
so that was going to you david oh that's
so kind of this deserve it very nice and
third place chess 24 premium for one
year
now you guys we have something quite
special we have a guest joining us
on skype it's sebastian he is uh
working in the play magnus company i
first i want to say congratulations
sebastian on
the the main man in the company magnus
being world champion again
yes absolutely thank you kaya and yeah
couldn't be prouder of magnus
congratulations to magnus for the fifth
win amazing amazing accomplishment and
yeah he's on to to yeah a great track
record
definitely and what has it been like for
you uh in your home to follow the last
game here today
yeah it's been fantastic i mean such
excitement and uh
yeah it's um
i wanted to be in dubai myself but uh i
caught uh
a brief episode of covet um two weeks
ago so i i couldn't i couldn't join
today
but uh yeah i can only imagine um how
they will be celebrating this weekend
yeah definitely and uh we have been
promoting something throughout the whole
match basically and that is the very
cool nft collection of magnus carlsen's
road to goat
and this collection just becomes getting
more special
every day and now you know another
moment in his career what is this
collection all about
yeah so the road to goat um it's about
the the most fascinating moments in the
most emotional moments also in magnus
career um starting from when he was
playing against kasparov
when he basically made himself more and
more known to the world becoming world
champion that famous picture in the pool
um
moments uh with with anand with with
karana with kayaking and um
yeah we we wanted people to be able to
own and collect that for for eternity to
have a piece of chess world history yeah
definitely and um
the how many of them are now out and and
uh ready to be collected
well three have been collected and uh
one is up for auction right now and
there will then be two more i think that
will be dropped and um yeah in addition
to that we we are coming with a very
exciting surprise tomorrow really
oh i'm getting anxious now
where would we go to sort of uh be ready
to see that surprise
so at chesschamps.io where you've
already been going to see that that
magnus wrote to goat collection you
can sign up for the newsletter right now
then you will be amongst the first
tomorrow
to
know what you have to do to become one
of 500 nft owners that we are giving
away to celebrate this world
championship victory by magnus in the
honor of a new partner joining us and
and our nft project
wow okay so free of charge
yes okay
yeah we think
this this whole world is overwhelming to
to for a lot of people it's all new
technology but it is here to stay we're
very convinced of that the whole
metaverse topic is becoming a buzzword
at the moment a huge hype but
with a lasting substance within it and
we just have to help people also to make
their first steps into it so we are
going ahead and paying for that
ourselves 500 people will get that and
we hope it's all viewers of this
broadcast oh that's so cool okay wow now
of course we have been talking about
nfts for some uh you know while now
these online basically collectibles that
you can start collecting why is
the play magnus group going into this
why is chess going into this
so it's it's been
taking all all major sports by storm
starting with the nba and going
into football into baseball
uh everything is everything has joined
basically several esports and we we want
to be the most innovative company in the
chess world um we've built an amazing
group here around magnus and um yeah we
think if you want to be the innovation
leader you have to step into new trends
as they arise and take risks just like
on the chessboard sometimes you have to
be the moment to be conservative there
are moments to press and yeah if you
want to lead you always have to keep the
pressure on and that's what you're doing
by innovating in this nft space and
creating hopefully some nice values some
nice memories some some nice collections
for all of the fans out there yeah i
like that both about value but also
about collecting great memories so all
happening tomorrow then the big surprise
prize on chess champs dot io am i
correct exactly yeah all right good now
sign up for the newsletter
perfect
that's what everyone should do thank you
so much sebastian for joining us from
your home
thank you for doing such a great job
thank you so much
all right that's what we all have to do
tomorrow then because there won't be any
world championship games going on it's
over after 11 games and you can now
collect nfts from magnus carlsen's great
career
we've asked you guys throughout the
whole world championship match to share
your selfies i wonder if there's any
celebration selfies out there right now
let's check
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so nice to see you all celebrating
around the world and here is uh the
final results you guys from the video
world chess championship 2021 magnus
carlsen he won a marathon game in game
six the longest game in world
championship history and then he
followed up with another couple of
wins
um to end up on seven and a half points
and uh that was the end of the match
after
11 games so yeah david what has been the
highlight for you
the past what is it two and a half weeks
i mean we touched upon it that game six
just being here being in the studio
getting front row seats to that marathon
game i know we were in the studio for
nearly nine hours but it was thrilling
and i don't think i've ever felt more
energized by chess it was i'll look back
on that for the rest of my career with a
lot of pride yeah ivanka what has it
been like to cover an entire world chess
championship match from a studio to
follow every single move every single
reaction the happiness and the
frustration from the players
it's been a bit of a whirlwind you know
i it's so much energy out there you know
people cheering for nabomiyashi people
cheering for magnus people trying to
understand exactly what they were going
to do over the board and try to
understand their moves so it's certainly
been the biggest experience of my life i
mean i can say i've been on tanter hooks
just wait watching and just expecting
every single moment and i've been
surprised all along the way and i have
to say big thank you to everyone out
there for their massive support
and also for joining in the fun the
conversation it wouldn't have been the
same without the definite home a big
thank you to everyone for watching and
nails for you first world championship
match in quite a few years that you
haven't worked on that you have
been watching maybe as a fan what has
that been like
it has been super exciting of course
yeah it's uh it was great to watch the
match
especially the first hulk when it was
still very very tense i mean the games
especially as they would say game six i
mean it's it was simply simply so
exciting yeah what's coming up for you
now next uh goals in your chess career
well potentially now world rapid and
blitz i haven't decided yet but
otherwise it's my kansai in january
where i think magnus is playing as he
usually does right yeah exactly so
that's the next big thing for me
and then the next big thing after that
will of course be the second season of
the mel tortor champions chess store
starting in february 2022 here is some
highlights from the very first season of
that
the meltwater champions chess tour 2021
was a great success 90 days of online
chess with the world's most exciting
players more than 100 million live views
and here are some highlights from the
season
hikaru just laughing intensely from
magnus's it's sort of opening choice i
love this i mean even with a quick draw
we find the humor in that magnus started
well started the joke he played an
opening known as the bong cloud
actually this move don't try it at home
it's probably the worst move on the
board this game is going to be over very
shortly and level running he resigns
timor rajavo the winner of the first
major in the champions chester
it's
he has beaten the world champion magnus
carlsen is out it's going to be good
night for napolita unless he whips up
some miraculous counter play here
he's won the tournament anit giri is the
winner of the magnus carlsen
invitational huge congratulations
it doesn't look like he's just missed
the key moments he's taking his foot off
the pedal and suddenly in the current
position wesley so he's defending
everything and wesley makes the draw
wesley
is the winner of the oprah euro rapid
game it's big it's totally unexpected
he's going to lose on the clock wesley
if he doesn't lose on the board he still
needs to save it on the board especially
after that last move white's for it
getting active magnus wins wow look at
that magnus carlton in armageddon
absolutely insane i i'm just so happy
to
have pulled through
[Music]
he's won his first game history in the
making everyone 12 year old avi monyo
mishra he's number 612 in the world he's
beating number 21.
yeah it was it was amazing
and okay nakamura playing a defensive
move nakamura offers a draw with that
move and magnus accepts magnus wins the
tournament magnus carlsen is the winner
of the new in chess classic wesley so
he's about to resign he's about to drop
into fourth place in the tour standings
after a great year for him there we go
we have a result ah there it is the
final game and the final win for magnus
carlsen in the 2021 season what a
performance it's been by the world
champion the funny part is
the last game really looked like a
fisher fish random game i think
i don't think i ever beat from wesleyan
fish random before so i'll count that
[Music]
thank you to everyone for a great year
of online chess we can't wait for the
new season it starts february 2022
[Music]
yeah we will be back in uh not too long
you guys and what a year it's been for
minus carlson world champion again
defending his title and winning the
first season yeah it's been a roller
coaster it didn't start off easy for him
he had a bit of a rocky few months but
he did show that uh cream does rise to
the top and uh it's been a great few
months for him it's been a great few
months it's been a great few weeks
covering the world chess championship
match again we want to say thank you so
much to everyone at home for following
for cheering us on for cheering the two
players on and for watching big thank
you to nils for being in the studio with
us today pleasure pleasure very very
nice to have you here and
we hope everyone keeps following in
chess keeps playing chess and that you
will be back for uh season two of the
mouthwater champions chess tour
and now i really guess it is time to say
dubai or goodbye to everyone thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you